GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO THE
JOINT INFORMATIONAL HEARING
HOSTED BY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
FOUR ON STATE ADMINISTRATION IN
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE BY MIKE IS ON.
YES IT IS OKAY GREAT I HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP INSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. TODAY
WE ARE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- TO
PERHAPS IF I MAY TAKE A MOMENT
A PRIVILEGE TO MY FELLOW
COLLEAGUES ONE OF THE LAST
HEARINGS THAT WE WILL HAVE. A
IN THIS ROOM BEFORE WE MOVE TO
THE NEW BUILDING. WE ARE HAVING
A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING. WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS OF
MINIMAL CONTENT IN A STAFF AND
ARE LIMITED TO A NUMBER OF
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN.
KEEP SAFE DISTANCE THING THERE
ARE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
RESTATE THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT
BEGINS BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WISHES TO
SPEAK. THEY WILL RAISE THEIR
HANDS AND I WILL ASK THEM TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. I
WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC
RESPECT PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE YOU
WILL HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT IS DONE OR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT BUT PLEASE ABSORB.
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITED ELEVATOR USED TO TWO
PEOPLE AT A TIME. THE PANEL IS
ON THE AGENDA AND ELLIE- ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. THE STATE AUDITOR
AND HER STAFF ARE JOINING US
HERE IN THIS ROOM. WELCOME WE
ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE END OF THIS HEARING BOTH IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD ALSO BE ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE WTCHING
OVER THE INTERNET. THE PHONE
NUMBER IS TOLL FREE. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR. TWO ZERO TWO. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
NINE. IN A STAFF MEMBER WILL
ASSIST YOU. TODAY'S HEARING AS
A JOINT COMMITTEE HEARING WITH
AS MENTIONED BUDGETS OF FOREIGN
STATE ADMINISTRATION AN
ASSEMBLY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
REVIEW CHAIRED BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN
CUDDY PETRIE-NORRIS. RELATING
TO UPDATES WITH. AND REFORMS TO
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. ADDITIONALLY WE
WELCOME THE CHAIRS OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUDY SALAS AND
SENATOR JOHN LAYERED. AND I
RESPECTED MEMBERS IN ATTENDANCE
TODAY. THE CONCERNS OVER THE
DEPARTMENT'S HANDLING OF
UNEMPLOYMENT AND DISABILITY
INSURANCE DURING THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES ARE VERY.
WELL DOCUMENTED. FEW ISSUES
MATTER MRE TO CALIFORNIANS
THAN A PROPERLY FUNCTION EDT.
IN THESE TIMES OF ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY MANY FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE RELY ON
TIMELY UNEMPLOYMENT PAYMENTS TO
KEEP A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD AND
FOOD ON THEIR FAMILY'S TABLE.
THE PANDEMIC HAS CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATED. THAT SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS LIKE EDT HAVEN'T
NEEDED LONG OVERDUE STRUCTURAL
REFORMS THIS IS THE FIFTH
HEARING. ON EDT. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE AS MANY
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THE
DEPARTMENT IS ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE. NO
CALIFORNIANS HAVE TO FALL
THROUGH THE GAPING HOLES OF A
SAFETY NET DESIGNED. FOR
ECONOMIC SECURITY. THE ECONOMIC
FORECAST FOR CALIFORNIANS
PROVIDE. ROOM FOR CONCERN AS
WELL CALIFORNIA IS REPORTING.
MORE THAN EIGHTY THOUSAND
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS FILED FOR
THE WEEK ENDING OCTOBER
SIXTEENTH REPRESENTING THE
STATE'S HIGHEST TOTAL. IN SIX
MONTHS. WELL EDIE'S BACKLOG HAS
BACKLOG HAS FALLEN DRAMATICALLY
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE THOUSAND CLAIMS ARE
IN THE THIRD WEEK BACKLOG AS OF
OCTOBER NINTH. ADDITIONALLY NEW
REPORTING LAST WEEK SHOW THAT
SOME CLAIMANTS HAVE BEEN
WAITING FOR UP TO TWENTY SIX
WEEKS. FOR AN INITIAL
ELIGIBILITY INTERVIEW THIS IS
SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE. AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR THIS BODY
REQUESTED THAT THE STATE
AUDITOR LOOKING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OPERATIONS AND MADE
A SERIES OF RECOMMENDATIONS TO
IMPROVE FUNCTIONALITY. UNDER
THE DIRECTION OF THE LECTURE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS WE WILL
REVIEW THE PROGRAMS MADE.
FOLLOWING THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE STATE AUDIT RELEASED
IN JANUARY. AT TODAY'S HEARING
WE WILL HEAR AND BOTH THE STATE
I AND THE DEPARTMENT ON
PROGRESS MADE IN THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS. I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT THE WORK OF THIS
LEGISLATURE TO IMPROVE
DEPARTMENT OPERATIONS. THIS
BUDGET YEAR LOAN WE APPROVED
SEVENTY SIX POINT THREE
MILLION. FOR ADDITIONAL EDT
STAFFING TO ADDRESS THE
WORKLOAD BACKLOG FIVE POINT
FIVE MILLION TO IMPLEMENT
DIRECT DEPOSIT OPTIONS. ELEVEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION TO IMPROVE
MULTI LINGUAL AXIS SIX MILLION.
TO IMPROVE SECURITY BY REMOVING
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS FROM
MAIL DOCUMENTS ELEVEN POINT
FOUR MILLION TO FUND THE
PLACEMENT OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE TRAINED STAFF IN
AMERICAN JOB CENTER STATEWIDE.
IN ADDITION WE EXTENDED THE
SUNSET DATE FOR CURRENT PAID
FAMILY LEAVE WAGE REPLACEMENT
RATE FOR ANOTHER YEAR WITHOUT
THIS ACTION CURRENT. PAID
FAMILY LEAVE WE TREAT THAT 70%
FOR THOSE MAKING LESS THAN
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTY
PERCENT. FOR THOSE MAKING MORE
THAN TWENTY TWO THOUSAND WILL
REVERT TO THE PRE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN RATE OF FIFTY FIVE
PERCENT. WE ALSO SAW A NUMBER
OF PIECES OF LEGISLATION SIGNED
INTO LAW THAT ADDRESS EDT
CONCERNS. AB TWELVE REQUIRES
STATE AGENCIES NO LATER THAN
JANUARY 1-202-020-2020 THREE.
TO STOP SENDING ONGOING UNITED
STATES MAIL TO INDIVIDUALS THAT
CONTAINED. THE INDIVIDUAL
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER UNLESS
THE NUMBER IS TRUNCATED TO WITH
THE LAST FOUR DIGITS AB FIFTY
SIX CODIFIES VARIOUS
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR REPORTS RELATED TO
EMPLOYMENT. DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT'S EDT PRACTICES.
ABOUT PERSONAL INFORMATION ON
OUTGOING MAIL CROSS MATCHING
AGAINST INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS INFORMATION
OVERPAYMENTS AND BACKLOG CLOSE.
AB ONE TEN REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. TO PROVIDE THE
NAMES AND SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS TO CURRENT INMATES TO
THE EDT DEPARTMENT TO PREVENT.
PAYMENTS ON FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION
BENEFITS AND WOULD REQUIRE EDT
TO CROSS MATCH THAT INFORMATION
BEFORE ANY PAYMENT OF
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION
BENEFITS AS PROVIDED. AB THREE
NINE SEVEN REQUIRES EIGHTY DEEP
BEFORE DISQUALIFYING AN
INDIVIDUAL AND SUBJECT SUBJECT
SUBJECT TAKING. THAT PERSON TO
A PERIOD OF INELIGIBILITY FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
TO PROVIDE NOTICE TO THE
INDIVIDUAL. OF THE PROPOSED
THAT TERMINATIONS AND REASONS
FOR IT THIS BILL ALSO GIVES
INDIVIDUALS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CORRECT ANY ALLEGED FALSE
STATEMENTS NOTED IN THE
PROPOSED A TERMINATION BEFORE A
FINAL NOTICE OF
DISQUALIFICATION. AB THREE
NINETY REQUIRES EDT TO DEVELOP
AN IMPLEMENTATION OF RECESSION
PLAN TO PREPARE FOR INCREASED
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
COMPENSATION BENEFITS DUE TO AN
ECONOMIC RECESSION. THIS WORK
HAS HELPED REDUCE BACKLOG AND
PROVIDE EASY DEAL WITH THE
STAFF AND RESOURCES IT NEEDS TO
PROVIDE SERVICES DURING THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES AND AMEND.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THERE IS MORE
WORK TO BE DONE I HOPE THAT
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE. BOTH
GIVE US N UPDATE ON
DEPARTMENT. FUNCTION HIGHLIGHT
AREAS WHERE IMPROVEMENT IS
NEEDED AND BEGIN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE. WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO ALLOW MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
IN TODAY'S HEARING TO MAKE ANY.
OPENING REMARKS. PLEASE LET ME
KNOW IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
WITH BETWEEN OURS. THANK YOU.
YEAH. YOU SHOULD BE OKAY ALL
RIGHT HI MIKE WE'RE READY ALL
RIGHT WELL GOOD MORNING AND
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I AM
ASSEMBLY WOMAN KIND OF
PETRIE-NORRIS AND I CHAIRED THE
ASSEMBLY'S ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE
AS WE ALL KNOW WHEN HE COVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC STRUCK AND
BUSINESSES ALL ACROSS OUR STATE
WERE- FORCED TO SHUTTER THEIR
DOORS MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
WERE LEFT UNEMPLOYED AND
CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT FACED AN
UNPRECEDENTED SURGE IN. CLAIMS
AND- AS CHAIR CARILLO NOTED
IT'S BEEN QUITE WELL DOCUMENTED
THAT TO THE DEPARTMENT WAYS
COMPLETELY UNPREPARED FOR THIS
DELUGE AND THE FALLOUT- WAS
HEARTBREAKING WE SAW MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS DESPERATE. FOR
BENEFITS AND UNABLE TO. I GET
PHONE CALLS ANSWERED EMAILS
RETURNED OR PAYMENTS RECEIVED.
THE REASON THAT AT THAT ARE
COMMITTEE AND THAT I PERSONALLY
HAVE BEEN SO FOCUSED ON THIS
ISSUE IS BECAUSE WHEN AN
AGENCY. FAILS THIS WAY WHEN AN
AGENCY ONE OF OUR GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES FAILS THIS BADLY I
BELIEVE THAT IT BREAKS THE
PUBLIC TRUST IT REALLY ERODES
PEOPLE'S FAITH IN GOVERNMENT
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE BEEN SO
FOCUSED ON EDT SINCE THE EARLY
STAGES OF THIS PANDEMIC I.
ENSURING THAT WE ADDRESS THE
IMMEDIATE FAILURES ENSURING
THAT WE ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES
OF THESE ISSUES AND ENSURING
THAT WE TAKE THE NECESSARY
STEPS TO MAKE SURE THIS NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN- FOR CALIFORNIANS
SO LOOKING FORWARD TO TODAY'S
CONVERSATION TODAY TASTE
HEARING AND RECEIVING AN UPDATE
ON PROGRESS THAT HAS BEEN MADE.
ON CUSTOMER SERVICE ON PROCESS
AND OPERATIONS AND ON IMPROVING
FRAUD PREVENTION STRATEGIES AS
WELL NOT SO WITH THAT. WILL
OPEN UP FOR WHO'S EVER NEXT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
GENEROUS MISTER CELIS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CARILLO ASSEMBLY WOMAN
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR HOSTING AT
TODAY'S HEARING. I THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME TO PARTICIPATE
AS CHAIR OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE YOU
KNOW FIRST I'D LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE
THAT'S PUBLICLY ACKNOWLEDGE AND
CONGRATULATE OUR STATE AUDITOR
ELAINE HOWLE. UNDER UPCOMING
RETIREMENT AND ON BEHALF OF THE
AUDIT COMMITTEE I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS OF PUBLIC SERVICE. AT
TWENTY ONE OF THOSE YEARS AGO
SERVED AS OUR STATE AUDITOR SO
WHETHER IT'S AND- DEBACLE IN
THE ELECTRICITY CRISIS OF THE
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS. OR THE
ORANGE COUNTY BANKRUPTCY IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES COST OVERRUNS
ON THE BAY BRIDGE RETROFITS A
DECADE AGO. I CORRUPTION AT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL OR
VISION ISSUES AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA NO MATTER THE
ISSUE YOU HAVE BEEN A TRUSTED
VOICE THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
RELIED UPON. TODAY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND EQUALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE OF THE ISSUE
AND CHALLENGE OF UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS AND ISSUE THAT WILL
SIMILAR. SIMILARLY GO IN THE-
WELL THE SIMILARLY AS A ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES
DURING THE PANDEMIC SO THEY CAN
BETTER MONITOR- FOR YOUR AUDIT
AND FOLLOW UP WORK AND THANK
YOU TO THE BIPARTISAN GROUP OF
THIRTY NINE. OTHER LEGISLATORS
WHO JOINED. AND REQUESTING THE
ADT ARE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
TODAY'S HEARING- WELL YOU
BETTER MONITOR YOUR OFFICE OF
SET A GOOD EXAMPLE FOR STATE
GOVERNMENT EDT. HAS BEEN QUITE
THE OPPOSITE. TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS. EDT AT ITS
PROCESS HAVE BEEN INCONSISTENT
UNCLEAR UNRESPONSIVE AND
FAILING. WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND QUITE
FRANKLY HELP WITH COURAGE DDD
TO EMPLOYMENT FIXES. IT'S BEEN
OVER A YEAR AND A HALF SINCE
UNEMPLOYMENT FIRST SPIKED
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC. AND
IT'S BEEN OVER SIX MONTHS NOW
SINCE THE STATE AUDITOR PRODUCE
THE AUDIT REPORT. THAT WE
REQUESTED REGARDING EDTA. IN
THAT REPORT THE STATE AUDITOR
MADE. MANY RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WOULD HELP ENSURE CALIFORNIANS
ARE RECEIVING THEIR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS TODAY I'M
HOPING TO HEAR FROM EDT IN THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE. ON
WHETHER OR NOT SIGNIFICANT
PROFIT FROM PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE- ON WHETHER CALIFORNIANS
ARE RECEIVING THEIR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. AND
WHETHER FRAUD IS BEING HELD IN
CHECK. YOU KNOW I TELL YOU
BASED ON THE STREAM OF CALLS MY
OFFICE CONTINUES TO RECEIVE-
MANY FROM FRUSTRATED
CONSTITUENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. I'M GUESSING THAT
ALL THE PROBLEMS AND ISSUES
HAVE NOT BEEN FULLY RESOLVED
EVEN AFTER ALL THIS TIME IT'S
PAST. THAT SAID WE ALL WANT EDT
TO BE SUCCESSFUL MY COLLEAGUES
AND I AUTHORED AT THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED A NUMBER OF COMMONSENSE
MEASURES. TO IMPROVE EDT. OUR
COLLECTIVE GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE
EDT IS STEPPING UP TO PROTECT
TAXPAYERS STOP FRAUD. IMPROVE
THE CLAIMS PROCESS AND THANKS
TO THE AUDIT COMMITTEE'S VICE
CHAIR SENATOR LAYERED HELP EASY
PREPARE FOR THE NEXT RECESSION.
THANK YOU AGAIN ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CARILLO ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
PETRIE-NORRIS PROVIDING J.
LASKIN ALLOWING US TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS
SENATOR. THANK YOU FOR. LET'S
SEE IF THAT WORKS. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM CHAIR AND
I TO APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PARTICIPATE AND BOB I WAS
GOING TO DO EXACTLY WHAT CHAIR
SALAS DID MANAGE KNOWLEDGE OUR
AUDITOR FOR LIKE THE SERVICE
AND I WORKED WITH HER AS A
CHAIR OF JAIL LIKE WHEN I WAS
IN THE ASSEMBLY AS A CABINET
SECRETARY AND NOW. AND SHE HAS
REALLY LED THE WAY ON MAJOR
ISSUES AND REALLY HELP THE
LEGISLATURE DRESS THEM DURING
HER TENURE AND SHE WILL HAVE
BIG SHOES TO FILL A FILL I'M
ALSO. AMAZED AT THIS IS THE
LAST HEARING IN THISROW OF
HAVING CHAIRED MANY BUDGET
HEARINGS IN THIS FROM HAVING
STARTED MY CAREER OUT AS AN
EMPLOYEE OF THE GUY WHOSE
PICTURES BEHIND THEIR- BEFORE
THE CHAIR MIGHT HAVE BEEN BORN.
MMHM IT I HAVE STARED AT IT
MANY TIMES AND I HOPE THAT
THAT- PICTURE MAKES IT TO THE
NEW. OF BUILDING. A WE HAD A
HEARING ON THE MAJOR AUDIT THAT
WAS DONE AT J. WACK. AND DURING
THAT MANY OF US OUTLINED THE
HARDSHIPS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCED BY OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE. I
DON'T WANT TO REITERATE SOME OF
US STAND BY THEM BUT THEY STILL
EXIST IN MANY WAYS AND- AND THE
WHOLE STORY OF A- A PROFESSOR
LIVING IN HER CAR- UP TO HAVE A
CAR PHONE RATE. IT COULD NOT
GET THE MONEY TO JUST MAKE IT
THROUGH THAT WAS REALLY
POWERFUL ONE THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT I THINK. MOTIVATE
US TO TAKE THE ACTIONS WE HAVE
TO TAKE. AND I APPRECIATE THE
DISPLAY OF SHOUT OUT FROM- SURE
SALAS BECAUSE BASICALLY SINCE
THAT HERE AND MANY OF US. TOOK
AUDIT RECOMMENDATIONS PUT THEM
INTO LEGISLATION AND THEY HAVE
BEEN ENACTED AND SIGNED. IN AND
THE ONE THAT I DID WAS REALLY
THE AUDITOR AFTER SIMILAR
THINGS HAPPENED IN THE GREAT
RECESSION OF TWO THOUSAND NINE
MADE A SIMILAR RECOMMENDATION.
IT WAS INDEED HERE TO BUY THE
GOVERNOR AT THE TIME. IT WASN'T
HERE TO BUY THE NEXT GOVERNOR
AND NOW THIRD GOVERNOR IS
FACING THE EXACT SAME THING. OF
I SAY THAT TO POINT OUT THAT
THIS ISN'T ONE GOVERNOR THIS IS
BIPARTISAN WHAT WHAT HAS GONE
ON HERE. BUT BASICALLY. OF THE
BILL THAT WAS CO AUTHORED. BY
PEOPLE OF BOTH SIDES OF THE
ISLAND BOTH HOUSES. REALLY SAID
THAT WILL BE READY. ARE ON AN
ONGOING OF ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT
BASIS. TO BE READY ANYTIME
THERE'S AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN
WITH THE STEPS THAT NEED TO BE
TAKEN TO GEAR UP IMMEDIATELY
AND I. APPRECIATE EVERYBODY. ON
THE DICE IS A CO AUTHOR VOTED
FOR IT AND I THINK THAT AS WE
HEAD INTO TODAY'S HEARING. WE
NEED TO KNOW THAT WE HAVE TAKEN
SOME OF THE STRONGEST FIRST
STEPS AS OUTLINED BY THE CHAIR
IN THE BUDGET. AND OUTLINED BY
THE CHAIR OF J. LACK OF- WITH
REGARD TO POLICY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE TESTIMONY. A TO
SEE WHAT FURTHER STEPS WE MIGHT
HAVE TO DO. TO BOTH DEAL WITH
THE REMAINING PROBLEMS NOW AND
THE FACT THAT THIS WILL NEVER
HAPPEN AGAIN SO THANKYOU AGAIN
FOR. INVITING ME THANK YOU
SENATOR AND NOW THE VICE. CHAIR
BUDGETS BEFORE MISTER LUCKY.
WHAT I YOU OF MADAM CHAIR PER.
FOR ORGANIZING- THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT HEARING IN.
PERMISSION TO USE A PROP. YEAH
PERMISSION TO USE A PROPER
QUICKLY.
AS I JUST INDICATED
EACH OF YOU MY FRUSTRATION THAT
I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS TO YOU AT
THIS PARTICULAR MOMENT HAS TO
DO WITH THE FRAUDULENT
DISPERSED. PAYMENTS BUT TOLD.
HELLO BILL. DOLLARS AND I KNOW
THIS IS HARD TO DIFFICULT AND
HARD AND DIFFICULT TO PROCESS.
BECAUSE WE HEAR REFERENCES TO
NUMBERS ALL THE TIME AND I
DON'T THINK PEOPLE OF CAPTURED.
IN THEIR MIND THE ENORMITY OF
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THERE'S
BEEN ISSUED. ERRANT WAY. TO
UNDESERVING PEOPLE. OF THIS
WASTE OF MONEY COULD A
PURCHASED. SIXTEEN THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
CALIFORNIA HOMES. AT THE MEDIUM
PRICE POINT PAID FOR CALIFORNIA
HOME. AND IT KIND OF ALSO PAID
FOR FOUR YEARS OF SCHOOLING AND
THE UC UNIVERSITY AND THOSE
THAT TOTAL OF STUDENTS WOULD
AMOUNT TO TWO THOUSAND SIXTY
FIVE. AND IT'S ALSO FOR BILLION
DOLLARS MORE THAN THE ENTIRE
OPERATING BUDGET OF THE CSU
SYSTEM. INSTEAD OF THOSE DAYS
WHERE THE OPPORTUNITIES THIS
MONEY IS GOING TO UNDESERVING
PEOPLE BUT A PURCHASE LUXURY
GOODS AND ALL SORTS OF
SQUANDERS. THERE'S ABSOLUTELY
NO REASON THAT IT INDEED
CONTINUES TO CODDLE THESE
OFFENDERS BY PAYING THEM
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS EIGHTEEN
MONTHS INTO THIS ONGOING
PANDEMIC. OUR DISTRICT OFFICE
CONTINUES TO DO THE JOB OF THE
DAY. MY OFFICE HAS PERSONALLY
ALERTED THE DEPARTMENT TO
SEVERAL CASES THAT WERE
OBVIOUSLY- FRAUDULENT LETTERS
LIKE TO SHARE JUST TWO EXAMPLES
REAL QUICKLY. THE LARGEST
BOONDOGGLE WE UNCOVERED WAS A
CLAIM FILED BY KIMBERLY L. WILL
COLOR KIMBERLY L. SHE WAS PAID
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS A
WEEK PLUS THREE HUNDRED AND
FEDERAL BENEFITS FOR THREE
MONTHS. WINNER CLAIMS STALLED
SHE OPENED ANOTHER CASE IN
KANSAS WHAT ARE LAYS ON TO
SCRUTINIZED HER CLAIM SHE
DISCOVERED OVER ONE HUNDRED
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS ALL LISTED
THE SAME. APARTMENT UPON
FURTHER INVESTIGATION THE LIES
ON AND HER MANAGER HAVE SHUT
DOWN OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS SPANNING SIX
STATES. THE WORK OF THESE
CLAIMS ARE STILL ON GOING AND
THERE WERE NO IDEA WAGE
VERIFICATION REQUIRED. WHICH IS
COMMON IN THESE CASES. ANOTHER
EXAMPLES TRC WHO HAD OF
VIRGINIA'S DRIVER'S LICENSE AND
APPLIED FOR BENEFITS IN AUGUST.
AFTER APPLYING SHE SAID IN SIX
REQUEST TO BACKDATE YOUR CLAIM
AFTER BEING REFUSED FIVE TIMES
WITH DOCUMENTATION IN HER FILE.
THE SIX THE TAP WAS BACKDATED
TO MID MARCH THE PAID OUT FOR
THREE MONTHS. SHE WAS
DISQUALIFIED SEVERAL TIMES AND
THERE WERE MULTIPLE PEOPLE AT
THE SAME ADDRESS. BUT THROUGH
THE ASK YOU D. D. SYSTEM SHE
WAS ABLE TO RECEIVE A HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR DOLLARS A WEEK.
PLUS THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL BENEFITS. BUT MANY MORE
EXAMPLES AND I'M NOT GOING TO.
BURDEN YOU WITH AT THIS
PARTICULAR MOMENT HOWEVER EDT
HAD NOT DETECTED ANY OF THESE
CASES. AN UNPAID AMOUNT UNTIL
MY OFFICE STEPPED IN AND ASK
QUESTIONS EDT PERSONNEL TOLD US
THAT THESE CASES REPRESENT RED
FLAGS AND THAT THE SYSTEM. IS
OKAY. BUT NOTHING HAS BEEN DONE
TO REALLY STOP AT THAT WE'RE
AWARE OF. I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION AHEAD AND IN THIS
MEETING TO SEE HOW THAT WE CAN
OF COURSE BASIC GUARDRAILS. ON
THESE PARTICULAR FUNDS PROVIDED
BY TAXPAYERS EIGHTEEN MONTHS
INTO THE PANDEMIC. SO THE WE DO
NOT FILL THE THIRTY DUMP TRUCKS
WITH WASTED PAYMENTS. AND
THAT'S ALL I HAVE MEANT. THANK
YOU MR LACKEY I THINK YOU POINT
OUT A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM THAT
IS. A BIPARTISAN ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE ALL BEEN TRYING IS. TO
FIND SOLUTIONS FOR- WE WILL
BEGIN OUR PANEL NO FIRST WE
WOULD OUR FIRST PANEL WE WILL
NOW HEAR FROM OUR STATE AUDITOR
MISS ELAINE HOWELL AND HER
STAFF UP HARRIS ON THEIR
UPDATES TO THE AUDIT AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. WELCOME.
HOPEFULLY THIS IS ON. THANK YOU
THANK YOU CHAIRED CARILLO
PETRIE-NORRIS AND CERTAINLY
CHAIR SALAS- FOR. YOU KELLY HI
THE VOLUME OF THAT PLEASE. OKAY
WELL I'LL SPEAK UP THEN- SO FOR
THE RECORD MY NAME IS ELAINE
HALL IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR TO MY RIGHT IS BOB
HARRIS MR HARRIS WAS THE AUDIT
MANAGER ON THIS PARTICULAR
PROJECT I KNOW OUR- THE
SERGEANT HAS HANDED OUT. COPIES
OF THE AUDIT REPORT AND A HAND
OUT RELATED TO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS MISTER HARRIS
WILL STEP YOU THROUGH. THE HAND
OUT RELATED TO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE STATUS
OF DD'S PROGRESS AND CERTAINLY
ON THE LAST PAGE OF KNOWLEDGE
IN A LOT OF LEGISLATIVE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE. WHAT I INTEND
TO DO VERY QUICKLY. IS TO GIVE
YOU A BRIEF. OVERVIEW ARE
REFRESHER OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
IDENTIFIED IN THE TWO ARTISTS
WE ISSUED IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- AS YOU KNOW THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE. APPROVED AN
EMERGENCY REQUEST IN THE FALL
OF TWENTY TWENTY IN SEPTEMBER.
WE COMBINE THAT WITH OUR HIGH
RISK AUTHORITY TO GIVE US THE
ABILITY TO CONDUCT. A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT OBJECTIVES- AND
LOOKING AT EDT. SO THREE KEY
AREAS I'M GOING TO TALK ABOUT
THE FIRST IS THEIR ABILITY TO
PROCESS CLAIMS. THE SECOND IS
RELATED TO THEIR CALL CENTER
AND THEIR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO PEOPLE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND THE THIRD
AREAS LOOKING AT FRAUD
PREVENTION AND DETECTION WHAT
THEIR EFFORTS WERE WHAT TOOLS
THEY USE IT CENTER. SO THE
FIRST ISSUE RELATED TO CLAIMS
PROCESSING THIS HAS BEEN A
HISTORIC AS CENTER LAYERED
INDICATED. AFTER THE RECESSION
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND NINE THE
LEGISLATURE ASKED US THROUGH
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE. ASKED US TO CONDUCT
AN AUDIT OF EDT AND ITS ABILITY
TO PROCESS CLAIMS PARTICULARLY
IN A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE THERE
IS A RECESSION. UNEMPLOYMENT
INCREASES SIGNIFICANTLY. WE
ISSUED A REPORT IN MARCH OF
TWENTY ELEVEN AND FOUND THEY
HAD STRUGGLES IN. PROCESSING
CLAIMS THEY HAVEN'T ASSESSED
THEIR STAFFING THEIR CALL
CENTER WAS. PERFORMING VERY
POORLY ANSWERED LESS THAN 10%
OF THE CALLS THAT GOT WORSE
DURING THE PANDEMIC. BUT THEY
REALLY STRUGGLE SO WE MADE A
VARIETY OF RECOMMENDATIONS TO
EDT TO IMPROVE. THEIR CALL
CENTER TO PROVIDE TRAINING TO
THEIR STAFF TO AUTOMATE CERTAIN
ASPECTS OF THEIR CLAIMS
PROCESSING. WE CONDUCTED A
FOLLOW UP ON IT NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY TWELVE UNFORTUNATELY
FOUND SOME OF THE SAME- ISSUES
STILL HAPPENING. STRUGGLING
WITH PROCESSING CLAIMS THEY HAD
IMPROVE THEIR CALL CENTER SOME
BUT THEY ACTUALLY LOST SOME
IMPORTANT FUNCTIONALITY AND
I'LL TALK ABOUT THAT. WHEN I
TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE RELATED TO
THE CALL CENTER. SO WE
CONDUCTED THIS AUDIT AGAIN ON.
AT THE DIRECTION OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND CERTAINLY UNDER
HIGH RISK IT ALREADY. AND FOUND
AGAIN THEY WERE CONTINUING TO
STRUGGLE TO PROCESS CLAIMS AND
CERTAINLY IN THE PANDEMIC. ALL
OF THE ISSUES THAT EDT HAD
EXPERIENCE IN THE PAST WERE
EXACERBATED BECAUSE YOU YOU
HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE. SEEKING
HELP SEEKING UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS THROUGH THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. SO WHEN
WE LOOK AT THEIR ABILITY TO
PROCESS CLAIMS WE FOUND THAT
CLOSE 250% OF THOSE CLAIMS.
WERE GETTING KICKED OUT WHERE
THEY HAVE TO MANUALLY DO SOME
ANALYSIS AND DO SOME WORK WITH
STATE THE PARTICULAR
CONSTITUENT WHO IS TRYING TO
GET BENEFITS. AND THAT JUST
DIDN'T WORK IT WAS JUST TAKING
WAY TOO LONG. TO TRY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
WHAT DO YOU DO EIGHTY DID DO.
AFTER AT THE RECOMMENDATION
BASED ON THE STRIKE TEAM AT THE
GOVERNOR PUT TOGETHER. WAS
USING ID ME SO THAT REALLY DID
ASSIST IN HELPING. VERIFY
IDENTITIES OF INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE THAT WAS A HUGE ISSUE.
AS FAR AS THE- ABILITY PROCESS
CLAIMS SO THAT WAS AN
IMPROVEMENT. BUT UNFORTUNATELY
WHAT UP OTHER THINGS EDT DID IS
THEY SUSPENDED CERTAIN THINGS-
SUCH AS ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS. OTHER ISSUES
THAT TEST TO- QUICK AND GET
THOSE CLAIMS PROCESS MORE
QUICKLY EXPEDITE PROCESSING OF
CLAIMS. THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
THEY CAN NOT DO. LONG TERM
BECAUSE IF THEY WERE ABLE TO DO
SOME OF THOSE THINGS BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC. THERE WERE SOME A
PANDEMIC PROGRAMS THAT CAME OUT
OF CONGRESS THAT WERE NEW
PROGRAMS. SUCH AS THE POOR
PROGRAM. PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE AND THIS IS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SELF
EMPLOYED. SO THERE'S REALLY A
DIFFICULT ABILITY TO CONFIRM
THEIR- THEIR INCOME THEIR
WAGES- SO EDT SAID WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO THAT LET'S JUST GO
AHEAD AND GET SOME OF THOSE
CLAIMS PROCESS UNFORTUNATELY
SOME OF THOSE. ULTIMATELY ENDED
UP AS FRAUDULENT CLAIMS SO THE
CLAIMS PROCESSING PRACTICES
WERE REALLY- THEY CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE- AND CERTAINLY AS I
SAID THE PANDEMIC EXACERBATED
THOSE PROBLEMS. NOW THE OTHER
ISSUE THAT I JUST MENTIONED IS
THEY DELAYED CERTAIN CRITICAL
WORK. TO TWO KEY THINGS
SUSPENDING ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS THIS IS A
REQUIREMENT THAT AN INDIVIDUAL
HAS TO DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY
ARE ABLE AND AVAILABLE TO WORK.
AND FOR ABOUT A TEN MONTH
PERIOD BETWEEN MARCH AND
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY THEY
SUSPENDED THOSE REQUIREMENTS
DIDN'T EXPECT PEOPLE TO PROVE
THAT SO. NOW THEY HAVE WHEN WE
ISSUED THE REPORT. IT AFFECTED
ABOUT TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
CLAIMANTS WILL CLOSE TO TWELVE
MILLION ISSUES- THE REASON WE
IDENTIFIED THIS IS THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR WHEN THEY
BECAME AWARE THAT EDT HAD
SUSPENDED THIS REQUIREMENT.
TOLD THE STATE YOU CAN'T DO
THAT YOU'VE GOT TO REQUIRE
THESE FOLKS TO. DETERMINE YOU
KNOW SUBMIT THINGS TO SO THAT
YOU CAN DETERMINE THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THESE BENEFITS.
SIMILARLY THERE'S A PROCESS
WHERE SOMEONE HAS TO SUBMIT A
BI WEEKLY CERTIFICATION EVERY
TWO WEEKS I AM SEEKING
EMPLOYMENT I'M TRYING TO GET A
JOB. EDT SUSPENDED THAT AS WELL
FOR ABOUT AN EIGHT WEEK EIGHT
WEEK PERIOD BETWEEN MID MARCH
OF TWENTY TWENTY. AND MAY OF
TWENTY TWENTY AGAIN- THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR BECAME
AWARE OF THIS- HAD CONCERNS AND
INFORM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
YOU CANNOT DO THAT YOU'VE GOT
TO REINSTITUTE THOSE. SO THAT
SITUATION THERE IS ABOUT ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION CLAIMANTS
AFFECTED BY THAT SO HUGE
DEFERRED WORKLOAD THAT WE TALK
ABOUT IN THE ART REPORT MISTER
HARRIS WILL TALK ABOUT. SOME OF
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO
WORKLOAD PLANNING HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO ADDRESS YOUR ABILITY
TO PROCESS CLAIMS AS THEY
CONTINUE TO COME IN. BUT NOW
DEAL WITH THIS DEFERRED
WORKLOAD THAT YOU HAVE SO YOU
HAVE BASICALLY ACCUMULATED
BECAUSE YOU SUSPENDED THOSE
THOSE TWO KEY- CONTROLS KEY
PARTS OF YOUR PROGRAM. SO THOSE
ARE SOME OF THE KEY ISSUES
RELATED TO PROCESSING YOU KNOW
ESTABLISH. IDENTIFYING WHAT
YOUR WORKLOAD IS THEY DEFERRED
SOME THINGS NOW THEY HAVE THAT
WORKLOAD. SKEWS ME ON TOP OF
THEIR EXISTING WORKLOAD. THE
CALL CENTER THE SECOND ISSUE
THAT WE TALK ABOUT IN THE
REPORT. AS YOU KNOW HOW MANY OF
YOUR CONSTITUENTS TRY TO CALL
EDT TO TRY TO GET ASSISTANCE
CAN'T EVEN GET THROUGH. WHEN
THEY DO GET THROUGH THEY GET AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO PERHAPS HASN'T
WORKED FOR EDT VERY LONG CAN'T
ANSWER THEIR QUESTIONS- THERE
WASN'T THE ABILITY FOR
CONSTITUENTS TO CALL IN AND
LEAVE A NUMBER SO THAT THEY
COULD BE CALLED BACK. THAT WAS
ONE OF THE- ASCENTIAL
FUNCTIONALITY. THAT THEIR PRIOR
SYSTEM HAD THEIR NEW SYSTEM
HABIT BUT THEY HAVEN'T
IMPLEMENTED THEY HAVEN'T
ESTABLISHED IT. SO THERE WAS NO
CALL BACK OPTION THERE WERE NO
PRE RECORDED MESSAGES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAYBE JUST
WANTED. TO GET A QUESTION
ANSWERED AND IT IF THERE WAS AN
AUTOMATED SYSTEM THAT ALLOWED
THEM TO GET THAT ANSWER. THEN
THEY WOULDN'T BE FRUSTRATED BY
BEING ON HOLD OR HAVING TO CALL
BACK OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN. TO TRY TO GET THROUGH
TO. TO AN INDIVIDUAL- SO THIS
THIS PERFORMANCE EVEN IF IT WAS
IT WAS POOR BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
IT JUST GOT. MISERABLE I MEAN
WAS LESS THAN 1% OF PEOPLE WERE
GETTING THROUGH TO SOMEONE AND
IMAGINE TRYING TO GET THROUGH
AND THEN GETTING TO SOMEONE
WHO. DOESN'T HAVE THE NECESSARY
TRAINING NO FAULT TO THEM THEY
THEY DID HIRE MORE PEOPLE BUT
THOSE PEOPLE DIDN'T HAVE THE
EXPERTISE. TO HELP FOLKS SO YOU
GET THROUGH AFTER CALLING
MULTIPLE TIMES. AND THEN YOU
TALK TO SOMEONE WHO CAN'T HELP
YOU. VERY FRUSTRATING FOR
CONSTITUENTS. THE OTHER THING
IS WE IDENTIFIED THIS BACK IN
TWENTY TWELVE AND TWENTY
ELEVEN. THEY WEREN'T ANALYZING
ANY FIRST CALL RESOLUTION SO
WERE THEY RECORDING OKAY I
ANSWERED THE LINE HOUSE CALL
AND I WAS ABLE TO ANSWER HER
QUESTION. LET'S RECORD THAT SO
THAT WE KNOW WHAT ARE THE TYPES
OF QUESTIONS THAT CONSTITUENTS
ARE ASKING FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE UNEMPLOYED
OR ASKING TO GET ASSISTANCE.
THAT WOULD IDENTIFY. WAYS TO
TRAIN OUR STAFF OR THINGS YOU
COULD PUT ON THE WEBSITE AS A
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS SO
SOMEONE DOESN'T EVEN NEED TO
CALL IN. SO THEY WEREN'T
ASSESSING FIRST CALL RESOLUTION
THAT IS A BEST PRACTICE OUT
THERE IN THE INDUSTRY. THEY
WEREN'T TRACKING WHITE PEOPLE
WERE CALLING- EDT. AND TRAINING
THEIR STAFF AND AGAIN AS I SAID
UPDATING THAT FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS. SO WE HAD A LOT OF
CONCERNS RELATED TO THE CALL
CENTER- WE MADE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO THAT
CERTAINLY RELATED TO. USING THE
FUNCTIONALITY THAT THAT SYSTEM
HAS AS FAR AS ALLOWING FOR A
CALL BACK OPTION. PUTTING PRE
RECORDED MESSAGES OUT THERE SO
THEY NEEDED TO DO A LOT OF
THINGS TO REALLY IMPROVE THAT
CALL CENTER. THE LAST AREA
QUICKLY GO OVER AND THEN I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO MR HARRIS'S OF
COURSE FRAUD PREVENTION AND
DETECTION- WHEN WE ISSUED THE
REPORT IN JANUARY WE HAD
ESTIMATED ABOUT TEN POINT FOUR
BILLION- AND FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
AND OR A VARIETY OF REASONS FOR
THAT. WE IDENTIFIED. HI NUMBER
OF SUSPICIOUS ADDRESSES- AS YOU
NOW I'M SURE SOME OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WERE RECEIVING
MULTIPLE MAILINGS AT THEIR HOME
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO DON'T EVEN
RESIDE AT THAT ADDRESS. WE HAD
ISSUED AN AUDIT REPORT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. THE ASSEMBLY
PRIVACY COMMITTEE ASKED US TO
LOOK AT EDT SENDING OUT
DOCUMENTS WITH FULL SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS. WHY IS THE
A FOLLOW UP ON THAT AUDIT
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY TO
SEE IF THINGS HAD BEEN
CORRECTED THEY HAD NOT BEEN SO.
YOU HAVE A HUGE ISSUE OF
IDENTITY THEFT. AND IN FACT
WHEN WE CONDUCTED THE AUDITS-
THAT WE ISSUED IN JANUARY. WE
HAD IDENTIFIED ABOUT SEVENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND CLAIMS THAT
INDIVIDUALS HAD SUBMITTED TO
EDT SAYING I THANK MY IDENTITY
HAS BEEN STOLEN. COMPARE THAT
TO CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN IT WAS SIX THOUSAND
FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR. SO FOR
ABOUT AN EIGHT MONTH WINDOW
YOU'VE GOT SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE SAYING. I THANK
MY IDENTITIES BEEN STOLEN YOU
HAVE COUNTLESS OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO AT THAT POINT
TIME MAY NOT EVEN KNOW. THAT
THEIR IDENTITY HAD BEEN STOLEN
SO A HUGE ISSUE. AS FAR AS- NOT
EDT NOT TAKING STEPS WHEN THEY
KNEW THEY HAD SOME SUSPICIOUS
ADRESSES. WE TALK IN THE AUDIT
REPORT. WHERE THEY STARTED TO
PUT SOME CONTROLS AROUND THAT
BUT EVEN THEN WHEN WE LOOKED AT
SOME OF THOSE ADDRESSES WE
FOUND SOME THAT HAD NOT BEEN
SUSPENDED THAT. WERE CLEARLY
SUSPICIOUS ADDRESSES SO THEY
HADN'T TAKEN THE APPROPRIATE
STEPS. TO TRY TO CLAMP DOWN ON.
ON SOME OF A FRAUD THAT WAS
OCCURRING. TO HIGH PROFILE
ISSUES YOU'RE WELL AWARE OF THE
BANK OF AMERICA WITH THE
BENEFIT CARDS. FROZE OVER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACCOUNTS. OUR
ISSUE IS I'S IMPORTANT TO BE
ABLE TO FREEZE THOSE ACCOUNTS
BUT YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND. THE
NATURE OF. HOW MANY OF THOSE
WERE LEGITIMATE BENEFIT
BENEFICIARIES VERSUS ACTUAL
POTENTIALLY FRAUDULENT. SO
THERE ARE PICKED INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAD THEIR ACCOUNT FROZEN.
THAT WERE LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS
BUT EDT AND DIDN'T WORK WOULD
BE OF A TO COME UP WITH A
PROTOCOL FOR. LET'S CLEAR SOME
OF THESE TO FREE UP THOSE ARE
YOU KNOW ON FREEZE THOSE
ACCOUNTS. SO WE REALLY HAD SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THEY WERE
WORKING WITH B. OF A- TO
DETERMINE WHICH COUNTS SHOULD
BE FROZEN WHICH SHOULD BE
UNFROZEN THEY JUST. BASICALLY
THE PENDULUM WAS SWINGING ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER LET'S FREEZE
EVERYTHING NOW LET'S ON FREEZE
EVERYTHING IT WASN'T A GOOD
STRATEGIC APPROACH. THE SECOND
HIGH PROFILE ISSUE OF COURSE IS
THE CROSS MATCHING- THIS IS
WHERE. EDT WAS NOT CROSS
MATCHING ITS INFORMATION WITH
OUR STATE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS. AND CERTAINLY NOT
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AS
WELL AS LOCAL FACILITIES.
DURING THE AUDIT WE AYE AYE WE
IDENTIFIED ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS THAT
HAD BEEN SENT OUT PAID OUT.
UNDER THE NAMES OF INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS SOME OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS MAY HAVE HAD THEIR
IDENTITY STOLEN SOME OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS MAY BE
FRAUDULENTLY. OBTAINING
BENEFITS. THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
WE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT WHEN WE
LOOKED WE FOUND A NATIONAL
STUDY THAT HAD BEEN DONE IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WHERE THEIR
WORKS UPWARDS OF THIRTY FIVE
THIRTY SIX STATES THAT WE'RE
DOING THIS CROSS MATCHING. AND
IN FACT EDT BACK THEN HAD
NOTIFIED THE LEGISLATURE THIS
IS SOMETHING WE WANT TO DO. BUT
HAD NEVER REALLY FOLLOWED
THROUGH WITH IT- SO IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT SOME OF
THE LEGISLATION ADDRESSES THIS
ISSUE THIS WILL BE A HUGE
CONTROL THAT WILL ALLOW EDT. TO
IDENTIFY THOSE CROSS MATCHES
AND THEN BE ABLE TO INVESTIGATE
AND HOPEFULLY PREVENT. OF FRAUD
IN THE FUTURE. AT THE LAST
ISSUE RELATED TO FRAUD
DETECTION AND PREVENTION WE
WANT TO LOOK AT THEIR STRUCTURE
WHAT KIND OF FRIED. A PROGRAM
DOES EDT HAVE AND THEN WHEN YOU
LOOK IN THE AUDIT REPORT. AND
WE PRESENTED THIS SENATE AND A
FIGURE THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT UNITS IT'S A
BASICALLY A PATCHWORK. THERE
ISN'T AN OVER. OVERVIEW OR ARE
AN INDIVIDUAL OR UNIT THAT HAD
RESPONSIBILITY FOR COORDINATING
ALL THE FRAUD DETECTION
PREVENTION EFFORTS. THAT EDT
WAS ENGAGING AND IT WOULD.
INDIVIDUALS HAD TO COMMUNICATE
ACROSS DIFFERENT BRANCHES
DIFFERENT UNITS WITHIN THE DAY
IT WAS. IT WAS NOT AN EFFECTIVE
PROCESS SO WE FELT THAT THEY
NEEDED TO ESTABLISH A
CENTRALIZED UNIT. ET WAS NOT
MEASURING. THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
ITS PROVOKED PREVENTION AND
DETECTION TOOL SO IT DIDN'T
KNOW WHICH TOOLS WORK BETTER
THAN OTHERS DO WE NEED TO
CONTINUE USING THIS TOOL IS IT
REALLY EFFECTIVE. IF THIS ONE'S
NOT EFFECTIVE THEN LET'S NOT
INVEST MORE RESOURCES IN THAT
PARTICULAR TOOL. AND THE FINAL
ISSUE RELATED TO THAT IS IF
YOU'RE NOT ASSESSING YOUR
TOOLS. YOU DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO ADJUST YOUR EFFORTS
DURING A HIGH DEMAND- TIME
FRAME. FOR EXAMPLE WE TALKED IN
THE MARCH OF TWENTY ELEVEN
REPORT AND THE FOLLOW UP. IN
TWENTY TWELVE. ABOUT THAT
RECESSION PLAN YOU NEED TO HAVE
A RECESSION PLAN RECESSION
HAPPENS EVERY FIVE TO SIX
YEARS. SO YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE A
PLAN IN PLACE TO DEAL WITH THAT
NOBODY CERTAINLY EXPECTED. THE
THIS COUNTRY IN THIS WORLD TO
HAVE TO BE DEALING WITH A
PANDEMIC OF THIS. OF THIS
ENORMITY BUT YOU IF WE HAD HAD
A RECESSION PLAN. AT LEAST WE
AS A STATE EDT WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS
STAFFING. WHAT KIND OF WORKLOAD
ISSUES DO WE NEED TO ADDRESS IT
CETERA SO. AGAIN WE FEEL THAT
THAT RECESSION PLAN WOULD HAVE
TIED INTO SOME OF YOUR
PREVENTION DETECTION TOOLS.
WHICH ONES ARE AFFECTED WHICH
ONES WE WANT TO KEEP USING.
WHICH ONES ARE WE MORE
COMFORTABLE BASICALLY DIALING
BACK SO WE CAN FREE UP SOME OF
THOSE STAFF TO DO OTHER THINGS.
SO THOSE ARE THAT'S GOOD. VERY
QUICK HOPEFULLY OVERVIEW A
REFRESHER ON THE TWO ARTISTS
THAT WE YOUR- JAN. OF TWENTY
TWENTY. BECAUSE WE DID THESE
AUDITS UNDER OUR HIGH RISK
AUTHORITY AND CERTAINLY THE
EMERGENCY I REQUEST THAT
MEMBERS SIGNED ON. WE GET
UPDATES FROM EIGHTY D. EVERY
NINETY DAYS- MISTER HARRIS HAS
BEEN. WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT IN FACT I THINK
HE GOT SOME UPDATES S RECENTLY
AS THIS PAST FRIDAY. I WAS
GETTING EMAILS FROM HIM- SAYING
HE WAS STILL WORKING WITH THE
DUTY TO GET SOME FRESH CURRENT
INFORMATION FOR THESE
COMMITTEES TODAY. SO WITH THAT
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MISTER
HARRISON HILL STEP YOU THROUGH
THE HAND OUT THAT. WE PROVIDED
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
CHECK CORREO- ATTRIBUTES YOU
NORRIS ENSURE SALAS- MY NAME IS
BOB HARRIS I'M A PROJECT
MANAGER MR HERS BEFORE YOU
BEGIN WHICH OF THE DOCUMENTS
ARE YOU REFERRING TO I'LL BE
STEPPING THROUGH THIS HAND OUT-
IT'S LEAR WHAT I THINK WITH
THAT CLAIM PROCESSING. YES THIS
THIS HAND OUT WE PROVIDE MY
NAME'S BOB HARRIS WITH THE
STATE OUT OFFICE I'M A PROJECT
MANAGER- THIS HANDOUT IS THE
MORNING I'LL BE WALKING YOU
THROUGH. THE PROGRESS E. D.'S
MATED ADDRESSING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. THERE ARE
ESSENTIALLY THE FIRST THREE
PAGES COVERS THE SAME SUBJECT
AREAS THE STATE AUDITOR JUST
COMMENTED ON CLAIMS PROCESSING
THE CALL CENTER AND THEN FRAUD
PREVENTION. AND DETECTION THE
FINAL PAGES A SUMMARY OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS THAT WERE
TAKEN THIS PAST YEAR- BY THIS
COMMITTEE. CHAIR PETRIE-NORRIS
TRISTE ALICE CENTER LAYERED- TO
ADDRESS AREAS OF CONCERN THAT
WE KNOW TO WHERE WE SAID THERE
NEEDED TO BE LEGISLATIVE ACTION
TAKEN. ALSO NOTE THERE ARE
SEVERAL OF THE E. D. D.
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE MADE
DIRECTLY TO ET DE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ALSO ADOPTED AS
PART OF LEGISLATION
PARTICULARLY. ENSURE SALAS IS
AB FIFTY SIX SO- THOSE IN
ADDITION TO BEING
RECOMMENDATIONS WE ARE
CONTINUING TO FOLLOW UP ON ARE
NOW ALSO STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
FOR EDT OR WILL BE. IN THE
COMING YEAR- I'LL STEP THROUGH
EACH OF THE SUBJECT AREAS ONE
BY ONE IN A MOMENT BUT FIRST
THERE'S A THERE'S A THREAD THAT
RUNS THROUGH ALL OF THEM AND
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY THIS. EDT
HAS MADE NOTABLE PROGRESS IN
ADDRESSING THE AREAS OF CONCERN
THAT WE FOUND DURING OUR AUDITS.
BUT SIGNIFICANT STEPS NOTE
STILL NEED TO BE TAKEN TO
ADDRESS AREAS OF RISK. WHERE IF
HE DOESN'T CONTINUE TO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON SOME OF THE INITIAL
POSITIVE FIRST STEPS IS TAKEN.
THEN IT WON'T FULLY REALIZE THE
BENEFITS FOR CALIFORNIANS THAT
NEED ITS ASSISTANCE. SO YOU'LL
SEE THAT KIND OF THEME
THROUGHOUT ALL THREE AREAS
WE'LL START WITH CLAIMS
PROCESSING ON PAGE ONE OF THE
HAND OUT. IN THIS AREA EDT HAS
TAKEN STEPS PARTICULARLY TO
ADDRESS. THE PROBLEMS THAT WERE
CAUSING CLAIMS TO NOT BE
PROCESSED EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY. YOU'LL SEE TOWARDS
THE BOTTOM OF THAT PAGE UNDER
THE JUNETWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AREA THAT THEY HAVE ALREADY
IDENTIFIED KEY PROBLEMS WITH IT
SYSTEMS. THAT WERE CAUSING HANG
UPS IN CLAIMS PROCESING.
IMPROVEMENTS THAT THEY CAN MAKE
TO MAKE SURE THE CLAIMS ARE
PROCESS MORE EFFECTIVELY. BUT
THAT WERE IN MARKING THOSE
EITHER PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED
RIGHT NOW OUR AND- IN THE CASE
OF IDENTIFICATION THE
IDENTIFICATION IS DONE. NOW EDT
NEEDS TO CARRY OUT THOSE AND
HIS SYSTEM IMPROVEMENTS SO
THEY'VE MADE GOOD PROGRESS IN
RECOGNIZING WHICH PARTS OF
THEIR IT SYSTEMS COULD MAKE
CLAIMS PROCESSING MORE
EFFECTIVE. NOW THEY NEED TO GO
AHEAD AND CARRY OUT THOSE
SYSTEM CHANGES. EDT IS ALSO
PRESENTING A MUCH MORE
TRANSPARENT PICTURE ON ITS
PUBLIC WEBSITE NOW. OF THE
CLAIMS BACKLOG DURING THE AUDIT
WE FOUND THAT THE CLAIMS
BACKLOG NUMBERS ON EDIE'S
WEBSITE WE'RE NOT COMPLETELY
ACCURATE THEY DIDN'T SEPARATE
OUT THE CLAIMS THAT WERE
BACKLOGGED TO DO DVD DIS IN
ACTION. VERSES THOSE WERE EDIE
HAD CONTACTED THE CLAIMANT AND
WAS NOW WAITING TO RECEIVE
DOCUMENTS BACK FROM THE
CLAIMANT. THE PUBLIC WEBSITE
NOW DOES A MUCH BETTER JOB AT
SEGREGATING THOSE TWO
POPULATION SO THAT THE PUBLIC
IN THE LEGISLATURE CAN HAVE A
MUCH BETTER UNDERSTANDING. OF
WHAT EDIE'S BACKLOG LOOKS LIKE.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE DEFERRED
WORKLOAD THAT THE STATE AUDITOR
MENTIONED A MOMENT AGO SO IT'S
TRUE DURING THE PAST THE HEIGHT
OF THE PANDEMIC EDT SUSPENDED
WORK IN TWO KEY AREAS THAT WE
KNOW IN THE AUDIT REPORT. THEY
STOPPED MAKING ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS VIRTUALLY ALL OF
THEM. AND STAY FOR A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME STOPPED
RECEIVING THESE REGULAR ONGOING
CERTIFICATIONS OF CONTINUED
ELIGIBILITY. DOES REPRESENT AN
ENORMOUS BACKLOG OF WORK THE
EDT NOW NEDS TO PROCESS AND SO
WE MADE SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS
ABOUT HOW IT COULD DO SO. THE
ENCOURAGING THINGS THAT IT'S
ALREADY DONE TO IMPLEMENT OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE FIRST IT'S
COMPLETED A RISK ASSESSMENT OF
THAT DEFERRED BACKLOG SO WE
WANTED THEM TO GO THROUGH AND
IDENTIFY AMONGST ALL OF THE
DEFERRED WORK WHAT IS THE
HIGHEST RISK FOR POTENTIALLY
HAVING BEEN OVERPAID OR
IMPROPERLY PAID. SO WHEN YOU'RE
NOT DOING ELIGIBILITY TO HER
DETERMINATIONS YOU COULD
POTENTIALLY PAY SOMEBODY WHO'S
NOT ACTUALLY ELIGIBLE FOR
THOSE. BENEFITS OR MAYBE NOT
FOR ALL OF THE BENEFITS THAT
THEY WERE. PROVIDED SO EATING
FIRST IN ORDER TO PROCESS THIS
ENORMOUS BACKLOG NEED TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT IS THE HIGHEST RISK
WORK IN THE BACKLOG THEY'VE
DONE THAT NOW THEY HAVE. THAT
RISK ASSESSMENT COMPLETED. THEN
THEY'VE GONE AHEAD AND ALSO
DEVELOPED A WORKLOAD PLAN FOR
HOW TO PROGRESS THROUGH THAT
WORKLOAD. SO NOW THEY HAVE
DEVELOPED A TIMELINE BY WHICH
THEY EXPECTS TO PROGRESS
THROUGH THAT WORK. IT
CONTRACTED OUT FOR ASSISTANCE
TO COMPLETE THAT WORK AS WELL
AS OTHER ON GOING HIGHER THAN
NORMAL WORKLOADS THAT THEY'RE
FACING. THE BIGGEST AREA OF
RISK NOW REMAINS THAT EDIE HAS
TO ACTUALLY EXECUTE THAT
WORKLOAD PLAN SO WE'LL BE
CONTINUING TO FOLLOW UP WITH
THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
STAY ON SCHEDULE. THERE IS A
WINDOW WITHIN WHICH EDT HAS.
TIME TO RECOUP IMPROPER
PAYMENTS TO REQUEST REPAYMENT
OF FUNDS THAT SHOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN PAID. BUT THAT WINDOW WILL
EVENTUALLY CLOSE AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT EDT COMPLETE
ITS- ASSESSMENT AND CONDUCTING
OF THIS BACKLOG WORK. BEFORE
THAT WINDOW CLOSES THEIR WORK
LOT LOAD PLAN RIGHT NOW HAS
THEM SCHEDULED TO DO SO. NOW WE
NEED TO SEE THEM CARRIED OUT
THAT WORKLOAD PLAN. SO THAT'S
CLAIMS PROCESSING ON THE SECOND
PAGE OF THE HANDOUT WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THE CALL CENTER. AND THE
THINGS THAT EDT IS DONE TO
IMPROVE ITS- ABILITY TO MANAGE
ITS CALL CENTER EFFECTIVELY. IT
HAS ADDED THOSE CONVENIENCE
FEATURES THAT WERE LACKING WHEN
IT. ADOPTED A NEW CALL CENTER
SYSTEM. SO IT IS ADDED THE PRE
RECORDED MESSAGES IF IT'S ADDED
THE ABILITY TO RECEIVE A CALL
BACK- INSTEAD OF WAITING ON
HOLD SO THOSE ARE POSITIVE
CONSUMER FACING. IMPROVEMENTS
THAT HELP THE EXPERIENCE B.
JUST SLIGHTLY BETTER FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE CALLING FOR ASSISTANCE.
IN ADDITION EDT HAS AT LEAST
ADOPTED THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES NEEDED. TO PROPERLY
ASSESS ITS CALL CENTRE WORKLOAD
SO THAT IT CAN BETTER ASSIST
CLAIMANTS THROUGH NON CALL
CENTER OPTIONS. KNOW WHETHER
THEY'RE A SUCCESSFULLY HELPING
PEOPLE WHO DO YOU CALL THEM.
THE FIRST TIME THEY CALL.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT NOW THOUGH IS
THOSE POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
ARE ONLY AS GOOD AS CARRYING
THEM OUT SO WE'LL SEE TOWARDS
THE BOTTOM OF PAGE TO. THE
AREAS WERE STILL ASSESSING IS
PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED ARE
PENDING IMPLEMENTATION ARE THE
AREAS OF REGULARLY REVIEWING
THE DATA THAT THEY ARE NOW ABLE
TO COLLECT. WHEN EDIE DOES
CONDUCT REGULAR REVIEWS OF THIS
DATA ARE THEY ASSISTING
CLAIMANTS THE FIRST TIME I CALL
WATER CLAIMANTS CALLING ABOUT.
THAT WHAT OTHER CLAIMANTS
CALLING ABOUT DATA WILL HELP
THEM DO TWO THINGS IT WILL HELP
THEM BETTER TRAIN CALL CENTER
AGENTS ON THE MOST COMMONLY
REQUESTED ITEMS FOR ASSISTANCE.
AND THAT IT WILL ALSO HELP THEM
PROVIDE THOSE NON CALL CENTER
SERVICE OPTIONS. TO SO PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE TO CALL THE CALL
CENTER THEY CAN HELP THEMSELVES
THROUGH EDIE'S WEBSITE. THAT'LL
HELP CLAIMANTS RECEIVE MORE
TIMELY ASSISTANCE IT'LL ALSO
REDUCE THE VOLUME OF PEOPLE
CALLING EDIE'S CALL CENTER. SO
IMPORTANT FIRST STEPS HERE IN
THE AREA OF THE CALL CENTER BUT
EDIE NOW HAS TO CONDUCT THIS
REGULAR DATA REVIEW AND USE IT
TO ACTUALLY IMPROVE THEIR
OPERATIONS. AND THEN LASTLY ON
THE THIRD PAGE THE AREA FRAUD
PREVENTION AND DETECTION. AGAIN
GOOD EARLY FIRST STEPS FROM EDT
THEY'VE IMPROVED THEIR
COORDINATION WITH BANK OF
AMERICA THEY HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY OF REVIEWING
THE ACCOUNT ACTIVITY NOW WHICH
ACCOUNTS ARE FROZEN WHICH
ACCOUNTS ARE BEING UNFROZEN WHY
ARE THOSE ACCOUNTS BEING FROZEN
OR UNFROZEN THEIR SYSTEMS FOR
TRACKING ALL THAT INFORMATION
ARE IMPROVED SINCE THE TIME WE
WERE DOING OUR AUDIT. THEY'VE
ALSO PROVIDED CLEAR INFORMATION
ON THEIR WEBSITE. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE IDENTITIES
WERE STOLEN HOW TO RESOLVE
THEIR PENDING TAX LIABILITIES
AS A RESULT OF THAT. SOME OF
THESE BENEFITS ARE TAXABLE
BENEFITS. IF YOUR IDENTITY WAS
STOLEN AND YOU NEVER ACTUALLY
RECEIVE THEM YOU MAY BE FACING
A TAX LIABILITY THAT YOU DON'T
ACTUALLY. OWN EDIE'S PROVIDED
CLEAR INSTRUCTIONS NOW ABOUT
HOW TO CONTACT THEM AND GET
YOUR ISSUE RESOLVED SO GRAND
REALLY GOOD FIRST STEPS. WITH
RESPECT TO FRAUD PREVENTION AND
DETECTION I WANT TO FOCUS ON
TWO AREAS ONE IS THE CREATION
OF A FRAUD UNIT AS THE STATE
AUDITOR MENTIONED. A MOMENT AGO
WHEN WE CONDUCTED OUR AUDIT
EDIE'S FRAUD PREVENTION
APPROACHES A PATCHWORK
PATCHWORK APPROACH. IT WAS
DEPENDED ON SIX DIFFERENT UNITS
WITH A NEEDY ALL COORDINATING
EFFECTIVELY WITH ONE ANOTHER SO
WE RECOMMENDED THEY CREATE A
FRAUD UNIT TO CENTRALIZE. THAT
VIEW OF FRAUD PREVENTION AND
DETECTION. AND THIS IS ACTUALLY
IN LINE WITH FRAUD PREVENTION
BEST PRACTICES SO THAT UNIT
NEEDS TO BE TASKED WITH THE
RIGHT. RESPONSIBILITIES AND
THEN ENABLED WITH THE RIGHT
AUTHORITIES. THE GOD NEWS IS
EDT IS DONE THAT THEY HAVE
CREATED THAT UNIT. THEY HAVE
TASKED IT WITH THE RIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES AND THEY HAVE
ASSIGNED AT THE PROPER
AUTHORITY WHATWE'RE WAITING ON
NOW IS THE FOR THAT UNIT TO BE
FULLY STAFFED. THEY ARE
RECRUITING THE MISTER HARRIS
THAT OR YOU CONTINUE ON THIS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND
IMPACTFUL IS THERE A WAY THAT-
SOME FOLKS CAN ACCESS THIS
DOCUMENT ONLINE IS AVAILABLE ON
YOUR WEBSITE. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS THIS DOCUMENT
THE STOCK. WE CAN MAKE IT
AVAILABLE IT IS NOT ON THE
WEBSITE RIGHT NOW ALL OF THE
INFORMATION ABOUT EACH
RECOMMENDATION IS ON THE
WEBSITE BUT NOT IN THIS FORMAT.
SO THE RECOMMENDATION STATUS IS
ON THE WEBSITE THIS FORMAT WE
CAN ABSOLUTELY MAKE IT
AVAILABLE. OKAY WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT. YOU KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
OTHERS HAVE ACCESS TO THE STOCK
MINUTES HERE READING THROUGH IT.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL WRAP UP SO
EDIE'S FRAUD UNIT GOOD FOR
STEPS WE JUST NEED TO SEE THEM
STAFF THE UNIT THEY'VE BEEN
RECRUITING FOR THAT UNIT THEY
JUST NEED TO FILL THE POSITIONS
NOW AND THAT WILL HAVE BEEN A
FULLY IMPLEMENTED
RECOMMENDATION ONCE THEY DO SO.
LASTLY ASSESSING WHICH FRAUD
PREVENTION AND DETECTION TOOLS
ARE EFFECTIVE VERSUS THOSE THAT
ARE NOT YOU'LL SEE IN THE HAND
OUT THIS IS UNDER THE MAY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE HEADING THIS
IS A FULLY IMPLEMENTED
RECOMMENDATION THE REASON FOR
THAT IS EDT NOW HAS A ROBUST
PLAN FOR HOW IT WILL ASSESS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF ITS TOOLS AND
THEY SHOWED US EARLY SIGNS THAT
THEY ARE IN FACT CARRYING THAT
PLAN OUT. THEY JUST STARTED SO
THIS IS ANOTHER AREA WHERE
THEY'RE GONNA NEED TO CONTINUE
TO SUSTAIN THE EARLY PROGRESS
THAT THEY'VE MADE AND THIS IS
NOW A STATUTORY REQUIREMENT AS
WELL. BILL COMING OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. LAST JULY. A DOCTOR
THIS IS A STATUTORY REQUIREMENT
EDT HAS TO REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE REGULARLY ABOUT ITS
ASSESSMENT OF THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF ITS FRAUD PREVENTION TOOLS
SO THERE'S STATUTORY
ACCOUNTABILITY NOW EDT NEEDS TO
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH ITS
ASSESSMENTS- AND WILL KEEP TABS
ON THEM FOR THAT AS WELL.
THAT'S THE CONCLUSION OF MY
SUMMARY BUT I BE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS MEMBERS MIGHT
HAVE ABOUT. THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS OR THE STATUS.
OF THEM RIGHT NOW. JACKIE YEAH
YOU YOU INDICATED THAT THE
HIDEOUS IN THE FORMATION OF
CREATING THIS OF FRAUD UNIT AND
THAT THEY'VE FORMULATED IT IS
OR ANY PROJECTION AS TO WHEN
THEY MAY BE. STAFFING THIS UNIT.
I WOULD DEFERRED EDT ON WHEN
THEY EXPECT TO BE FULLY STAFFED
I KNOW WE'VE SEEN RECRUITMENT
EFFORTS THEY'VE ADVERTISED
POSITIONS- FOR THAT UNIT SO-
AND IT'S- THERE ARE PARTIAL
STAFFING IT'S JUST NOT. CLOSE
TO FULL STAFFING YET. OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT OVERVIEW AND
UPDATE- I THINK IT'S IT IS GOOD
TO HEAR THAT THERE HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IS MADE ON
MANY OF YOUR HOT SPOT ON
RECOMMENDATIONS. DOES SEEM LIKE
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT WORK
REMAINING AND THAT. IN SUMMARY
THAT THERE THE PLANS HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED BUT THERE ARE A LOT
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
STILL NEED TO BE
OPERATIONALIZED. BOB HAS THE
PACE IF THEY'RE PART OF
PROGRESS FELT. FAST SLOWER WHAT
YOU WOULD HAVE EXPECTED. WELL
WE'VE WE'VE PLACED AND IT'S IN
THE DOCUMENT BUT EACH OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS HAD EXPECTED
TIME FRAMES WITHIN WHICH WE
WANTED THEM TO ACCOMPLISH THESE
TASKS EDT APPEARS TO HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWING THOSE TIMELINE SO TO
THAT END I WOULD SAY. FOR THE
MAJORITY OF THESE IT'S BEEN ON
PACE WITH WHAT WE ARE EXPECTING
THEM TO ACCOMPLISH. I KNOW
WE'VE BEEN DOING WE'VE BEEN
HAVING HEARINGS FOR. GOSH ABOUT
SIXTEEN MONTHS SO IT CAN OFTEN
SEEM FRUSTRATINGLY SLOW- FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO SHIFT IN THESE
THINGS BUT- GOOD TO HEAR THAT
THERE IS ON TRACK WITH THE
PROJECT PLAN THAT YOU SET OUT.
AND APPLE I'VE GOT A QUESTION
FOR YOU- THIS HALL AS YOU WALK
THROUGH KIND OF THAT THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE ON IT HE YOU POINTED OUT
WHICH BUT CENTER LAYERED IN
WITH MANY OF US HAVE THAT MANY
OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
THINGS THAT. WERE IDENTIFIED.
TEN YEARS AGO FIVE YEARS AGO
TWO YEARS AGO. WHAT AT ITS WHAT
ADVICE WOULD OU LEAVE US WITH
TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE NOT
SITTING HERE AGAIN TEN YEARS
FROM NOW HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT THEY FOLLOW THROUGH AND
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THE CHANGES
THAT ARE GOING TO ENSURE THAT
THAT THAT THIS IS THE LAST TIME
WE DEAL WITH THIS FIASCO. WELL
I WAS GOING TO FALL ON THE
ANSWER MISTER HARRIS IS GAVE IN
AND THE DISCUSSION YOU JUST
SIXTEEN MONTHS OF HEARINGS THE
LEGISLATURE WHAT WHAT MY OFFICE
HAS BEEN DOING MORE AND MORE IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS IS FOCUSING
ON MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE LEGISLATURE. BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE IT AT THE STATE
AUDITOR DOES NOT HAVE
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY WE CAN'T
FORCE THE ADMINISTRATION TO DO
CERTAIN THINGS BUT CERTAINLY WE
CAN PARTNER WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE STRONG
OVERSIGHT TO GIVE YOU THE
INFORMATION YOU NEED. TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT WE
NEED TO PUT THIS IN STATUTE AND
IT'S NOT JUST EIGHTY IT'S OTHER
STATE DEPARTMENTS IF THEY HAVE
SOMETHING IN STATURE THAT
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO THEIR
MUCH MORE INCLINED TO DO IT
THEN IF THE STATE AUDITOR TELLS
AND TO DO IT NOW I. EIGHTY I
THINK AND THERE ARE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THEM OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST YEAR OR TEN MONTHS
THAT WE'VE BEEN AFTER WE ISSUED
THE REPORT HAS BEEN VERY
RESPONSIVE TO A LOT OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE MADE
SOME OF THE PROGRESS. HAS BEEN
SLOWER THAN WE WOULD LIKE AS AS
MR HARRIS SAID. SOME OF IT'S ON
PACE SOME OF IT IS A LITTLE TOO
SLOW. LIKE WE'RE EXPECTING SOME
THINGS AND JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. BUT YOU HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE SOME OF THAT IS I.
T. THEY HAVE A LEGACY SYSTEM
MOST. WORKFORCE DATA SYSTEMS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY OUR LEGACY
SYSTEMS SO WE HAVE TO CHIP AWAY
AT THAT AND TRY TO IMPROVE
THAT. BUT MY THOUGHTS OR MY
OBSERVATION IS. I THINK. STRONG
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT WHICH WE
HAVE SEEN IN THE LAST YEAR AND
A HALF. AND A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN MY OFFICE AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND MAKING SURE
THAT IF THERE ARE THINGS WE
THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD. YOU KNOW AN ACT TO TRY
TO. TRY TO GET INTO STATE LAW.
IT WILL COMPEL A DEPARTMENT
LIKE ANY DAY AND SOME OF THE
OTHER DEPARTMENTS THAT WE OUGHT
IT. TO ACTUALLY DO THINGS THE
OTHER THING IS OUR FOLLOW UP
PROCESS AND HAVING THESE KINDS
OF HEARINGS WHERE. THE
DEPARTMENT KNOWS I MEAN THAT
THEY WERE CONTACTING MISTER
HARRIS. ON THURSDAY I MET WITH
HIM BEFORE I WORK FROM HOME ON
FRIDAY AND HE WAS. CALLING ON
FRIDAY EDIE'S TRYING TO STILL
GET ME SOME INFORMATION BECAUSE
THEY KNEW. THIS HEARING WAS
HAPPENING AND THEY WANTED US TO
BE ABLE TO SAY. YEAH THEY'VE
MADE PROGRESS AS FAR AS PUTTING
A PLAN TOGETHER PUTTING THAT
WERE- THAT FRIED UNIT TOGETHER
THEY'RE STARTING TO STAFF A
UNIT. SO I THINK PERSISTENT
OVERSIGHT AND I KNOW IT'S A LOT
OF WORK BECAUSE YOU HAVE A LOT
OF RESPONSIBILITIES. BUT
PERSISTENT OVER STATE BY THE
LEGISLATURE BY THE VARIOUS
COMMITTEES. AND CERTAINLY
PUTTING THINGS INTO STATE LAW.
AND THEN USING THIS OFFICE.
LONG AFTER I'M GONE THIS OFFICE
IS GOING TO BE FINE. I'M GONNA
MISS IT I'M HONORED TO HAVE
SERVED AS LONG AS I DID- BUT I
THINK THAT PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE THE
TALENTED STAFF THAT THAT THE
OFFICE HAS. WILL WILL ALLOW YOU
TO YOU AS MEMBERS TO CONTINUE
TO STAY ON TOP OF THIS ISSUE.
AND OTHER ISSUES THAT THAT
CALIFORNIA FACES. THANK YOU FOR
THAT WE VALUE YOUR PARTNERSHIP
AS WELL. WELL WE CAN CELEBRATE
YOUR RETIREMENT I'M NOT SURE
I'M READY TO. HAVE I'M NOT
READY TO THERE JUST YET
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE ON EDT
AND THE FRAMEWORK THAT IT'S
TAKEN US TO GET HERE I THINK
IT'S SO INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
I'M SURE WE'LL WE'RE GONNA BE
RELYING ON YOU EVEN. AFTER YOU
YOUR HOPES ARE MEANT I'M NOT
ANYWHERE AND I WOULD JUST SAY-
MISTER HARRIS WHEN YOU GET A
MOMENT OR WHEN YOUR OFFICE GETS
A MOMENT IF YOU CAN SEND IT IS
VERY- FOUR SHEETS OF
COMPREHENSIVE DATA. TO MICHAEL
ON ON BUDGET STAFF SO THAT WE
CAN PUT IT UP ON THE WEBSITE AS
WELL THAT WOULD BE. INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL AS THERE'S FOLKS
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW IN IN REAL
TIME ASKING ASKING FOR THE
INFORMATION SO AS. SOON AS YOU
CAN PLEASE LET US KNOW. SALAS
MARK. THANK YOU CHAIR- AND MY-
AT AGREE MORE YOU PER
ACCOUNTABLE IT'S A MAY THAT ONE
WE SET A HEARING HOW MUCH WORK
GETS DONE RIGHT BEFORE THE
HEARING SO THAT THEY HAVE
SOMETHING TO REPORT ON SO I
WANTED TO DELVE INTO SOMETHING
THAT YOU AND MR HER SEXUALLY
TOUCHED UPON- YOU KNOW THE
REPORT CONCLUDED THAT EDIE'S
FAILURE TO PLAN FOR RECESSION
HINDERED ITS RESPONSE TO THE
SURGEON CLAIMS. SO THE REPORT
RECOMMENDED THE EDT MEDIALLY
BEGIN MODELING WORK FLOW
PROJECTIONS AND DEVELOP
STAFFING PLANS AROUND CERTAIN
SCENARIOS GIVEN THE CYCLICAL
NATURE THAT YOU BOTH SPOKE
ABOUT THE ECONOMY AND
UNEMPLOYMENT HE DOES A LITTLE
PERPLEXED TO THE EDT DIDN'T
ALREADY HAVE PLANS FOR DEALING
WITH THE ECONOMIC DOWN TERMS OF
SPIKES IN UNEMPLOYMENT. SO I'M
JUST WONDERING WHAT EDT IS
PROVIDED YOU IN TERMS OF
WORKLOAD PROJECTIONS AND
STAFFING PLANS IN THE AND IF
YOU COULD SPEAK TO THE QUALITY
AND POTENTIAL EFFECTIVENESS OF
ANY NEW WORKLOAD OUR STAFFING
PLANS TO ADDRESS A LOT OF THESE
ISSUES I KNOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IT AT A AT A BIG LEVEL
BUT I'M JUST WONDERING HAVE YOU
ACTUALLY SEEN THEM PUT TEAMS
TOGETHER- YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR
LIKES TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW A
STRIKE TEAM FOR INSTANCE HAVE
YOU SEEN THAT APPLE DEPARTMENT.
TO START WORKING THROUGH THESE
ISSUES. SO WE'VE ONLY SEEN THAT
APART CLAIM THAT IT'S WERE ON
THIS THEY'VE NOT THEY'VE NOT
CLAIMS TO US THAT THEY ARE DONE
IN THIS AREA- THE DEPARTMENTS
TALK TO US ABOUT. FORMING A
WORKLOAD FORECASTING UNIT AND
WORKING WITH A CONTRACTOR TO
TRY AND DEVELOP WHAT THEY CALL
WHAT IF SCENARIOS- TO PREDICT
ITS WORKLOAD- BUT CERTAINLY
THIS IS ONE WHERE WE'RE WE'RE
NOT SAYING THEY'RE EVEN
PARTIALLY DONE YET THIS IS A
PENDING RECOMMENDATION AND
WE'VE ONLY SEEN VERY. EARLY
STATEMENTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
ABOUT WHAT THEY'VE DONE TO
ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM. GOT IT
BUT YOU HAVEN'T SEEN ANY
WORKPLACE TEAMS OR MANAGERS
BEING ASSIGNED TO ACTUALLY
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES. SO THE
DEPARTMENTS CLAIMING THAT WE
WERE JUST NOT SEEN THE
DOCUMENTATION AT. OKAY ALL
RIGHT THAT'S QUESTION WILL
FOLLOW UP WITH THE NEXT PANEL
ON DVD THAT. I WANTED TO ASK
ANOTHER QUESTION IF I COULD YOU
KNOW THE OTHER. REPORT PROVIDED
A LITANY OF GREAT
RECOMMENDATIONS YOU KNOW AND
THAT APPROVING EASY THESE
EFFORTS. TO PROCESS CLAIMS
MANAGE WORKLOAD AND IMPROVE
PERFORMANCE. AT THE CALL
CENTERS. BUT JUST THRESHOLD
OVERALL ON A SCALE OF ONE TO
TEN YOU KNOW ONE BEING AWFUL
TEN BEING GREAT FOR I WOULD
JUST SAY EDIE'S PERFORMANCES.
IN IMPLEMENTING THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS RIGHT NOW. SO
AGAIN THEY'VE THEY'VE STAYED
MOSTLY NOT ENTIRELY ON SCHEDULE
WITH THE ROAD MAP THAT WE LAID
OUT FOR THEM- CERTAINLY.
CONTINUED. THIS LEGISLATIVE
HEARINGS IN THE ACCOUNTABILITY
OF THE ATTENTION THAT'S BEEN
BROUGHT TO THEM OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS. SHE LAST FEW MONTHS.
OKAY AND I WAS JUST TRYING TO
DO THE MATH AND I THINK. BASED
OFF OF WHAT YOU PROVIDED- YOU
KNOW. THE COMMITTEE HERE TODAY
YOU KNOW THIRTEEN OUT OF TWENTY
ONE THAT'S LIKE 62% OF IT
ACTUALLY BEING DONE. IS THAT
CORRECT. THAT SOUNDS ABOUT
RIGHT I HAVEN'T I HAVEN'T DONE
THAT SPECIFIC NOW BUT YES OKAY
ALL RIGHT AND I WANTED TO ASK
ANOTHER QUESTION WE HAVEN'T
TOUCHED UPON IT TOO MUCH BUT I
KNOW MY OFFICES RECEIVE CALLS
YOU DON'T ADDITION TO HELPING
PEOPLE PROCESS THEIR CLAIMS
THROUGH EDT. BUT ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT- PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN CALLING ABOUT IT WE'VE
BEEN ASSISTING TO IS THE
UTILITIES BENEFITS. SYSTEMS
MODERNIZATION PROJECT RIGHT
JUST BCAUSE THEY BUT FOLLOWING
UP UNDER THAT YOU AYE. SO IT'S
ONE OF ASK AND YOU KNOW IT WHAT
LET ME JUST LET ME FRAME IT THE
RIGHT WAY SO OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE REPORT
PERTAINS TO EDIE'S BENEFIT
SYSTEMS MODERNIZATION PROJECT
WHICH IS A PROJECT TO MODERNIZE
EDIE'S YOU WHY AND OTHER
BENEFITS SYSTEMS. THIS PROJECT
BEGAN IN TWENTY SIXTEEN BUT WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR AND THE OTHER
REPORT YOU THOUGHT EDT BY JUNE
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE SHOULD AT
LEAST IDENTIFY THE ELEMENTS OF
THE OF THE BENEFITS SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION PROJECT THAT CAN
ASSIST DVD AND MAKING TIMELY
PAYMENTS AND CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED. INCREMENTALLY AND
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED ELEVEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS TDD TO REFOCUS
ON THIS PROJECT AND I BELIEVE
THE EDT HAS IMPLEMENTED THIS
RECOGNITION WE HAVE ALLOCATED
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TO HELP
SO COULD YOU PLEASE JUST TRY TO
SUMMARIZE WHAT INCREMENTAL
MODIFICATIONS EDT HAS
IDENTIFIED OR IMPLEMENTED TO
IMPROVE ITS CLAIMS PROCESS. AND
THAT JUST KIND OF THE IMPACTS
THAT THAT'S GOING TO HAVE. SO
IT WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU.
WITH THE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC AREAS THAT EDIE'S
IDENTIFY CAN BE AND
INCREMENTALLY IMPLEMENTED BUT
THEY HAVE IDENTIFIED THE
PORTIONS OF THE B. S. M.
PROJECT. THAT THEY CAN
IMPLEMENT INCREMENTALLY THAT
WOULD PROVIDE MORE IMMEDIATE
ASSISTANCE TO FOLKS- IN GETTING
THEIR CLAIMS PROCESS BUT TO THE
SPECIFIC AREAS AND THERE WERE
SIX OF THEM THAT THEY
IDENTIFIED- THAT THEY COULD
IMPLEMENT IN A MORE TIMELY
FASHION WE'D HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU WITH THAT INFORMATION-
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT IT'S STILL WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ALLOCATES
RESOURCES FOR THIS YEAR WE
EXPECT TO SEE RESULTS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER SALAS. IN
MY OPENING REMARKS I MENTIONED
THAT WE HAD THE LEGISLATURE
HAD. ALLOCATED A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF MONEY FOR. ADDITIONAL
STAFFING AND A TOTAL OF. TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS THE WORKLOAD BACKLOG.
BUT AUDITOR HOW YOU MENTIONED
BRIEFLY AND ISSUE RELATED TO I.
T. AND TECHNOLOGY TESE LEGACY.
OF PROGRAMS THAT DON'T FUNCTION
IN TODAY'S SOCIETY. I'M CURIOUS
IF- YOU CAN SHARE. TIMELINE IN
TERMS OF WHAT WILL IT TAKE TO
IN MANY WAYS. TURN THIS TITANIC
AROUND- AND REALLY IMPROVE THE
TECHNOLOGY WITHIN EDT. SO THAT
WE HAVE A MORE MODERN SYSTEM
THAT CAN REALLY TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE NEEDS OF THE STATE-
I KNOW IT CAN'T HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT. BUT I REALLY DO
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO SET
GOALS AND WE NEED TO MEET THOSE
GOALS. IN ORDER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO BE ABLE TO SHIFT
AND REALLY TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE
THAT THE SAFETY NET. THAT
REALLY SHOULD JUST BE A
FUNCTIONING SAFETY NET. DOESN'T
HAVE PEOPLE FALLING THROUGH IT
BECAUSE OF THESE GAPING HOLES
WITHIN THE SAFETY NET AND A
LARGE PART OF THAT. IS SIMPLY
NO MATTER HOW MANY PEOPLE WE
PUT BEHIND IT HOW MANY PEOPLE
WE HIRE. HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
TRAINED. TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT AND HIRING
PEOPLE. WHAT'S THE USE IF THE
SYSTEM IS SO SLOW. THAT IT
CAN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT A NEW
WORK FORCE OR THE NEED FROM
PEOPLE REQUIRING ASSISTANCE
FROM EDT. MISTER HARRIS CAN
ASSIST ME WITH THIS BUT AS HE
JUST INDICATED THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE AN INCREMENTAL APPROACH.
SO ONE OF ONE OF BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE AS THE AUDITOR AND
LOOKING AT A LOT OF I. T.
PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA
OBVIOUSLY. THE SYSTEM'S EDT
SYSTEM IS HUGE AND THEY NEED TO
DO T INCREMENTALLY SO I THINK
WHAT I CAN'T GIVE YOU A TIME
FRAME BECAUSE WE WOULD NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THE INCREMENTS THAT
THEY'VE IDENTIFIED THAT ARE.
CRITICAL MISSION CRITICAL- SO
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN WHEN WE LOOK
AT DEPARTMENTS THAT WANT TO
UNDERTAKE AND I. T. PROJECT
EITHER DESIGNING A NEW PROJECT
OR IMPLEMENTING CHANGES TO AN
EXISTING PROJECT. IS SCOPE
CREEP SO YOU MADE USE ME YOU
MAY SAID WE'RE GOING TO DO AN
INCOME AND CROWN- PROSTATE
WE'RE GONNA USE AN INCREMENTAL
PROCESS WHICH THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY- ADVISES START
SHOULD PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
EDT- BUT WHAT WE HAVE TENDED TO
SEE IS HERE ARE MISSION
CRITICAL THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
FIX AN EDT SYSTEM. BUT THEN THE
VENDOR GETS IN ITS AS WELL
WOULD BE NICE TO HAVE THIS NICE
TO HAVE THAT NICE TO HAVE THAT
THEN YOU GET THE SCOPE CREEP
NOW YOUR YEARS AND YEARS AWAY
FROM BEING ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH.
THE MISSION CRITICAL ARE
CHANGES THAT WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ACCESSING THE SYSTEM SO
WHAT I BELIEVE SHOULD HAPPEN
IS. EDT IDENTIFYING THIS
INCREMENTAL APPROACH AND THEN
SETTING TIMELINES WHAT ARE THE
SPECIFIC TIMELINES FOR US BEING
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THESE MISSION
CRITICAL CHANGES TO THE SYSTEM
AND LET'S HOLD ON TO THAT AND
NOT ALLOW ANY SCOPE CREEP-
THOSE ARE NICE TO HAVES AND WE
CAN DO THAT DOWN THE ROAD BUT
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET MONEY TO
DO THAT UNTIL YOU ACCOMPLISH
THIS. BECAUSE THESE ARE THE
THINGS THAT YOU AS THE AGENCY
AND WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
ACKNOWLEDGE A DETERMINED ARE
THE THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
IMPROVED MODERNIZE ETCETERA
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT GETS DONE
SO I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD BE ABLE TO. PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT. BUT ALSO HOLD ON YOU
KNOW THE PERSON BRING JUST. WE
GET YOU MONEY DO THESE THINGS.
YOU NEED TO GET THOSE THINGS
DONE BEFORE WE'RE WILLING TO.
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND
MISTER SALAS TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION RELATED TO- SOME OF
THE WORKLOAD STAFFING AND
PLANNING THOSE ARE AREAS THAT
WE FELT AS WE SAY ON THIS
HANDOUT. THEY NEED TO DO THAT
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING THE
REPORT. YOU KNOW I MEAN YOU'VE
BEEN PROCESSING UNEMPLOYMENT
CLAIMS FOR DECADES YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO TO PROCESS
CLAIMS SO. AS WE HAVE ON HERE
WERE SAYING PENDING WHICH MEANS
THEY HAVEN'T MADE MUCH PROGRESS
SO. IF THAT'S AN AREA THAT I
WOULD FOCUS ON I WOULD BE
DISAPPOINTED IN THEIR
PERFORMANCE BECAUSE THEY NEED
TO PUT THAT WORKLOAD PLAN
TOGETHER. AND PROJECTIONS
BECAUSE- HOW DO YOU DETERMINE
HOW MANY STAFF YOU WANNA HIRE
HOW DO YOU DETERMINE HOW MUCH
MONEY YOU NEED THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION TO
PROVIDE. SO THAT WE CAN HIRE
THE APPROPRIATE STAFF WHAT KIND
OF TRAINING DO WE NEED TO
PROVIDE TO THESE FOLKS IF WE'RE
GOING TO MODERNIZE THE SYSTEM.
WHAT KIND OF TRAINING TO OUR
STAFF NEED TO YOU TO HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO USE THAT SYSTEM AS
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE SO.
THEY HAVE MADE PROGRESS IN YOUR
RIGHT IT'S ABOUT SIXTY FIVE
PERCENT- IT THIRTEEN OUT OF
TWENTY ONE- SO BUT BUT AREAS AS
FAR AS PLANNING PROJECTIONS
ANALYSIS. IS WHERE IN SOME
AREAS THEY'VE DONE WELL IN SOME
AREAS THEY HAVE DONE HAVE NOT
DONE AS WELL- AND THIS IS AN
AREA THAT WE FELT THEY NEEDED
TO ADDRESS IMMEDIATELY AND- YOU
KNOW HERE WE ARE IT'S OCTOBER.
SO HOPEFULLY THAT ANSWERED BOTH
BOTH YOUR QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FIFTY TWO NORTH. I
KNOW IN YOUR AD JANUARY AUDIT
YOU HAD A ESTIMATE OF FRAUD
THAT WAS I THINK TEN POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS HAVE YOU
REVISED THAT ESTIMATE. NOW
WE'VE NOT THAT'S THE ESTIMATE
AT THE TIME WE COMPLETED THE
AUDIT WOULD NOT COME BACK TO
REVISE THAT. IF YOU HAVEN'T
LOOKED AT THE DIFFERENT TACK
INTO. REFINING THEM NO ALTHOUGH
EDT ITSELF AROUND THE SAME TIME
WE PUBLISH THE AUDIT- ESTIMATED
THAT IT COULD BE AS MUCH AS
THIRTY BILLION BUT NOW WE HAVE
NOT COME UP WITH A SEPARATE.
CHECK INTO THAT WITH OUR NEXT
PANELIST. OKAY IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS AND FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY WE WILL MOVE ON
TOWARDS ADAM PANEL NUMBER TWO.
THANK YOU. MUCH OF IT SHOULD BE
PERFECT FOR ME I JUST GOT IT
OKAY WE HAVE FOR THOSE OF YOU
WATCHING ONLINE WE HAVE
RECEIVED THE FOUR PAGE
DOCUMENT- PROVIDED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE AND THAT
SHOULD BE UP ON OUR WEBSITE
VERY SHORTLY IF YOU'RE WATCHING
ONLINE AND WANT TO SEE IT
SHOULD BE A VERY SOON. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA START WITH
OUR PRESENTATION FOR A PANEL
NUMBER TWO IF WE HAVE DIRECTOR
OF EDT DIRECTOR SIGNS ONLINE.
AS WELL AS THE REST OF HER
STAFF AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. MORE GLOBAL INTRODUCED
THAT STAFF AS WE GO ALONG AS
WELL AS ALEJO. CHARACTER SIGNED
GOOD AFTERNOON. REMEMBERS
CHAIRS ONE CHER APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY. I
AM I AM BY THE DISCUSSIONS AND
REPORT OF THE LEGISLATOR-
AUDITOR DAHLE. STATE AUDITOR
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS THAT
ALL RIGHT TO WHO- WAS OUT AS A
PRIVATE CITIZEN- DURING THE
TIME OF THE PANDEMIC WELL I
CAME TO. BE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
IN JANUARY AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FRUSTRATIONS THE
PEOPLE HAVE HAD. FOR WAITING
FOR IMPROVEMENTS. WHAT I CAN
TELL YOU IS THAT. A SUBSTANTIAL
IS THE AUDITOR STAFF SENATORS
SUBSTANTIAL PORTION OF THESE
HAVE BEEN COMPLETE.
APPROXIMATELY 70% ACCORDING TO
OUR ESTIMATION. SO FOR THE
RECORD I AM WE JUST SCIENCE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE DEPARTMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT AND WITH ME TODAY
ARE IMAGE AMY FAULKNER WHO IS
OUR CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS. CHRIS YES STATEN
OUR UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BRANCH DEPUTY DIRECTOR KEVIN
METALIK CHIEF OF FISCAL
PROGRAMS DIVISION EXCUSE ME
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS AND WHAT MANY OF YOU
HAVE MET HIM AND CALEB CORRAL
CHIEF OF THE FISCAL PROGRAMS
DIVISION THEY WILL BE AVAILABLE
TODAY TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS.
SO NOW TO MURRAY. 70% OF THE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
COMPLETE. WE HAVE MET EVERY
DEADLINE. AND THOSE REMAINING
ARE EITHER NOT YET DO OR THEIR
PRIVATE CATERED S. AND HIS.
LARGE AS THE AUDITOR STAFF SAID
ONE PART COMPLETE AND THE OTHER
REQUIRING MONITORING OF A TRUMP.
HAVING BEEN IN STATE GOVERNMENT
OFTEN KNOWN FOR FORTY YEARS I
SAY THAT- MONITORING IS. IS
EVERY DEPARTMENT COULD YOU
COULD. IT'S A VALUABLE TO EVERY
DEPARTMENT- DISTRICT THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE 68% PERCENT
COMPLETE WE'RE ON TRACK TO
REACH 75% BY DECEMBER A 100% OF
THE SHORT TERM RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE COMPLETE A 100% OF THE NEAR
TERM RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
COMPLETE. AND THE LONG TERM OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ALL THE
TRUCKERS. BEHIND THOSE NUMBERS
ARE IMPORTANT IMPROVEMENTS SOME
OF WHICH OF THE STATE ARCHER'S
OFFICE AS MENTIONED ALREADY.
LAUNCHED LAUNCHED A VIRTUAL
CALL BACK FEATURE TO CUT DOWN
CLAIMANTSTWO WEEKS SO THEY
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT ON THE
PHONE. WE DEPLOYED OUR IDENTITY
VERIFICATION AND FRAUD FILTERS
THAT BLOCK A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
BILLIONDOLLARS IN FUNCTIONS.
WE ELIMINATED THE BACKLOG OF
ONE POINT SIX CLAIM ONE POINT
SIX CLAIMS MILLION CLAIMS FROM
LAST YEAR WHEN WE SET UP THE-
WE SET UP A FORM TEN NINETY
NINE G. INFORMATION HELPLINE TO
HELP CLAIMANTS WITH TAX
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE FATHER
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER. AND IT
WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL. IN
ADDITION WE'RE OVERHAULING OUR
BENEFITS SYSTEM TECHNOLOGY AND
OUR BUSINESS PROCESSES TO
DELIVER SERVICES. FOCUS FIRST
ON THE CLAIMANT'S NEEDS. DURING
THE PANDEMIC IT BECAME VERY
CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO REFOCUS
OUR IT MODERNIZATION WHICH HAD
BEGUN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC TO BE
CLAIMANTS CENTER. A REVIEW OF
OUR BENEFIT PROGRAM RULES AND
BUSINESS PROCESSES WHICH IS THE
FIRST STEP. TO THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A NEW I. T. SYSTEM HAS BEGUN
THIS MONTH AND SOME CHANGES
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE. I
APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WE'VE HAD WITH THE
LEGISLATURE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC UNION LEADERSHIP AND
ACTIONS WILL HELP US CONTINUE
TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS. BOTH WITH
BUDGET ALLOCATIONS AS A
CHAIRPERSON MENTIONED AND
LEGISLATION. TODAY WE ARE
STRONGER MORE EFFICIENT AND
HAVE PUT IN PLACE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT WILL HAVE LASTING
BENEFITS. LEGISLATURE HAS
CODIFIED MANY OF THESE KEY
IMPROVEMENTS AND A SPECIAL
THANKS TO THOSE PRESENT TODAY
WHO STEP FORWARD TO DO THAT. MY
EMPLOYMENT IN THIS NEW
LEGISLATION AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE STRIKE
TEAM. AND THE STATE AUDITOR.
THIS DEPARTMENT IS BEING
TRANSFORMED. WE ARE PAYING
BENEFITS FASTER ANYMORE IN IN A
MORE SECURE WAY. WE PAID A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN BENEFITS TO
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE OVER THE
PANDEMIC THAT'S FOUR TIMES AS
MUCH AS THE WORST TWO YEARS OF
THE GREAT RECESSION COMBINED.
WELL FOR FILLING THE CSA AND
STRETCHING RECOMMENDATIONS WE
IMPLEMENTED MAJOR NEW
UNANTICIPATED FEDERAL PROGRAMS.%
SINCE JANUARY WE WERE PAYING
THREE MILLION PEOPLE. ABOUT ONE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS PLUS
A WEEK. WE HIRED OVER SIX
THOUSAND WORKERS DURING THE
PANDEMIC INCLUDING MORE THAN
THIRTEEN HUNDRED OFFICE
TECHNICIANS AND CALL CENTER
EXPERTS SINCE MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY. WE IMPLEMENTED THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN FASTER
THAN PROMISED INCLUDING
DELIVERING P. YOU SEE BENEFITS
FOR SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE. IN JUNE WE AUTOMATED
THE BENEFIT YEAR RENEWAL. THE
BENEFIT YEAR END IN JULY WE
INSTITUTED A PAY NOW POLICY TO
HELP CLAIMANTS WITH INDIAN
CLAIMS THAT HAS EXPEDITED SINCE
THAT TIME PAYMENT FOR NEARLY
FOUR. HUNDRED THOUSAND CLAIMS.
AT THE END OF THE MOST OF THE
FEDERAL PROGRAMS SEPTEMBER THE
FOURTH AUTOMATICALLY EXTENDED
AN ADDITIONAL WEEK TO THE FETID
PROGRAM FOR THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND CLAIMS. WE ALSO
PUT A STOP TO THE UNPRECEDENTED
LEVELS FRAUD ACTIVITY FROM
TWENTY TWENTY WE KNOW HOW THE
SYSTEM IS MORE SECURE THAN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO NOTE IS THAT
TWENTY TWENTY WAS AN ANOMALY. A
CRIMINAL ASSAULT ON THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. WE CLOSED
THE DOOR TO THAT. FRONT LAST
YEAR IN A STE NEW FOR PREVENT.
MEASURES INCLUDE ID ME THOMPSON
WRITERS NEXT. CAN WAS THE FIRST
STATE DO THIS. CRIMINAL HAVEN'T
GIVEN UP. WE CONTINUE TO AND
STRENGTHEN FRAUD FOR TO PREVENT
FROM SPEED PAYMENT NOT AFFECT
CLAIMANTS BUT AS YOU YOUR
OFFICE STAFF KNOW LIKE THEY
HAVE BEEN DOING WITH E. G. D.
WE HAD A- A NEW WAVE FOR.
CLAIMS JUST THE END OF THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM SO. WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON A TO. ENSURE THAT
DATA THOSE KINDS OUR GREAT ARE
NOT PAID. WE HAVE BEEN GREAT WE
CURRENTLY IN. IN. SEVEN
HUNDRED. LOCAL FRAUD CASES
ACROSS THE STATE. WE ALSO
BROUGHT IN FORMER US ATTORNEY
MCGREGOR SCOTT TO HELP US HOLD
BROADER FRAUDSTERS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR ACTIONS LAST YEAR.
GREGOR SCOTT HAS LED NUMEROUS
LARGE SCALE CRIMINAL PROBES IN
HIS MANY YEARS AS A STATE AND
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR. WITH HIS
DATE WE ARE IN POWERING MORE
PROSECUTORS TO CRACK DOWN ON
THOSE WHO ENGAGED IN CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY LAST YEAR. WE HAVE
ALSO TAKEN STRONG STEPS TO
IMPROVE OUR MULTI LINGUAL
SERVICE. WITH THE SUPPORT OF
THE LEGISLATURE WE ARE
INVESTING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN INTERPRETER AND TRANSLATION
SERVICES. FOR EXAMPLE EDT
EXPANDED ITS LANGUAGE LINE
CONTRACT INCLUDES FRONTLINE
STAFF TO MAXIMIZE ACCESS TO
LANGUAGE LINE SERVICES. MAJOR
INVESTMENTS ARE ALSO BEING MADE
TO EXPAND TRANSLATIONAL VITAL
DOCUMENTS INTO MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES MANY KEY FORMS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN TRANSLATED. OUR
CALLS HONOR EXPENDED EXPANDED
LANGUAGE LINES HAVE BEEN
INCREASING WEEKLY. THE CALL
CENTER REMAINS A CHALLENGE. WE
RUN THE CALL CENTER TWELVE DAYS
OR WEEKS SEARCH TWELVE HOURS A
DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK ASTRID
MORE THAN TEN MILLION CALLS
DURING THE PANDEMIC STILL THE
LEVEL OF WEEKDAY CALLS STILL
OVERWHELMS THE SISTER. IN JULY
THERE WERE ABOUT THREE MILLION
CALLS A WEEK. IT'S NOW DOWN TO
A MILLION BUT LET ME CLARIFY
THAT NUMBER BECAUSE PERCENTAGES
ARE ALWAYS TAKEN FROM THE
LARGEST NUMBER. THAT NUMBER
REPRESENTS A HUNDRED AND FORTY
ONE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FORTY UNIQUE COLORS LAST WEEK.
THE STAFF ANSWERED A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND TWO OF THOSE CALLS
WHICH IS APPROXIMATELY 95% OF
THE CALLS. THE REST WERE REPEAT
CALLS OR ROBOCALLS THE AVERAGE
SPEED IN ANSWERING HAS IMPROVED
NOW TO EIGHTEEN MINUTES THE
CALL THE ALL VALUE ON WEEKENDS
AND IN THE EVENINGS HAS DROPPED
SUBSTANTIALLY. WE ARE IMPROVING
IMPROVING SERVICE QUALITY SO
THAT WE CAN RESULT CALLER
ISSUES THE FIRST TIME. THIS IS
AN IMPROVEMENT BUT THE OBO
CALLS AND THE REPEAT CALLS CAN
STILL OVERWHELM THE SYSTEM
DURING THE WEEK DAYS. THE
FEDERAL PROGRAMS OVER WE SEE
LESS CALL STRUCTURE TRAFFIC IN
THE EVENINGS AND THE WEEKENDS.
MEANWHILE THE PAPERWORK WE NEED
TO COMPLETE TO GET PEOPLE PAID
REMAINS. SO WE ARE EXPLORING
WAYS TO BE ABLE TO REJECT
REDIRECT THE EVENING AND
WEEKEND RESOURCES SO THAT WE
CAN PAY PEOPLE EVEN FASTER.
WELL WE'RE CHANGING POLICIES
AND AUTOMATING. THINGS ARE NOT
IMPROVING FAST ENOUGH FOR SOME.
THERE ARE STILL CHALLENGES
AHEAD. DETERMINATION INTERVIEWS
AS I MENTIONED WE LARGE TO PAY
NO POLICY IN JULY TO GET FUNDS
TO CONTINUE CLAIMS- PASTOR
FRAUD FILTERS AND WE'RE WAITING
MORE THAN CHAU TWO WEEKS FOR
PAYMENT. WE HAVE PAID SINCE
THEN NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND CLAIMS UNDER THIS
CHANGE IN POLICY. SOME OF THOSE
CLAIMANTS ARE WAITING FOR
DETERMINATION INTERVIEWS BUT
THEY ARE BEING PAID. WELL
CONTINUED CLAIMANTS ARE NOW
PAID WORK FOR DETERMINATION
ELIGIBILITY REMAINS FOR EXAMPLE.
CLAIM WAGE INFORMATION.
EMPLOYER PROVIDED MAY CONFLICT
WITH WHAT THE CLAIMANT PROVIDED
OR WE NEED TO ESTABLISH WHY A
PERSON LEFT A JOB WHEN THEY
QUIT OR WERE FIRED THESE KEY
ISSUES REQUIRING INTERVIEWING
THE CLINT. THESE INTERVIEWS ARE
NOW SCHEDULED FOR TWENTY SIX
WEEKS OUT WHICH IS COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE. ONCE AGAIN HALF
OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE BEING PAID.
WE ARE TARGET TRAINING TWO
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL EMPLOYEES TO
HANDLE THE MOST COMMON ISSUES
REQUIRING INTERVIEWS THEY WILL
BEGIN IN MID NOVEMBER WE ARE
ALSO COLD COAL CLEAN DIRECT
CLAIMANTS DIRECTLY WHENEVER WE
CAN RESOLVE. THE ISSUES IN THAT
WAY AND WE ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF DEVELOPING A FORM THAT WILL
BE SENT OUT TO THOSE WAITING
FOR DETERMINATIONS WHICH MAY
COMPLETELY ELIMINATE THE NEED
TO HAVE AN INTERVIEW. IN
COMPARISON THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CLAIMANTS NEVER NEED AN
INTERVIEW. 85% OF CUSTOMERS
DURING THE PANDEMIC WERE PAID
WITHIN ONE WEEK OF CERTIFIED
FOR BENEFITS. THAT'S NO COMFORT
TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE WAITING.
IN SUMMARY WE HAVE CHANGED I AM
A POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
STREAMLINED PROCESS SINCE WE
ARE AUTOMATING EVERYTHING WE
CAN AND DEVELOPING PARALLEL I.
T. SYSTEMS. ADDING MORE NEW
FEATURES TO THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CALL CENTER. ARE WE
SATISFIED NO WE ARE NOT. BUT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE CHANGES
UNTIL THINGS ARE COMPLETE. I
ESPECIALLY I WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT I HAVE ALWAYS WELCOMED IN
THIS DEPARTMENT IS ALWAYS
WELCOMED THE RECOMMENDATIONS
MADE BY THE STATE AUDITOR THE
STRIKE TEAM AND THE LEGISLATURE
I'VE SPENT MANY HOURS ON CALLS
WITH LEGISLATORS TALKING ABOUT
THEIR IDEAS AND SUGGESTIONS AND
THEY HAVE COME THROUGH. WE ARE
USING THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE STRIKE
TEAM RECOMMENDATIONS. AS A
BLUEPRINT A ROAD MAP FOR HOW TO
IMPROVE. IT WILL CONTINUE
TOWARDS WORKING IMPLEMENTING
ALL THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN FULL.
YOU KNOW I THE IDEA THAT THE
EDT IS DOING THE DOING THESE
THINGS TO ACCOMMODATE OR
RESPOND TO A HEARING IS THERE
ARE UNFORTUNATELY NOT
COMPLETELY ACCURATE EDT IS
DOING THESE THINGS BECAUSE WE
SEE THAT THERE ARE THE RIGHT
THINGS TO DO. WE HAVE AN
EXCEPTIONAL LEADERSHIP TEAM NOW
WE ARE HARD WORKING EMPLOYEES
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE CLIENTS AND YES WE HAVE
FAILED IN SOME SENSE IN SOME
SITUATIONS. BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TO IMPROVE OUR
SERVICES. RESHAPED THE
PARTNERSHIP WILL DEVELOP WITH
THE LEGISLATURE DURING THIS
TIME AND I ESPECIALLY WANT TO
THANK LEGISLATIVE STAFF FOR ALL
THE WORK THEY HAVE DONE TO
ASSIST. OUR CLIENTS WHO ARE
YOUR CONSTITUENTS THIS. THE
SITUATION WITH THE PANDEMIC WAS
AN ALL HANDS ON BOARD
SITUATION. YEAH PEOPLE HAVE
STEPPED UP MAKING EFFICIENTLY
TO HELP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR SIGNS FOR THAT REPORT
TO ME TO OPEN IT UP TO MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE DYESS- MISTER
LUCKY. HELLO DIRECTOR SCIENCE
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY
AND- LISTENING TO WHAT WE HAVE
TO SAY I KNOW IF YOU HAD A
CHANCE TO. SEE THE- THE PROP
AND I HAVE DISPLAYED HERE BUT
WILL. IT ACTUALLY- ADDRESSES.
THE THE FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN- DISPERSED BY
YOUR YOUR DEPARTMENT AND THIS
IS ONE OF THE- THE MORE
CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATIONS IT'S
ABOUT ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS.
AND WHAT I HAVE DISPLAYED HERE
TWENTY NINE INDUSTRIAL. DUMP
TRUCKS THAT WOULD IF THEY WERE
FILLED WITH HUNDRED DOLLAR
BILLS WOULD REPRESENT THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY. THAT HAS BEEN-
PAID OUT AND FRAUDULENT CLAIMS.
AND AN ORDER TO DISPERSE THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY. LINE UP ALMOST
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE AND
GIVE THEM ENOUGH MONEY TO BUY A
HOME WITH THE MEDIAN PRICE.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD
BE A WONDERFUL THING BUT WHAT'S
HAPPENED IS THESE A FALL INTO
THE HANDS OF PEOPLE WHO DO NOT
DESERVE THAT KIND OF PAYMENT.
AND I. I DID HEAR FROM THE
AUDIT TEAM AND IT'S BEEN
INDICATED THAT- THEY'VE
SUGGESTED HE RESPONDED
FAVORABLY. TOWARDS A FORMING A
AFFRONT INVESTIGATIVE UNIT AND
I WAS WONDERING. WHEN WE CAN
LOOK FORWARD TO THE HIRING
THOSE PEOPLE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I AM VERY APPRECIATE TO
THE DISTRESSED ABOUT HER. BOB
THE NUMBER OF FRAUD CLAIMS THAT
WERE PAID I JUST HAVE TO SAY
AND I'VE I'VE SPOKEN TO A
NUMBER OF STATE DIRECTORS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. THERE'S NOT
ONE STATE THEY DID NOT
EXPERIENCE A SUBSTANTIAL.
AMOUNT OF FRAUDULENT CLAIMS I
THINK IN ARIZONA THEY HAD JOHN.
TEXAS THEY HAD 14% OF THE
CLAIMS WERE FRAUDULENT IN
ARIZONA IT WAS CLOSE 234% SO WE
HAVE ALL HAD DIFFICULTY WITH
THIS. IN A SUBSTANTIAL PORTION
OF THOSE CLAIMS. WE WERE WAS
BASICALLY AN ASSAULT BY
CRIMINAL GANGS OUTSIDE THE
COUNTRY AND INSIDE THE COUNTRY
AND- WE'VE DONE QUITE A BIT TO
STOP THAT YOU KNOW THIS IS AN
INSURANCE PROGRAM AND THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE FAMILIAR WITH
INSURANCE YOU KNOW THEIR
INSURANCE PROGRAMS. ARE OFTEN
TARGETED FOR FROM THE UNIT THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT REQUIRED
GETTING. HR APPROVALS WELL IN
REACTIVE CONSTRUCTED ESTABLISH
THE POLICIES ARE THOSE OF. WE
WILL BE GOING TO MOVE PEOPLE
INTO IT- LET ME ASK MY CHIEF
DEPUTY OF OPERATIONS WHAT HER
THOUGHT IS ABOUT THE TIMELINE.
ANY. GOOD AFTERNOON THANKS FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY I'M
EXCITED TO BE IN FRONT OF ME
ALL TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
ATVS PROGRESS AS IT PERTAINS TO
THE AUDITOR RECOMMENDATIONS I
AM AS IT PERTAINS TO THE
DESIGNATION OF THE FRAUD UNIT
SPECIFICALLY- WE ARE CURRENTLY
STILL WORKING WITH OUR
CALIFORNIA OUR SKINNER GETTING
RESOURCES DIVISION- TO EXECUTE
ON THE MOVEMENT OF STAFF INTO
THESE POSITIONS- AND ALSO WILL
MANAGER ONE LEVEL POSITIONS I'M
FOR THIS YEAR AND WE ANTICIPATE
THAT IT BE FULLY STAFFED BY THE.
END OF NOVEMBER OF THIS YEAR.
YEAH WE DEFINED VERY IMPORTANT
WE HAVE STAFF THAT ARE MOVED
INTO THE UNIT AS OPPOSED TO NEW
HIRES- BECAUSE WE HAVE FOLKS
THAT ARE. FAMILIAR WITH THE
PROGRAM IN POSSESS THE
KNOWLEDGE SKILLS AND ABILITIES.
TO EXECUTE. AT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE UNIT AS
A WHOLE. I HOPE THAT ANSWERS
YOUR- QUESTION. YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH N. TO BE CLEAR THAT
THE DIRECTION AND TIMELINE AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AND SETTING
GOALS AND EXPECTATIONS IS THAT
B. THE FRAUD UNIT WILL BE FULLY
VETTED AND FULLY STAFFED BY END
OF NOVEMBER OF THIS YEAR. I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S A CONFIRMATION. THAT'S
CORRECT THANK YOU MISTER SALAS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU DIRECTOR FOR JOINING US FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WE APPRECIATE
YOU BEING HERE AND ANSWERING
QUESTIONS- THE NEW EARLIER YOU
SAID. YOUR DEPARTMENT WAS OUT
LIKE 70% LIMITING EVERYTHING
AND YOU KNOW WHAT I. SPOKE WITH
THE AUDITOR OF THE PREVIOUS
PANEL I THOUGHT THIRTEEN OUT OF
TWENTY ONE- THINGS BEING
IMPLEMENTED THAT'S LIKE 62% SO
LOVE TO SEE WHAT THAT.
ADDITIONAL 8% AND REALLY GET TO
THE HUNDRED PERCENT. OF FULLY
IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL THE
AUDITORS RECOMMENDATIONS BUT IT
WILL. GO AHEAD SENATOR I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT THEY WILL BE
MET. THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT-
I WANTED TO TOUCH ON SOMETHING
YOU TALKED ABOUT EARLIER YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE BACKLOG IN THE
BACKLOG THAT WE HAD A- LAST
YEAR AND THE AMOUNT THAT IT
WAS. YOU KNOW BUT AND HE ALSO
TOUCHED ON THIS YOU KNOW THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE STILL WAITING ON EDT
TO GET THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. YEAH LAST I CHECKED I
THINK YOU JUST CONFIRMED IT IN
YOUR TESTIMONY. WAS THAT THERE
WAS A BACKLOG OF PENDING. THAT
THE BACKLOG OF PENDING CLAIMS
THAT ARE TWENTY ONE DAYS OR
OLDER WAS NEARLY A. HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND CLAIMS. I'LL
WELL THAT CURRENT NUMBER BY ON
A PLANE AS MUCH THAN IT WAS A
MY AGO. HI THIS IS STILL
SIGNIFICANT OF UNRESOLVED
CLAIMS YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE
REASON FOR THE CONTINUED
BACKLOG AND WHAT IS THE
ANTICIPATED. TIME FRAME FOR
DEALING WITH THE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND. BEFORE I HAVE
STAFF ASK THAT- ANSWERED LET ME
SAY THAT- THERE HAS ALWAYS BEEN
SOME BACKLOG WITH THE- SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE TO BE
RESOLVED ARE VERY COMPLICATED.
AS A MATTER OF FACT I WAS
SURPRISED TO HEAR THIS MYSELF.
ALTHOUGH IT DOES EXPLAIN SOME
THINGS NEXT SOMETIMES IT COULD
TAKE AS MANY AS A HUNDRED ITEMS
TO CLEAR. OF HELD. FOR APPLYING
THE RULES OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR ARE EXTREMELY COMPLICATED.
AND EACH INDIVIDUAL HAS TO BE
REVIEWED AS AN INDIVIDUAL ARE
THERE ARE LIKE NOT GENERAL
RULES FOR EVERYONE SO. THAT'S
THAT'S A PART OF IT YEAH I'LL-
AND I APPRECIATE THE DIRECTOR
I'M JUST TRYING TO GET OUT
BECAUSE I REMEMBER AT THE LAST
HEARING YOU TOLD US THAT THE
BACKLOG WOULD BE CLEARED BY THE
END OF JAIL AND THEN THE END OF
JUNE WAS THE END OF SUMMER. AND
NOW THAT WE HAVE. EXCUSE ME
SIR. LOG I THINK THEY ARE THE
BACKGROUND THAT YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT IT THERE ARE THERE'S A
BACKLOG AND THERE'S THE
DEFERRED WORK OR WHAT THE WHAT
THE- WHAT THE- STATE AUDITOR
WAS TALKING ABOUT HIS THE
DIFFERENT LOCAL. I CAME TO THE
HEARING TO EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE
WHAT THE DEFERRED WORK ALL DAY
BOTH THE AUDITOR AND THE
AUDITOR'S STAFF MENTIONED. AND
WE CAME TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
ASK FOR FUNDS TO BE ABLE TO
RESOLVE THOSE WITHIN A YEAR AND
THE LEGISLATURE WE- ARE THIS IS
ONE OF THE MAJOR LOSSES. IN THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THE TRAFFIC'S NOT
HAVING SCARY IT'S SO WEIRD
CHESAPEAKE THAT THE DEFERRED
BOOK ON WOULD BE- COMPLETED ONE
YEAR. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
THAT CLARIFICATION AND I COULD.
AND SO THE DEFERRED WORKLOAD
WOULD BE COMPLETED WITHIN A
YEAR OF WHEN YOU REQUESTED THE
RESOURCES FROM THE LEGISLATURE
AND THAT WOULD GIVE A SINGLE
MAJOR IT WILL BE. WHAT WHEN THE
ALLEGED WHEN THE- BUDGET WAS
APPROVED HER. SO THAT WAS KIND
OF THE REQUEST BUT WHEN THE
BUDGET WAS APPROVED SO THAT
WOULD BE JULY. TO HIRE THOSE
PEOPLE. SO I BELIEVE THAT'S
JULY CORRECT. WHOA BY THE END
OF THE HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND CLAIMANTS WITH THE
TWENTY ONE DAYS OR OLDER.
WHAT'S THE ANTICIPATION FOR
THOSE CLAIMS. WELL AS YOU KNOW
THIS IS KIND OF INTERESTING
WINNER WHEN I READ CDSS THE
SAME ISSUE- ALMOST ABOUT HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE ON- ONE CAL
WORKS SO D. R. THIS IS NOT A
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND.
PAUL WHO IS A LIKE A BLOCK OF
PEOPLE IN USE IS GOING THROUGH
THAT WHERE THERE WERE ALWAYS
GETTING NEW PEOPLE IN. SO TO
GIVE YOU A COMPLETE- YOU KNOW
LIKE ON A DEFINITE WINNER OF
THE HUNDRED YOU KNOW I THINK.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY THIS IS
EXPLAINED TO MORE IN DETAIL I'M
GOING TO ASK THE STAFF TO.
EXPLAIN TO YOU HOW THIS WORKS
PLEASE THANK YOU. WHO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CRISTIAN
FRAME THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FRENCH DEPUTY
DIRECTOR THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE- I CAN
SPEAK TO THE- LIQUIDATION AND
WORKLOAD OF THE- DEFERRED
WORKLOAD AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
EFFORTS WERE DOING DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE WORKLOADS I MEAN WE
UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS
FRUSTRATING FOR CONSTITUENTS TO
WAIT TWENTY SIX WEEKS FOR AN
INTERVIEW AND WE AGREE THAT
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT ACCEPTABLE
I'M A WHAT WE ARE DOING TO
REDUCE THE WAIT TIME OR
ELIMINATE THE NEED FOR THE
INTERVIEW ALL TOGETHER IS TO AS
DIRECTOR SIGNS MENTIONED PARTY
TRAINED THE RECENT GROUP OF
STAFF THAT ARE OVER THE TOP
ISSUES REQUIRING AN INTERVIEW
FOR CONSTITUENTS. COLD CALLING
CAN. TO OBTAIN INFORMATION THAT
MAY ELIMINATE THE NEED FOR AN
INTERVIEW ALL TOGETHER. AND
WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF THE
LEGISLATURE WE RECEIVE THE
FUNDING TO ASSIST US IN
COMPLETING THESE DEFERRED. AND
PERSPECTIVE WORKLOADS WHICH
INCLUDES THE INTERVIEW SPECIFIC
ELIGIBILITY INTERVIEW WORK
WHAT. WE ARE ONBOARDING
HUNDREDS OF AGENTS EVERY TWO
WEEKS- PROVISIONING IN
PROVIDING TRAINING TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN MEET THE TARGET- I
DO WANT TO ENSURE COVERED A
LITTLE BIT OF CLARIFICATION AS
FAR AS- THE- WE RECEIVED A
BUNCH THE FUDGE IT. SO YOU
THINK WE RECEIVED THE BUDGET.
AUTHORITY AND THE FUNDING AND
WENT AND RELEASED A REQUEST FOR
QUOTE. THAT CONTRACT WAS SIGNED
IN JANUARY I'M SORRY IN
SEPTEMBER OF THIS YEAR AND- WE
EXPECT TO COMPLETE WITHIN ONE
YEAR OF. OF THE CONTRACT ITSELF
BEING AWARDED SO IT'S WHEN
YOU'RE FROM SEPTEMBER FIRST
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND THE- AND IF
I COULD JUST FOLLOW UP ON THAT-
THE PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE
ONBOARDING THESE ARE GONNA BE
PEOPLE THAT CAN ACTUALLY
RESOLVE CLAIMS BECAUSE I CAN
TELL YOU A LOT OF TIMES WHEN
PEOPLE ARE CALLING. MY OFFICE
AND I'M SURE MY COLLEAGUES
OFFICES AS WELL. IT'S ALWAYS.
IT'S ALWAYS SOMETHING THAT
CAN'T BE ANSWERED OR- THE CLAIM
CAN'T REACH WAS ALL MEANT. ON
LIKE THAT PHONE CALL OR THAT
INTERVIEW. SO THE FOLKS THAT
ARE BRINGING ON BOARD YOU'RE
LOOKING AT. MORE MORE SENIOR
PEOPLE THAT CAN ACTUALLY START
RESOLVING THESE CLAIMS IS THAT
WHAT I'M HEARING. SO WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS WE'RE ACTUALLY
CHANGING THE WAY IN WHICH WE'RE
OPERATING AND I'M WORKING THIS
WORKLOAD I'M VERY SIMILAR TO
SOME OF THE OUTLINED ITEMS IN
THE RECESSION PLAN SO WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS PROVIDING TARGET
SPECIFIC TRAINING. THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY FOUNDATION- IN CORE
OF THE FOR THESE DEFERRED
WORKLOAD VENDOR AGENTS THAT'LL
BE ABLE TO ASSIST US IN
TACKLING THE ADMINISTRATIVE-
INFORMATION COLLECTION- SO THAT
SPECIFIC INFORMATION DISCARDED
TRAINING AND IT WE ARE MOVING-
ANY OF THE ADDITIONAL ENHANCED
AND SEPARATE ISSUES THAT WOULD
TYPICALLY COME WITH. A STATE
EMPLOYEE- ONBOARDING IN
TRAINING- BROWN. AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS ENSURING THAT ONCE THE
INFORMATION IS COLLECTED AND
OBTAINED IN A MORE EXPEDITIOUS
MANNER GIVEN THE LEVEL AND
NUMBER OF AGENTS THAT WE'RE
ONBOARDING EVERY TWO WEEKS WE
DON'T HAVE CITY STAFF AT ALL
LEVELS TO FINALIZE THE
EDUCATION. I'M AN INTERVIEW AND
LIQUIDATE THE WORK LEFT. I HOPE
THAT HELPED. MISSTATEMENT JUST
TO A POINT OF CLARIFICATION ON
STATE EMPLOYEES TO MISTER SALAS
THIS QUESTION. THE GROUP THAT
YOU ARE ONBOARDING TO HELP WITH
THE TWENTY SIX WEEK- AND
CONTINUED DELAYS AND- THE
INTERVIEW ELIGIBILITY THAT'S
PART OF THAT THE CONTRACT OF
NON STATE EMPLOYEES NON UNION
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE COMING IN TO
SUPPORT. THE WORKLOAD OF EDT IS
THAT CORRECT- A PORTION ALSO A
DIRECTOR SIGNS MENTIONED THE
TWO HUNDRED AGENTS- ARE THEY
STATE STAFF THAT WERE ALSO
TARGET TRAINING SEPARATE AND
APART SO WE'RE MANAGING AND
WORKING TO- WORK THIS WORKLOAD
IN TWO DIFFERENT AND
CONCURRENT. AVENUES TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN WORK THIS WORKLOAD
FAST OKAY. I JUST WANT TO MAKE
THAT POINT OF CLARIFICATION AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH- GOALS AND
EXPECTATIONS AS TO WHAT THE
WORKLOAD- AND WORK FORCE LOOKS
LIKE. IN TERMS OF TURN AROUND
OR- FOLKS THE MAKE COMMAND OR
MAY NOT STATE OR WHAT IT
ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT A TWO DIFFERENT
TYPES OF WORK FORCE WE'RE
LOOKING AT LONG TERM STATE-EMPLOYEES THAT HAVE BEEN. PART
OF THE EDT SYSTEM FOR QUITE
SOME TIME THAT HAVE
INSTITUTIONAL AND INHERIT
KNOWLEDGE THAT ARE PART OF. THE
STATE WORKFORCE AND THEN WE'RE
LOOKING CONCURRENTLY. ADD
SUPPLEMENTAL WORK FORCE THAT'S
CONTRACT BASE THAT'S NON UNION
NON STATE EMPLOYEES HOW CAN WE
ARE HOW ARE YOU DETERMINING.
UNDER THAT WORK FORCE. HOW
EXPEDITIOUSLY- THERE. MOVING
THROUGH THE BACKLOG OR IS THERE
A DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF.
RAINING. THERE IS WE CERTAINLY
A PULL UP PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FOUNDATION AND TRAINING FOR THE
US STATE STAFF THAT WE WILL
HAVE AND THAT HAVE BEEN
ASSISTING US DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE HAVE A SEPARATE AND
APART- TARGET TRAINING WITH
RESPECT TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COLLECTION OF INFORMATION FOR
THESE INTERVIEWS SPECIFICALLY-
THE ELIGIBILITY INTERVIEWS- AND
SO WHAT WE HAVE PUT TOGETHER
IS- EIGHT. WORK LIQUIDATION
PLAN AS THE AUDITOR OF SPOKE TO
THAT ALLOWED US TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE BENCHMARKS THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO COMPLETE AND WORK
THIS WORKLOAD UTILIZING BOTH
OF. THE STATE STAFF AND
CONTRACTORS STAFF TO ENSURE WE
MEET THAT ONE YEAR- EXPECTED
TIMELINES. THANK YOU MISTER
KNIGHT I APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION ESPECIALLY FOR
THE MEMBERS OF THIS DIET AND AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH. WITH
CREATING THE BENCHMARK
NECESSARY FOR EDT IN TERMS OF
THE ACCOUNTABILITY MEASUREMENTS
OF THE WORK FORCE BEHIND ET DE
BOTH OF WHICH ARE STATE
EMPLOYEES. AS WELL AS
CONTRACTED EMPLOYEES THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME. THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS ENTERED INTO
A CONTRACT OF NONUNION STATE
EMPLOYEES WORKING FOR A
DEPARTMENT WHICH I THINK IS
IMPORTANT FOR US. TO UNDERSTAND
IN TERMS OF ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY AND WHO ULTIMATELY
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CALLS
FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS SO TO
MISTER SALAS THIS POINT. WHEN
OUR STAFF GETS CALLS AND WE
NEED THEN OUR DISTRICT OFFICES
MOSTLY GETS CALLS AND THEN WE
RE DIRECT THEM TO EDT. HOW ARE
WE TO INSURE THAT WE ARE
SPEAKING TO A- STATE. A TRAINED
WHICH IS AS YOU MENTIONED A
DIFFERENT MEASUREMENT OF
TRAINING VERSUS A CONTRACTED
EMPLOYEE WHICH WE HOPE WILL GET
TO THE SAME LEVEL OF
EFFICIENCY. AS A STATE EMPLOYEE.
RIGHT SO I COULD CERTAINLY
ALLOW- KEVIN TO ADD A LITTLE
BIT AS FAR AS A LEGISLATIVE
PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE WITH
CONSTITUENT OFFICES BUT WE WILL
HAVE THE VENDOR AGENCY
CONTRACTED STAFF SEPARATE APART
WORKING ON BE. THE WORKLOAD
DEFERRED AND SOME OF THE
PROSPECTIVE WORKLOADS WE WILL
CONTINUE OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE STATE STAFF ARE LIAISING
WITH YOUR OFFICES AND- THAT
WILL MEAN THAT WILL ENSURE THAT
WE MAINTAIN THE CONTINUITY OF
THE INFORMATION AND THE SKILL
SET THAT- WE HAVE PROVIDED. BUT
WILL ALSO ENSURE THAT IT IS
SEPARATE AND APART SO THAT- THE
SPECIFIC- SKILLED. SKILLED
EIGHT UP STATE STAFF ARE
AVAILABLE I'M TO PROVIDE THAT
CONSISTENT SUCCESS- OF- TRAINED
EXPERIENCE TO THE OFFICES.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND THANK
YOU MEDICARE FOR THE
CLARIFICATION OBVIOUSLY AT THE
END OF THE DAY WE WATER
CONSTITUENTS TO GET THE ANSWERS
THAT THEY NEED SO THAT THEY
COULD GET THEIR CASE IS
RESOLVED BUT IN HEARING- YOU
KNOW THE RESPONSE IT. DOES BEG
THE QUESTION ON WORKFORCE I'M
WONDERING WHAT THE RETENTION
LEVELS ARE. AT AT AT EDT RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE IF YOU'RE ALWAYS
HIRING HIRING YOU KNOW THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY THAT LEARNING CURVE
TO HELP RESOLVE THESE ISSUES
HAVE YOU HAD A PROBLEM WITH THE
RETENTION IS AN ISSUE THAT ARE
NON ISSUE. I'M JUST CURIOUS
THOUGH JUST BECAUSE OF THE
RESPONSES. GARCIA BEFORE YES
AND LET ME JUST SAY THAT ONE OF
THE THINGS- PROBABLY- ALL. ARE
REASSURED THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS THAT. ALTHOUGH WE HAVE HAVE
A VERY OLD LEGACY SYSTEM. WE
HAVE BEEN DOING CARILLO
IMPROVEMENTS ON IT BECAUSE WE
CAN'T WAIT FOR. WITH AND ART WE
ARE LAW OF OUR PROCESS IS
SIMPLE THAT WILL ALLOW
EXPERIENCED AND MATURE STAFF
MERIT STAFF TO BE ABLE TO CLOSE
THE CASES WHEN SO WHAT YOU KNOW
OUR LONG TERM GOAL WHICH IS TO
INSURE AS MUCH AS AUTOMATED AS
POSSIBLE TO ALLOW FOR FEWER
PEOPLE TO HAVE A MORE.
IMPORTANT IMPACT CLOSING THESE
CASES MOST OF THE THINGS THAT
WERE DONE AT EGP BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC UNFORTUNATELY. WHAT
PAPERWORK. UNDERSTOOD SO IS
THERE A ISSUE WITH PERSONNEL
AND WORK FIRST THOUGH IN TERMS
OF RETENTION WITH WORKERS IS AT
A NON ISSUE IS THAT AN ISSUE AT
AT THE DEPARTMENT. LET ME JUST
SAY THAT ABOUT. HAVING
EXPERIENCE BOTH IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
IN A CALL CENTER THERE IS YOU-
GENERALLY THIRTY PERCENT.
TURNOVER EVERY YEAR. SO IN THAT
RESPECT WE ARE WE ARE IN THE
SAME SITUATION AND I MUST SAY
THAT YOU KNOW. EDT WHEN I WAS
NOT HERE LAST YEAR WAS UNDER
QUITE A PRESSURE COOKER AND WE
HAD A NUMBER OF PEOPLE CHARTER.
WE HAD MANAGER STEPPED DOWN SO
WHAT WE DID LISTEN STAFF.
UNDERSTOOD YEAH I LOOK FORWARD
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA WANT TO
DELVE INTO SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
TO TRY TO HELP BECAUSE AT THE
END OF THE DAY WE JUST WANNA
GET HELP FOR CONSTITUENTS. BUT
I DID WANT TO ASK A QUESTION
BECAUSE ONLY A THREE QUESTIONS
AND- BUT YOU HAD. MENTIONED THE
BENEFITS MODERNIZATION YOU DID
IN YOUR OPENING AND YOU JUST
REFERENCED IT RIGHT NOW. YOU
KNOW- THE LEGISLATURE IS
ALLOCATED TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS AT TWO EDT TO REFOCUS
ON THE BSM PROJECT YOU MIGHT.
ASK YEAH THE FIRST PANEL. AT
THIS QUESTION EARLIER BECAUSE
IT STARTED BACK IN. TWENTY
SIXTEEN SO IT'S LIKE THAT FIVE
YEARS THAT. SO IF ONE TO ADD
WHERE YOU EXT THIS TO BE ABLE.
TO SAID WE'RE TRY TO ADAM FOR
TRY TO- YOUR HOME IT AND THIS
NEW BENEFITS. D. SEE THAT.
COMING COMPLETELY. SOON YOU
SAID YOU'VE USED SOME SOME
ASPECTS OF IT ALREADY. THERE
ARE YES. WE SIGNED OUT. THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF IMPROVEMENTS
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD MEAN THAT
WE AUTOMATE. FOR SOME PAPERWORK
PROCEDURES IN ADDITION TO THAT
WE ARE WE HAVE A PARALLEL I. T.
SYSTEM- AND IN THAT PARA WHAT
IT SYSTEM WE SOMETIMES MOVE.
SOLUTIONS TO A PROBLEM OR NOT A
NATION INTO THE PARALLEL IT
SYSTEM SO THAT WE'RE NOT OVER
BURDENING MAINFRAME. SO THAT
THAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE HAVE EVERY
TIME WE CHANGE OF POLICY WE
NEED TO DO IT EVERYTHING COSTS
ARE CHEAP. SO YOU KNOW THIS
YEAR IN ADDITION TO MAKE ANY
CHANGES WE HAD TO MAKE WE ALSO
HAD THESE NEW FEDERAL PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAD TO IMPLEMENT AND
THEN WE HAD TO THE COMMISSION.
SHOW UP WHAT WE ARE DOING RIGHT
NOW BILLS AND THANKS TO THE
LEGISLATURE. IS OUT WE WERE
GIVEN FUNDS TO. REVIEW ALL OUR
BUSINESS PROCESSES IN OUR
BUSINESS RULES NOW FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE. FAMILIAR WITH T
PROGRAMS AND I KNOW. BECAUSE OF
OVERSIGHT YOU ARE. WELL THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AN IT SYSTEM.
IS 80% GETTING THE BUSINESS
RULES RIGHT IN TRAINING THE
STAFF AND 20% IMPLEMENTATION.
SO YOU WILL YOU'LL SEE THAT IN
THIS COMING YEAR WE WILL COME
TO YOU WITH THIS THESE BUSINESS
RULES OR REVIEW AND REVISION
ARE DONE. WE WILL COME TO YOU
AND ASK YOU FOR FUNDS TO LOOK
AT THE INITIATION OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SYSTEM. OKAY
SO WE'VE WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
FOR FIVE YEARS WOULD YOU SAY
WERE HALFWAY THERE WERE ALMOST
THERE ONCE WE GET THESE
BUSINESS RULES DONE AS A
JOURNALIST AND KIND OF WERE
RANDOMLY OFFICER HOW MUCH MORE.
YOU ALSO ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO DO THE
BUSINESS RULES REVIEW AND SUCH
A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME FOR A
RELATIVELY COMPLEX. PROGRAM
COLLUDING YOU IPFL. TAX BRANCH
AND DINNER DIAZ YES BECAUSE
WE'RE TAKING SOME OF THE WORK
DONE ON THE BSM SYSTEM OVER
THESE NUMBER OF YEARS SO THAT'S
ALLOWING US TO TRUNCATE THE
AMOUNT OF TIME IT WILL BE DOING
THESE BUSINESS RULES PROCESSES.
ARE SO- AS YOU MAY REMEMBER.
THE B. S. M. WAS. OKAY DURING
THE BECAUSE THE STAFF WAS
WORKING ON IT WAS NEEDED TO
CLEANING. SO THAT WHY IT WAS-
THAT'S WHY IT WAS IT. SO DO YOU
SEE THIS FALL AMPLE THEN YEAR
ONCE COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THE B. S.
EMERALD TRIANGLE I DON'T SEE IT
FULLY IMPLEMENTED- I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTED MUCH
FASTER THAN YOU SEEN SOME I. T.
SYSTEMS ARE. PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE IN THE OLD DAYS WE USED
TO USE WATERFALL WHICH IS WE
WORKED AND WORKED AND WORKED ON
IT AND THEN. WE. ARE UNVEILED
IT TO THE PUBLIC. WE'RE USING
ASSIST CALLED AGILE NOW. AND WE
WILL BE IMPLEMENTING THINGS. IN
IN PHASES SO NO YOU WON'T SEE
THE ENTIRE. SITUATION BUT IT
WILL TAKE ME PROBABLY TAKE
ANOTHER COUPLE OF THE-
ABSOLUTELY FULLY IMPLEMENTED
BUT IT WILL BE IMPLEMENTED IN
STAGES. OKAY WELL WE'LL FOR THE
COMING KEEPING TABS ON THAT
OBVIOUSLY THE QUICKER THE SM
PROJECTS ONLINE OR FULLY
IMPLEMENTED IT HELPS WITH THE
TURN AROUND AND WAIT TIMES FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS TO ACTUALLY
GET THE CASE RESOLVED. AS HAD
ONE FINAL QUESTION IF I MAY.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF
CALLS THAT YOU GUYS A PROCESS I
THINK YOU SAID IT WAS TEN
MILLION CALLS SHE HAS OF DONE
THROUGH THE CALL CENTER. AND I
WAS JUST WONDERING BECAUSE I
KNOW I BELIEVE IT WAS EITHER
THE LEGISLATURE OR THE STRIKE
TEAM. THAT HAD A REPORT TALKING
ABOUT HOW MANY OF THE CALLS
RECEIVED A CALL CENTERS
ACTUALLY HELPED REACHED A
RESOLUTION FOR THE PERSON
CALLING IN FOR THEIR CLAIM AND
IT WAS. ABYSMALLY LOW IT WAS
LIKE LESS THAN 5% NOW YOU SAID
NOW YOU GUYS OF PROCESS TEN
MILLIONS DE ARE YOU KEEPING
STATISTICS ON THAT'S FINE
YOU'RE GETTING ALL THESE CALLS
IN YOUR ANSWERING THEM BUT ARE
YOU RESOLVING THE CASES. AND DO
YOU HAVE STATISTICS ON THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE TRYING TO GET ON WITH THE
PERSONNEL QUESTIONS IS ARE WE
HAVE OKAY PEOPLE ACTUALLY
ANSWER AND RESOLVE CASES SO
THAT PEOPLE ARE WAITING TWENTY
SIX WEEKS. YOU KNOW FOR AN
INTERVIEW- EXCITER. OKAY I
THINK I'M GONNA ALL REFER THIS
THE CHIEF OR TO DEPUTY OF THE.
FAULKNER AND CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OVER- SO YES THANKS TO
THE CSA RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE
MADE SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS
TO OUR CALL CENTER WHICH
INCLUDES IMPLEMENTING A POLICY
FOR TRACKING AND MONITORING
THEIR RATE OUR FIRST CALL
RESOLUTION. AND WE REVIEW THESE
DATA ON A MONTHLY BASIS TO
ENSURE WE'RE PROVIDING
EFFECTIVE ASSISTANCE TO CALLERS
PENSION SYSTEM. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'D LIKE ELABORATE ON THAT
AND GARCIA. YES ABSOLUTELY SO-
OF COURSE WE ARE PUTTING A FEW-
ENHANCEMENTS WOULD HAVE ROLLED
OUT SOME ENHANCEMENTS AND WE
ALSO ARE WORKING TO OUR RELEASE
SOME SOME ADDITIONAL
ENHANCEMENTS THAT ALLOW US NOT
ONLY TO. PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION TO CUSTOMERS- THEIR
BODY IN AN ATTEMPT TO AND
HOPEFULLY ELIMINATE THE NEED
FOR A CONSTITUENTS TO CALL IN-
AND SOME OF THE THINGS WE PUT
IN PLACE TO ENSURE- WE HAVE
THESE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM IS
TO WE BROUGHT OUT OUR VIRTUAL
HOLD WHICH- HAS BEEN SPOKEN
ABOUT- TODAY WE HAVE RELEASED A
MOBILE FRIENDLY. UPGRADE THAT
ALLOWS CONSTITUENTS TO UPLOAD
DOCUMENTS APPLY FOR BENEFITS
SUBMIT THE BI WEEKLY
ELIGIBILITY CERTIFICATION- VIEW
PAYMENT HISTORY AND PAYMENT
STATUS ALL FROM THEIR MOBILE
DEVICE- AND WE'VE ALSO RELEASED
THE CLAIM STATUS TRACKER
TRACKER- ON ARE YOU AYE ONLINE
WHICH PROVIDES CONSTITUENTS
WITH THE STATUS OF THE CLAIM-
THAT'LL HELP WITH
UNDERSTANDING- WHERE THEIR
CLAIM FALLS WITHIN- IT. ANY
KIND OF PENDING ELIGIBILITY
ISSUE THAT IS REQUIRING AN
INTERVIEW I'M A PHONE INTERVIEW
THAT HAS BEEN SCHEDULED OR THAT
HAS PASSED IT IS PENDING A
DECISION. OR WEEKS THAT THE
CONSTITUENT CONSERVE I- ALL OF
THIS IN- IN CONCURRENT SESSION
WITH LAUNCHING THE VOICE OF THE
CUSTOMER WHICH ALLOWS US TO
TRACK CUSTOMER QUESTIONS AND
PROACTIVELY PROVIDE THOSE
ANSWERS IN THE. CHAT BOX AND ON
ON OUR WEBSITE. OTHER THANK
THANK YOU FOR EXT THE BUT I'M
JUST TO GET AT. YOU KNOW THE
NUMBER LIKE. WITHIN TWO OR
THREE PHONE CALLS X. AMOUNT OF
CLAIMANTS CASES ARE RESOLVED
DID YOU GUYS KEEP THOSE
STATISTICS THIRTY OR NOT. I
THINK DURING THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY. IT WAS THE REASON THAT
THE STATE ORDERS TO RIMAC
RECOMMENDED THAT I'M NOT SURE
THAT. IT THAT WAS KEPT DURING
THAT TIME BUT IT IS BEEN
INITIATED NOW SPEAK INITIATED
THAT OKAY YEAH BECAUSE I THINK
THOSE ARE METRICS THAT HELP US
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO HELP
US. YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
PUBLIC AS WELL WHO WOULD WANT
TO KNOW THOSE. THOSE NUMBERS
THANK. YES SENATOR SENATOR
SALAS. I JUST LIKE TO REITERATE
THIS OF. WE WELCOME ANY OUR
THOUGHTS AND IDEAS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE OF IT AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED I HAVEN'T RUN THIS IS
MY FOURTH DEPARTMENT THIS IS
ONE OF THE MOST ROBUST
PARTNERSHIPS THAT I'VE HAD AS A
DIRECTOR AND YEAH ARE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT YEAH WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO RESOLVE ISSUES
MAKES GOVERNMENT WORK MORE
EFFICIENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
AND CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. I
KNOW THAT THAT. THE MEMBERS ON
THE DIETS ARE ANXIOUS TO ASK
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AS WELL.
BEFORE WE MOVE WE MOVE ON I
JUST I WANNA POINT OF
CLARIFICATION. BUT IT WAS
MENTIONED THAT 30% OF THE CALL
CENTER STAFF- THERE'S THAT
THERE'S A RETENTION ISSUE WHERE
30% OF THE OF THE STAFF LEAVES.
WHAT IS WHAT IS THE TRAINING
TIMELINE. TO HIRE. INDIVIDUALS
INTO THE CALL CENTER I WANT TO
GET A BETTER UNDERSTANDING IN
TERMS OF RETENTION
UNDERSTANDING- TRANSPARENCY AND
ULTIMATELY HELP THE HELP THE
GOES INTO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
CALLING CALIFORNIANS ARE
CALLING INTO THE CALL CENTER IN
TERMS OF RECEIVING EIGHT. SO IF
THERE'S A 30% RETENTION ISSUE
WHAT IS THE TIMELINE IN WHICH
NEWS NEW INDIVIDUALS ARE BEING
TRAINED INTO THE CALL CENTER.
GARCIA WOULD YOU LIKE TO ANSWER
THE CALL AND- MAY MAY I POINT
OUT THAT- 30% AS I SAID IS A
TRADITIONAL- STATISTIC OUR CALL
CENTERS PRIVATE AND IN PUBLIC.
YES TO ADD A LITTLE BIT MORE TO
THAT WE ARE SEEING THAT 30% OF
TUITION RATE AND UNFORTUNATELY
WE HAVE HAD OUR- OUR AGENTS ON
THE FRONT LINES ARE PROVIDING
SERVICES TO CONSTITUENTS- SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK TWELVE HOURS A DAY
WHICH CERTAINLY HAS LED TO-
INCREASED- FATIGUE AND
FRUSTRATION AS WELL AS MUCH AS
WE DO EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN SUPPORT
OUR INTERNAL STAFF WITH THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES AND
TRAINING. ON THE TYPICAL
TRAINING FOR OUR- OUR NEW LOOK
ONBOARDED EMPLOYS APPROXIMATELY
FOUR MONTHS AND THAT ALLOWS-
DIFFERENT METRICS AND ON THE
JOB TRAINING TO ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE SUPPORT FROM
THEIR DIRECT MANAGER I'M TO BE
ABLE TO FIELD MANY OF THOSE
QUESTIONS THAT COME UP WHEN WE
DO HAVE SOME SHADOW- TRAINING
SIDE BY SIDE THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT WE PROVIDE SOME
REINFORCEMENT TO STUFF AS WELL
SO THAT WE CAN IN. SUPPORT
STAFF AND ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
WHEN THEY'RE WORKING SUCH LONG
HOURS. THANK YOU FOR THAT AGAIN
JUST THE I WANT TO POINT OUT
JUST THE COMPLEXITIES OF
ONBOARDING TRAINING. OF ANY
DEATH. AND HOW IT CAN HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE LONG CALL CALL
TIMES AN- INTERVIEW. IT
INTERVIEW PROCESS AND WHATEVER
THAT LOOKS LIKE IT TAKES FOUR
MONTHS TO TRAIN INDIVIDUALS TO
GO INTO THE CALL CENTER CALL
CENTER AND THERE'S A 30%
RETENTION- ISSUE THEN THAT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
COMPLICATES. ASSISTING
CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE CALLING
IN. AND SO I JUST I WANNA MAKE
THAT VERY CLEAR THAT THAT IS
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY AN ISSUE THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED- MISTER
KELLY YOU HAD SOME QUESTIONS. I
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH- GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT DIRECTOR OF ONE
OF THE REASONS FOR THE LARGE
WORKLOAD FOR YOUR DEPARTMENT IS
THE VERY HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
IN CALIFORNIA- WHICH HAS
REMAINED- MUCH HIGHER HERE THAN
IN OTHER STATES THAT RETURN TO
RELATIVELY NORMAL LEVELS AND-
WE NOW HAVE THE HIGHEST
UNEMPLOYMENT IN THE COUNTRY.
WHY THAT IS. I THINK TO GIVE
YOU ARE AS ACCURATE. RESPONSE
ON THAT AS POSSIBLE LET ME JUST
SAY IN GENERAL. WE ARE ALL
AWARE OF THE DIFFICULTIES THAT
PEOPLE ARE. HAVING WITH HIRING
BUT WE ALSO THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFICULTIES BUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
LOOKING FOR A JOB. ONE OF THE
CENTRAL OF THEM IS THERE A FOR
WOMEN ESPECIALLY. A CHILD CARE.
YEAH I'M GONNA HAVE A CALEB OR
OF ANY WHICH OF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO. HANDLE THAT. YEAH THIS IS
CALEB MORAL- CHIEF OF THE
FISCAL PROGRAMS DIVISION FOR
UNITY I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION- I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN
REALLY RESPOND TO WHY
CALIFORNIA IS PERHAPS WORSE OFF
THAN THAN OTHER STATES WHAT I
CAN SAY IS THAT THE RECOVERY IN
CALIFORNIA LIKE OTHER STATES
HAS BEEN A LOT- QUICKER THAN
WHAT WE PREVIOUSLY ANTICIPATED-
I KNOW THAT ECONOMIC RATES ARE
PROJECTED- UNEMPLOYMENT RATES
MOVING INTO THE NEXT CALENDAR
YEAR ARE PROJECTED TO BE A LOT
LOWER THAN WHAT THEY PREVIOUSLY
WERE- AS I THINK ALL OF YOU
MEMBERS THAT HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT.
THIS RECESSION WAS ONE THAT WAS
VERY UNIQUE AND THAT THE ONSET
OF IT WAS SO QUICK AND THAT
THE- IMPACT TO- CLAIMANTS IN
THE STATE- WAS SO RAPID AND
SUDDEN AND IT CAUSED MASSIVE
INCREASES IN UNEMPLOYMENT
SYSTEM WHICH WAS VERY DIFFERENT
FROM THE GREAT RECESSION AND
THEN WHAT WE'RE ALSO SEEING ON
THE BACK END IS THE RECOVERY IS
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THE
RECOVERY WASN'T ADDRESS
RECESSION AS WELL WHICH WAS A
LOT MORE GRADUAL WE'RE SEEING A
MUCH MORE SON RECOVERY THEN
WHAT WAS DEFINITELY PREVIOUSLY
ANTICIPATED AND I CAN- INDICATE
THAT. IT LEAST CURRENT PUBLIC
ECONOMIC FORECAST DUE TO
ANTICIPATED HEADING INTO THIS
NEXT CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE PERHAPS DIPPING DOWN INTO
ABOUT FIVE AND A HALF PERCENT
LEVEL- OUT AS AN AVERAGE FOR
THE STATE AND THEN BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE I'M MOST MAJOR-
ECONOMIC INDICATORS AND
FORECASTS ARE PREDICTING
UNEMPLOYMENT LEVELS TO BE BACK
TO- ALMOST PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS-
HELP HOVERING. IN THE MID 4%
RANGE. I HOPE THAT HELPS AND
YOUR QUETION. WELL I DON'T
REALLY SEE HOW- WE HAD A QUICK
RECOVERY OUR UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
HAS BARELY BUDGED THIS YEAR
WHERE AS IN OTHER STATES IT'S
BEEN DIFFERENT AND SO HE HAS A
QUESTION FOR YOU MAYBE FOR THE
DIRECTOR I MEAN WE'RE WE'RE
LITERALLY LOST IN THE COUNTRY
AND SO OTHER STATES HAVE DONE A
BETTER JOB OF GETTING PEOPLE-BACK TO WORK. WHAT IS IT YOU
THINK THAT THEY'RE DOING THAT
WE'RE NOT. ACTUALLY I DON'T
THINK THAT THE- THEY'RE DOING
ANYTHING SUBSTANTIALLY
DIFFERENT THAN WE'RE DOING OF
WE'VE HAD AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF RETIREMENTS INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF WORKERS WHO
QUIT THEIR JOBS AND DECISION BY
WORKERS NOT TO JOIN THE LABOR
FORCE THAT'S HAPPENING ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY. AND JOB. WE LOST A
SUBSTANTIAL PORTION. A FROM
YOUR BUSINESSES- THE ONE AREA
THAT WE ARE SEEING SOME
IMPROVEMENT IS THE AREA THAT
WAS THE HARDEST HIT LAST YEAR
AND THAT WAS- HOSPITALITY AND-
ENTERTAINMENT I THINK SO- RIGHT
YOU KNOW IT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
WE HAVE A RESEARCH TEAM THAT WE
CAN TAKE A LOOK MORE CLOSELY AT
THE QUESTION THAT YOU ASKED. SO
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I CAN SAY
RIGHT NOW SO WE CAN GET BACK TO
YOU ON. I'M HAPPY TO ALLOW RATE
A LITTLE BIT DIRECTOR SIGNS-
I'M AMY FAULKNER AGAIN CHIEF
DEPUTY OF OPERATIONS. SO WE DO
HAVE ECONOMIST AT THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT THAT ARE REGULARLY
MONITORING. IRON POINT RATE AND
FLUCTUATIONS OF THE M.
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE. AND TRACKING
HOW CALIFORNIANS DOING AS
OPPOSED TO THE NATION. AND
ACCORDING TO THEIR KIND OF
ANALYSIS. AND REVIEW OF THE
LATEST WORK FORCE THERE ARE
SEVERAL TRANSCEND HAVE KIND OF
HAMPERED. THE RAPID DECLINE OF
THE STATE'S UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
SOME OF THOSE TRENDS INCLUDE A
BUSINESS HIRING TRENDS.
INCREASES IN THE NUMBER OF
RETIREMENTS AS THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED. INCREASES IN THE
NUMBER OF WORKERS THAT QUIT
JOBS AND THE DECISIONS OF
WORKERS JUST SIMPLY NOT TO JOIN
THE LABOR FORCE. AND IN TERMS
OF THE BUSINESS HIRING TRENDS-
THERE FOLLOWING RESEARCH PUBLIC
AVAILABLE RESEARCH. THAT HAS
KIND OF SAID THAT FIRMS HAVE
REDUCED UNEMPLOYMENT LEVELS
DURING THE RECESSIONARY
PERIODS. AND THAT THEY'VE UNDER
UTILIZED EMPLOYEES ON THEIR
PAYROLL SO INSTEAD OF CREEK
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
WORKERS IN THE SHORT TERM. SOME
BUSINESSES ARE LOOKING TO
UTILIZE THEIR CURRENT
WORKFORCE. BEFORE ADDING NEW
EMPLOYEES. I'M ALSO THE
DIRECTOR KIND OF ALLUDED TO YOU
KNOW THE CALIFORNIA BABY
BOOMERS AND PEOPLE BETWEEN
NINETEEN FORTY SIX TO NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR THAT CONTINUE TO
REQUIRE. AND RETIRE IN
INCREASING NUMBERS. AND THERE'S
IMPLICATIONS THERE AS IT
PERTAINS TO THE STATE
EMPLOYMENT. THE STATE'S
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE. I THINK IN
THE TO THE THERE IS MOST GIVE
FOR NUMBER. TO THE LABO AND-
INCLUDE TAKING FOR. SCHOOL
ENROLLMENT AND DISABILITY. WHEN
WE CAN GET TO THE NUMBERS ON IF
YOU'D LIKE THAT THAT BE GREAT
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
LOOKING INTO THIS ISSUE CLOSELY
I KIND OF STRUGGLE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW IT IS IN THE
CENTRAL ISSUE- THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS FOCUSED ON- NOT
ONLY BECAUSE- IT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT MEASURE OF OUR-
STATE'S ECONOMIC HEALTH BUT
ALSO BECAUSE THE BEST WAY TO
DEAL WITH- YOU KNOW THE
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIM BACKLOG IS
TO HAVE YOUR UNEMPLOYMENT
CLAIMS. ASIDE JUST ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT ISN'T THE
TOP PRIORITY OF THE DEPARTMENT.
WELL ONE OF THE THINGS. IS SO
YOU SO. YOU KNOW OUR EDG IS NOT
JUST UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE WE
ALSO HAVE A WORKFORCE SERVICES
BRANCH. AND THEY HAVE DONE A
SUBSTANTIAL OUT REACH. ARE TO
THE COMMUNITY TO GET PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK WE OFFER TRAINING
PROGRAMS AND WE FUND. LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS. TO DO TRAINING
PROGRAMS. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S HAPPENING IS THAT PEOPLE
ARE WAITING TO GET A BETTER
JOB. IT DOESN'T MEAN
NECESSARILY THAT THEY HAVE THE
SKILLS. TO FOR FILL THAT JOB.
SO YOU KNOW I JUST TALKED TO
MY- OUR DEPUTY OVER THERE. AND
THEY ARE SURPRISED AT THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ARE NOT
TAKING. THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
ADDITIONAL TRAINING. SO OUR- WE
ARE OUT THERE ARE POUNDING THE
PAVEMENT TRYING TO GET PEOPLE
JOBS WE WORK YOU KNOW IN OUR
AMERICAN. JOB CENTERS WE HAVE
PEOPLE THERE ARE WORKING WITH
PEOPLE TO GET THE BETTER JOBS
AND JOB WE'RE JUST NOT GETTING
THE UPTICK THAT WE EXPECTED.
THANK YOU ARE THAT ON ANOTHER
TOPIC THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE TRUST FUND MY-
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE DEBT
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS ON
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS NOW AND
THAT- THAT BUSINESSES ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO ACCOUNT FOR THAT
THROUGH INCREASED PAYROLL TAXES
IS THAT. CORRECT DO YOU WANT TO
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT.
YES I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION-
SO I CAPABLE FISCAL OFFICER
THREE D. YOU'RE CORRECT THE
CURRENT- OUTSTANDING TRUST FUND
DEBT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS ABOUT NINETEEN
POINT EIGHT BILLION AS OF THE
END OF LAST WEEK. AND THAT THE
EXISTING MECHANISM TO PAY DOWN
A TRUST FUND AT WHICH WAS THE
SAME MECHANISM THAT EXISTS IN
FEDERAL LAW AND HOW WE CLIMBED
OUT OF DEBT- AFTER THE GREAT
RECESSION IS THROUGH- FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT TAX ACT CREDIT
REDUCTIONS THAT'S THE FEDERAL
TAX ID EMPLOYERS PAY TO THE
IRS- FOR YOU I TAXES. AND THAT
WILL START TO BE INCREASED
COMING TAX YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- MOST EMPLOYERS PAY THAT
TAX THE BEGINNING OF THE
FOLLOWING YEAR SO MOST
EMPLOYERS WILL START TO SEE
THAT HIGHER INCREASED FEDERAL
TAX COMING ON JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AND JUST TO BE
CLEAR THE PORTION OF THAT. DEBT
THAT HAS RESULTED FROM THE
FRAUD. THAT TOO WILL BE- IT
PAID BACK THROUGH INCREASED
PAYROLL TAXES ON THE PART OF
THE EMPLOYERS. IS THAT CORRECT.
TO WHAT EXTENT FEDERAL YOU AYE
BENEFITS HAVE BEEN PAID OUT
FRAUDULENTLY IN THE REGULAR YOU
AYE PROGRAM ANYTHING
CONTRIBUTED TO THAT TRUST FUND
DEBT THAT IS PART OF THAT
OVERALL- TRUST FUND THAT
APPLICATION. MARIN TO THAT- A
SUBSTANTIAL PORTION OF THE FROG
ADA. WAS PAID OUT OF. IN THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM THE P. WAY
PROGRAM. AND THE FINAL QUESTION.
OF ALL THE FOLKS ALL THE
EMPLOYEES AT I. D. D. L.
MANAGEMENT OR OTHERWISE DO YOU
KNOW ROUGHLY HOW MANY HAVE BEEN
TERMINATED FOR SUB STANDARD JOB
PERFORMANCE SINCE HE BECAME
DIRECTOR. I'D HAVE TO I'D HAVE
TO GET SOME STATISTICS ON THAT.
GENEROSA INCIDENT IS IT YOU
KNOW SINGLE YOUNG DOUBLE DIGITS
NO I DON'T AND I DON'T HAVE ANY
SENSE THAT IT'S AN UNUSUAL
AMOUNT. AN UNUSUAL AMOUNT
MEANING A HIGH AMOUNT. YES OKAY
I MEAN I THINK SOME PEOPLE
MIGHT SAY THAT YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU LOOK AT A LOT OF THE
PROBLEMS THE EDS HAD MAYBE
THERE'S ROOM FOR- SOME
PERSONNEL CHANGES- OKAY I'M
SORRY I COULD NOT UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING I'M SORRY SO-
LET ME. LET ME SAY THIS. THE
ISSUE ADD. IS NOT. THAT WE
DON'T HAVE AN EXCEPTIONAL GROUP
OF PEOPLE. WHO ARE DEDICATED TO
GETTING THIS WORK DONE. AND
THAT THEY ARE COMPETENT WE HAVE
A LIBRARY THAT OUR STAFF IS
VERY COMPETENT NOT I CAN SAY
THAT BECAUSE I RUN ALL THE
DEPARTMENTS. OKAY SO THERE'S NO
LACK OF CONFIDENCE IN THIS
DEPARTMENT. IF YOU GO BACK TO
WHAT THE STATE ARBITRATION IT
REALLY IS WAS A FAILURE OF
SYSTEMS. THE BUSINESS RULES
THAT YOU TO DATE HAS BEEN
OPERATING UNDER. THE LEGACY
SYSTEM THAT IT HAS HAD TO
CONTEND WITH. THE NEW RULES AND
NEW PROGRAMS WERE ON A GESTURE
THAT CAME TO EDT THOSE WERE A
LARGE PART OF THE PROBLEMS FOR
EDT. SO IT IS IT IS NOT THE
PEOPLE. IT WAS THE SYSTEMS THAT
YOU DD WAS OPERATING UNDER.
THAT CREATED THE PROBLEM IN
ADDITION TO HAVING TO DEAL WITH
A STAGGERING WORKLOAD. ARE
THERE ANY WAYS IN WHICH YOU
KNOW YOU COULD BE GIVEN
GREATER. CONTROL AND
FLEXIBILITY OVER HOW YOU MANAGE
YOUR PERSONNEL- THAT YOU THINK
WOULD LEAD TO A BETTER
PERFORMANCE OF THIS AGENCY OR
THE OTHERS THE RUN- FOR THAT
MATTER WILL. THINK IT'S A
WONDERFUL QUESTION- AND- I'M
HERE TO TELL YOU THAT I HAVE
MADE CHANGES. BUT I MEAN IN
TERMS OF WHAT IS A LIAR. WHAT
YOU TO DO UNDER EITHER STATE
LAW OR THE RELEVANT- CONTRACTS.
HAVING BEEN A CIVIL SERVANT.
OFTEN IN FORTY YEARS LET ME SAY
THAT. THERE IS A BALANCE
BETWEEN ATTRACTIONS ALL OF OUR
EMPLOYEES AND OF THE KINDS OF
PROCESSES THAT HAVE TO BE
UNDERTAKEN TO MOVE EMPLOYEES
OUT OKAY. R. IF YOU TALK TO
ANYONE WHO KNEW ME AS A
DIRECTOR BEFORE. THEY CAN TELL
YOU. I HAVE MOVED AS MANY AS
TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE. AT A TIME
OUT OF THE DEPARTMENT SO I AM
RELUCTANT I HAVE PLENTY OF
FLEXIBILITY AND I WILL I AM
ALSO HERE TO TELL YOU IF PEOPLE
ARE. ON OUR STEM. ARE BEING
INAPPROPRIATE. WITH ANY CRIME
OR THEY'RE NOT GETTING THEIR
JOB DONE IT COMES TO MY
ATTENTION. AND IT'S VERY SELDOM
THAT WE HAVE HAD TO. FIRE
PEOPLE FOR INCOMPETENCE. VERY
SELDOM. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
I'M THANK YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF
VERY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT
I'D LIKE TO JUMP INTO- THAT
BEFORE I DO AND I DON'T WANT TO
BEAT A DEAD HORSE BUT I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
BE TO BE HONEST ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENED AND I THINK YOU SAID
THAT THE FAILINGS WERE THE
RESULT OF SYSTEM FAILURES THE
ACTUAL TITLE OF THE AUDIT THAT
WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT.
ACTUALLY IS CALLED EDIE'S POOR
PLANNING AND INEFFECTIVE
MANAGEMENT LEFT UNPREPARED TO
ASSIST CALIFORNIANS UNEMPLOYED
BY COVERED NINETEEN SHUT DOWN
SO JUST RESPONDING TO YOUR LAST
RESPONSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
MOMENT THAT APT AT OKAY A
COUPLE OF VERY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS TO FIRST IN FRAUD
WHAT IS YOUR UPDATED ESTIMATE
OF- THE FRAUD THAT WAS
PERPETRATED THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC. OF THE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS PAID OUT. TWENTY
BILLION IS ESTIMATED TO BE
FRAUDULENT. TWENTY BILLION OKAY.
AND I'M I KNOW IT IN YOUR
OPENING REMARKS YOU YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU'VE DONE
QUITE A BIT TO STOP THIS. AT
BEYOND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
CROSS CHECKING WITH CDCR WHICH
I'M REALLY FAMILIAR WITH CAN
YOU. ARTICULATE WHICH SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS. THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED OR WHAT SPECIFIC
CHANGES HAVE BEEN MADE TO MAKE
OUR FRAUD DEFENSES MORE ROBUST.
ABSOLUTELY ASSEMBLY RUNNING- WE
HAVE- WE HIRED ID ME- AND
THOMSON REUTERS BOTH OF WHICH
COMPANIES ARE ARE THAT WERE
CONSIDERED FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN THEIR NEW- FRAUD
PREVENTION BUDGET WILL PROB
FIVE PREVENTION PROCUREMENT. WE
HAVE ID ME I'M HERE THOMSON
REUTERS. AND WE HAVE ACCENTURE
THAT HAS BEEN HELPING US TO
REFINE AND REVIEW THE STANDARDS
THAT BOTH PROGRAMS BOTH ID ME
THOMPSON WRITERS ARE USING.
THANK YOU I'M AND THEN JUST
BACK TO THE CONVERSATION THAT
WE WERE HAVING EARLIER ABOUT
FIRST CALL RESOLUTION AND- I
THINK WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF STEPS
IMPLEMENTED Q. RACK FIRST CALL
RESOLUTION. WHEN SO WHAT IS THE
CURRENT FIGURE FOR THE NUMBER
OF CALLS THAT ARE RESOLVED
FIRST TRY. CAN YOU HAVE A
RESPONSE TO THAT. I DO I AM I
DON'T HAVE THE EXACT NUMBER BUT
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A SERVICE
LEVEL AGREEMENT INTERNALLY TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN RESOLVE OUR
FOR OURS THE FIRST CALL
RESOLUTION- BY AT LEAST 60% AND
EVERY ATTEMPT- WE SEEM TO BE
MEETING THAT I CAN PROVIDE-
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AS FAR
AS THAT THE STATISTICS ARE THE
INFORMATION SHORTLY AFTER
WONDERFUL THANK YOU YES IF WE
CAN CAN FOLLOW UP WITH THAT
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. AND I'M
ON THE AT DEFERRED AT WORKLOAD
ISSUES SO. I BELIEVE YOU SAID
THAT THERE'S A PLAN TO RESOLVE
AT THAT DEFERRED WORKLOAD OVER
THE COURSE OF THE NEXT AS ITS
BY SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AS THE AUDITOR POINTED OUT
THE WINDOW FOR US TO ACTUALLY.
FIVE I GUESS RESOLVE CLAIMS THE
PREP FOR PAID OUT MISTAKENLY
DOES NOT REMAIN OPEN FOREVER
WHAT IS THE WINDOW RIGHT WHICH
THAT BACKLIT THE AD DEFERRED
WITH WORKLOAD HAS TO BE
RESOLVED. WHAT'S THE DROPPED IT
HERE. YES SO WE DO HAVE A YEAR
FROM THE BENEFIT YEAR END FOR
THAT COLLECTION THE OVERPAYMENT
ESTABLISHMENT TO OCCUR FOR THE-
FOR THE NON FOUGHT FOUGHT WE DO
HAVE THREE YEARS FROM THAT
BENEFIT YOUR AND FOR ANY FRAUD
OR FALSE THAT IS IDENTIFIED IN
THE STOP LIST. OKAY SO THAT
WOULD BE THIRD READING MEANT.
EITHER THIS END OF THIS YEAR
FIRST SOME OF THAT SO WITH
EVERY TIME AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR. IT IT'S THE BENEFIT YEAR
END WHICH MEANS IF- A CLAIM WAS
UP THE BENEFIT YOUR BEGAN IN
MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY- IT'S ONE
YEAR FROM THE BENEFIT YOUR END
SO IT'S MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AGAINST THE CLOCK AND IT'S
ONE YEAR FROM MAY OF THIS YEAR.
AND CRISTINA WOULD YOU OKAY
THEREFORE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE OVERPAYMENT AND THE
COLLECTION OF THE OVERPAYMENT.
YES SO- WE HAVE THAT THE TIME
FRAME IN WHICH THAT PARAMETER
COMES INTO PLAY IS JUST THE
ESTABLISHMENT WE CAN CONTINUE
COLLECTION EFFORTS BEYOND THAT
TIME FRAME I'M SO LONG AS IT'S
ESTABLISHED WITHIN THAT PERIOD
OF TIME. OKAY UNDERSTOOD THANK
YOU FOR CLARIFYING THAT AND I'M-
WE'VE TALKED A BIT ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUR- ABILITY TO I
THINK CONTINUE TO TRACK AND
ADDS IT TO MONITOR THE PROGRESS
THAT'S BEING MADE AND TO
FULFILL OUR OUR ROLES- AS SAID.
AS THE ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE
AND- THE AUDIT COMMITTEE AND
THE UP BUDGETS OF FOR COMMITTEE.
DO YOU HAVE THAT ESTIMATES.
ORTEGA'S COMMITMENTS OF WENDY'S
REMAINING RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
GOING TO BE COMPLETED SO I
THINK THERE'S EIGHT OF TWENTY
ONE THAT ARE EITHER. PARTIALLY
IMPLEMENTED ARE PENDING- EITHER
IF YOU CAN TAKE THEM OFF NOW
THAT WOULD BE GREAT IF NOT IF
YOU CAN INCLUDE THAT AS A POINT
OF FOLLOW UP. IN NON. THAT THE
COMING DAYS. WELL AS THE BUZZER
OF THE PARTRIDGE DR SAID
EARLIER THESE ARE ISSUES THAT
ARE GOING TO BE MONITORED OVER
TIME SO- WHICH WE WOKE UP- BUT
THEY'RE GONNA BE MONITORED OVER
TIME SO THE FIRSTPART OF IT IS
A COMPLETE IS COMPLETE BUT THE
REST HAS TO BE SOUGHT. THE
DECISION OF THE STATE AUDITOR
FOR WHAT. CONSTITUTES
SUFFICIENT OVER TIME. THE
IMPLEMENTATION. I THINK IT'S
PROBABLY IN THEIR HANDS. AND
I'M I'M JUST MEANING I'M
LITERALLY JUST MEAN AT WHAT
POINT I WANT TO KNOW LIKE FOR
HIM I THINK WE'VE GOT EIGHT
RECOMMENDATIONS I WANT TO KNOW
HOW WHICH OF THEM ARE GONNA BE
DONE IN NOVEMBER DECEMBER
JANUARY IT'S SATURDAY- SO THAT
WE CAN UNDERSTAND AND WHEN WE
CAN SAY OKAY THIS IS DONE. AND
WE'RE DONE. AND AS I SAID
THAT'LL PROBABLY BE IN THE IN
THE PURVIEW OF THE STATE
AUDITOR. BECAUSE WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO DO IT THE STATE
AUDITOR HAS TO DECIDE WHEN
THEY'LL BE SATISFIED. THAT
WE'VE MET OF THE DEAD YOU KNOW
THAT WE HAVE SATISFIED THEN
THAT THE- PROCEDURE IS
SUFFICIENTLY IN PLACE IT WILL
CONTINUE. I UNDERSTAND
COMPLETELY WHY. THEY'RE DOING
THAT. IF OUR EDIE WAS. RAISED
IN PREVIOUSLY IN PREVIOUS YEARS
AND THE THING DIDN'T GET
COMPLETE OR SOMETHING WENT
WRONG. ANOTHER REASON REASON TO
HAVE. THEM THE NEW YORK POINTS
CARD- THEN- THE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO MEET THE ARE SATISFIED
OF THIS ARE. THEY FEEL THIS IS
NOT PERMANENTLY IN PLACE
BECAUSE AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED
THERE PERMANENTLY IN PLACE.
UNDERSTOOD AND CERTAINLY THE
STATE AUDITOR WILL PLAY A ROLE
IN DETERMINING WHETHER OR NOT
THE CONDITIONS OF SATISFACTION
HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN MAPPED. BUT
MY QUESTION FOR YOU IN YOUR
DEPARTMENT. IS WHAT IS YOUR
TIMELINE. FOR FULLY
IMPLEMENTING EACH OF THE
REMAINING ITEMS THAT ARE ON
THIS LIST. WE WILL MEET THE
STATE AUDITOR'S DEADLINES BUT
YOU'VE ALREADY MISSED THE STATE
AUDITOR'S DEADLINES NO WE HAVE
MET THE STATE AUDITOR'S
DEADLINE IN ESTABLISHING A
POLICY BUT THEY'RE NOT RISKING
TO MONITOR OVER TIME THE
IMPLEMENTATION WHICH I LIKE I
SAID I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND.
AND SOME OF THE I THINK GO
THERE ARE FEW OF THESE IN THE
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG THAT
ARE NOT DO YOU. THAT'S CORRECT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
ASSEMBLY WOMEN PETRIE-NORRIS.
THEIR TIMELINES FOR EACH OF
THEIR RESPECTIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS VERY. AS SOME
OF THEM HAVE CSA IMPOSE
DEADLINES IN WHICH THE EDB
FULLY INTENDS TO MEET. AND SOME
OF THEM DO NOT HAVE A CSA
IMPOSE DEADLINES THEY HAD ETT
IMPOSE DEADLINES. SO WE
PROVIDED A DAY IN WHICH WE
INTEND TO- TO FULLY MEET. SEVEN
THANKS VERY OKAY AND THE
DIRECTORS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT
THAT. WE DON'T SEE FULL
IMPLEMENTATION UNTIL WE MEET
THE EXPECTATIONS OF THE CSA
OPERATOR AND THAT AS BEEN A
PARTNERSHIP IN A COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS THAT WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE. AND WE INTEND TO
CONTINUE TO SEE THAT ALL.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY THREE OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED. OKAY AND PERHAPS I
CAN THEN MAYBE I CAN TURN TO
THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE WITH THE
FOLLOW UP THEN ON THIS SO. IT
THERE THERE ARE EIGHT OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT. ARE
LISTED AS EITHER. PENDING OR
PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED. HAVE YOU
ESTABLISHED UPDATED TIMELINES
FOR WHEN YOU EXPECT DOES NOT
SEE ANY RECOMMENDATIONS TO BE
FULLY IMPLEMENTED. BOB HARRIS
FOR THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
SO THE TIME LINES THAT WE
EXPECT HAVE NOT CHANGED OR OR
MOVED- I THINK THE INFORMATION
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR AND WE
CAN GO THROUGH ANY SPECIFIC ONE
RIGHT NOW- EDT HAS PROVIDED AN
ESTIMATED COMPLETION DATE TO US
FOR EACH OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT'S UP ON OUR WEBSITE RIGHT
NOW I ALSO HAVE IN FRONT OF ME
IF YOU HAVE A SPECIFIC QUESTION
ABOUT ONE OF THEM. OR WHICHEVER
ONES OF THEM I COULD I COULD
GIVE YOU WHAT THEY'VE PROVIDED
TO US RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
THEIR ESTIMATED COMPLETION DATE
AND I DON'T THINK WE NEED TO
GET TO THAT HABIT YOU'RE SAYING
THERE IS IN FACT AN ESTIMATED
COMPLETION DATE THAT DOES EXIST
THAT THEY PROVIDED TO AFFECT
UNDER FULL SO WE WILL. ADD
CYCLE BACK ON ON THOSE
SPECIFICS THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THAT AND I WOULD
SAY- TO BACK TO- AT. EDT AB I
THINK ON A SIMILAR VEIN WE
TALKED A BIT ABOUT THE B. S. M.
PROJECT AND I UNDERSTAND THAT.
I WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING AN
AGILE APPROACH AND WE ARE GOING
TO BE IMPLEMENTING THIS
INCREMENTALLY WHICH- I THINK
IS. IS EXACTLY WHAT WE SHOULD
BE DOING- AS THE AUDITOR HAD
MENTIONED WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
FOCUSING ON. THE MOST MISSION
CRITICAL ELEMENTS. AND I THINK
THAT AS A FOLLOW UP TO THIS
HEARING. POSSIBLY EVEN AS A
TOPIC OF IT AND- HAVE A NEXT
HEARING. UNDERSTANDING HOW THAT
BSM IS GOING TO UNFOLD. WHAT IS
MISSION CRITICAL. AND WHAT CAN
WE WHAT ENHANCEMENTS AND
IMPROVEMENTS CAN WE EXPECT TO
SEE WHEN. I THINK WOULD BE
REALLY PRODUCTIVE. AGAIN NOT
LOOKING FOR RESPONSE AND THAT
NOW JUST FOLLOWING AT FLAGGING
THAT. FOR FOLLOW UP AS WE AT.
YOUR WORD. AND CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO CONTINUALLY IMPROVE
THE SERVICE THAT WE'RE
OFFERING. TO OUR CONSTITUENTS.
I THINK IT'S AN EXCELLENT IDEA.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MISTER SALAS NE HAD A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION. THANK YOU
RETURNS ONCE ASKED THE QUESTION
AND SOMETHING THAT I KNOW HAS
BEEN ADDRESS JUST YET. WHAT I
WANTED TO ASK ABOUT AND ON ON
THE ISSUE OF BANKING. RIGHT TO
THE START OF THE PANDEMIC YOU
KNOW EDT DEBIT CARDS ISSUED BY
THE BANK OF AMERICA HAS BEEN A
HEADACHE FOR. SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN CONNECTED TO BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN FRAUD AND FRUSTRATED
CALIFORNIANS IS FUNDS HAVE BEEN
FROZEN IN FACT THERE'S A CLASS
ACTION LAWSUIT. REGARDING THE
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS TO
BUY THEIR BENEFITS WHEN THEIR
BANK OF AMERICA CARDS WERE
FROZEN SO I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE RATIONALE- MADAM
DIRECTOR JUST FROM EDT TO RENEW
THE CONTRACT WITH BANK OF
AMERICA. WAS IT WOULD CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE THE DEBIT. DEBIT
CARE SERVICE. OKAY THE ANSWER
TO YOUR QUESTION I BROUGHT IN A
SPECIALIST IN CONTRACTS NOT TO
SUPPORT WAY OUR ALREADY
EXCEPTIONAL CONTRACTS STAFF. TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE BANK OF
AMERICA CONTRACT- WE ARE
EXTENDED IT BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
WANT TO SEE A DISRUPTION IN
SERVICES FOR OUR CLIENTS- I
THINK THE- EARLIER IN THE
HEARING SOMEBODY GAVE A NUMBER
OF THE- NUMBER OF CARS THAT
WERE FROZEN AND IT WAS ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
ACCOUNTS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND OF THOSE. COULD NOT BE
VERIFIED AND THEREFORE REMAIN
FROZEN. A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND WERE VERIFIED AND ARE
BEING PAID. WE HAVE ALL WE HAVE
A MUCH. STRONGER RELATIONSHIP
WITH BANK OF AMERICA RIGHT NOW
AND I THINK WE EVER HAD THEY
ARE THE MORE COOPERATIVE WITH
US FOR THE INFORMATION THAT
WE'RE SEEKING FROM THEM ABOUT
THESE CARDS THE FREEZING
BLOCKING A CART. AT THE SAME
TIME. WE ARE PREPARING RFP. TO
LET IN A FEW MONTHS FOR DIRECT
DEPOSIT. DR RIGHT NOW IF
SOMEBODY CATCHES WITH BANK OF
AMERICA TO HAVE IF THEY HAVE AN
ACCOUNT THEY HAVE THE MONEY PUT
IN DIRECT DEPOSIT IN YOUR
ACCOUNT OR THEY CAN HAVE CHOOSE
TO HAVE. THE BANK CARD. LOADING
WITH THE MONEY. THAT'S YOUR
QUESTION YEAH NO THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THE RELATIONSHIP AND
HOW IT IMPROVES LIKE I DO
APPRECIATE THAT SO DOES THAT
MEAN WE WORK THROUGH THE NUMBER
OF ISSUES THAT WE'VE READ AND
HEARD ABOUT FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS RIGHT A LOT OF IT
A LOT OF IT WAS A DEBIT CARDS-
THE ADDITIONAL FEES THAT THEY
HAD TO. BUT THEY HAD TO AND
CURRENT BECAUSE OF THE DEBIT
CARDS AND THEN YOU JUST TOUCHED
UPON MY NEXT QUESTION. ABOUT
DIRECT DEPOSITS ARE WE GONNA
ALLOW DIRECT DEPOSIT SO THAT WE
AVOID THE DEBIT CARD KIND OF
FIASCO THAT WE'VE BEEN DEALING
WITH SINCE THE PANDEMIC. YES WE
WILL EVENTUALLY WELL IT WILL
TAKE- THIS IS NOT AN OVERNIGHT-
OVER TOP OF A CHANGE. IN AND
DAY OUT WELL AS I SHOULD
REDEVELOPMENT ARE A FEW RIGHT
NOW. THE THANK YOU TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR GIVING US THE
MONEY. TO IN. ADD TO OUR I. T.
SYSTEM SO THAT WE COULD
ACCOMMODATE THIS CHANGE. BUT
IT'S PROBABLY A COUPLE OF YEARS
OR. A COUPLE OF YEARS OKAY
THAT'S WHO WILL BE WAY PASSES
PANDEMIC I GUESS WE'RE GETTING
READY FOR THE NEXT. RECESSION
BECAUSE YOU KNOW. IT'S A LITTLE
FRUSTRATING BECAUSE YOU SEE
LIKE PLACES LIKE MARYLAND OR
MASSACHUSETTS AND WASHINGTON
THESE OTHER STATES THAT I AM
ABLE TO DO THE DIRECT DEPOSIT.
RIGHT AWAY AND IT'S JUST YOU
KNOW BEGS THE QUESTION WHY WE
COULDN'T DO THAT AND STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH. AS
TECHNOLOGICALLY AS ADVANCED AS
WE LIKE TO SAY WE ARE WHY WE
COULDN'T DO THIS FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THEN ACTUALLY
AVOID SOME OF THE- THE FEES
FROM DEBIT CARDS AND ALL OF THE
DEBIT CARD FIASCO IN ACCOUNTS
BEING FROZEN NOT FROZEN IN
GETTING TO THE RIGHT
INDIVIDUALS- JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. YOU KNOW. I
UNDERSTAND I KNOW IT'S
FRUSTRATING I KNOW IT'S
FRUSTRATING AT SOME POINT THE
STATE DECIDED THE DEBIT. CARDS
WOULD BE A BETTER ALTERNATIVE.
FOR COMPLIMENTS. IT I THINK
THAT KIND- WITH REGULAR HAS
BEEN IN PLACE FOR FIVE OR SIX
YEARS NOW. AND THERE WERE NOT
THE SAME ISSUES THAT WE IN
CHARACTER INDEPENDENT. WE ALSO
DIDN'T HAVE DURING THOSE SAME
YEARS CRIMINAL. RINGS
ASSAULTING THE U. Y. SYSTEM
HERE. RIGHT AND WHILE AND
WHILE- OTHER STATES HAVE DIRECT
DEPOSIT I CAN GUARANTEE YOU
THAT IT DID NOT HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT. DOING THESE OUT
CONTRACTS FOR DIRECT DEPOSIT
ARE COMPLICATED THEY'RE ALL
KINDS OF RULES AND REGULATIONS
THAT GO. AND ANDY AND THE OTHER
THING IS THAT THERE ARE NOT A
WHOLE LOT OF- THANKS OUT THERE
THE ONE IT IS BUSINESS. YEAH
YEAH WELL THAT'S JUST MY HOPE
THAT SHE REACHED OUT TO PERHAPS
YOUR COUNTERPARTS IN.
CALIFORNIANS YOU WILL BE VERY
GLAD TO HEAR THAT WE HAVE DONE
ALL THOSE THINGS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS I DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF FINAL
QUESTIONS BUT BEFORE WE GO INTO
THAT I WANNA JUST THANK THE
STAFF THAT'S IN THE ROOM- FOR
ALL OF THEIR SUPPORT IN PUTTING
THIS BUDGET HEARING TOGETHER
WE'VE GOT A LITTLE BIT OVER
TIME AND SO I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE PANELISTS AT EDT I
KNOW WE HAVE THE OFFICE OF
FINANCE AS WELL AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ALL UP. THE L. A.
ILL AS WELL AS WELL AS THE
STATE AUDITOR WHO'S WHO'S STILL
HERE IN THE IN THE ROOM- IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE LET US KNOW IF
YOU'RE IN THE ROOM ON THE PHONE
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT OF THE NUMBER S.
877-692-8957 THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO ZERO TWO I DO WANT TO GIVE
AN OPPORTUNITY. TO MY
COLLEAGUES TO MAKE ANY FINAL
REMARKS AS WE CLOSE OFF I DO
HAVE JUST TWO PENDING QUESTIONS
THAT HAVE ARISEN JUST A AS WE
CLOSE OUT WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
THE TWENTY SIX WEEK TIME
BEFORE- THE INTERVIEW PROCESS
BUT THERE WAS ALSO MENTION
ABOUT THE SIX MONTH SPIKE UP
FOR EDT CASES I'M CURIOUS AS TO
HOW YOU'RE HANDLING THE SPIKE
AND I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS TO.
WHAT OTHER RESOURCES ARE NEEDED
FOR EDT TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
MANAGE THE SPIKE AND WE'RE NOT
SURE WHAT THE FUTURE IS GOING
TO LEAD TO BUT THAT IS A VERY
REAL SITUATION RIGHT NOW THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO MANAGE IN TERMS
OF EFFICIENCY AND GETTING BACK
TO THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHO RIGHTFULLY DESERVE SOME
HELP. SO I GUESS I'LL I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO YOU DIRECTOR SIGNS
HOW ARE YOU MANAGING THE SIX
MONTHS BIKE. AND THEN TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHAT ARE
THE RESOURCES ARE ARE NECESSARY
AND NEEDED AT THIS TIME. OKAY
LET ME CLARIFY AND- AND-
CHAIRWOMAN CARILLO- I WANT TO
PERSONALLY THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE SUPPORT THAT YOU'VE GIVEN
ME AND THE DEPARTMENT. OVER
THESE. MONTHS THAT I HAVE BEEN
DIRECTOR- YOUR ARE YOUR
CRITICISMS YOUR SUGGESTIONS.
APPLE ALL BEEN VERY WELCOME. SO.
I WANT TO POINT OUT I THINK YOU
KNOW THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS
THAT ARE COMPLICATED AN EDT. SO
ONE OF THE REASONS FOR THE
SPIKE IS AT THE FEDERAL
BENEFITS AND- SOME OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON FEDERAL
BENEFITS. BURKE CAME ON THEN
OFF FEDERAL BENEFITS AND DURING
SOME PORTION OF TIME. WORKED
AND THEY- THEY GENERATED FUNDS
SOME PEOPLE DID NOT. AT THE END
FEDERAL BENEFITS WE ENCOURAGE
THOSE PEOPLE WHO MIGHT QUALIFY
TO REAPPLY- AS HOPE SPRINGS
ETERNAL WE HAD A COMBINATION OF
PEOPLE WHO DO QUALIFY AND A
LARGE PORTION PEOPLE WILL DO
NOT. WE ALSO HAD A LARGE WITH A
FRAUDULENT APPLICATIONS. ALL
THE REST OF THAT I'M GONNA
LEAVE FOR OGRESS HERE TO
EXPLAIN. THE SPIKE WHEN I WENT
THERE I THINK YOU HAVE TO KEEP
THOSE TWO THINGS IN MIND. YES
THERE WAS EDTA- TO ADD TO IT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THAT DIRECTOR-
PREVIOUSLY- SPOKE ABOUT A
CHANGING AND ADJUSTING THE WAY
IN WHICH WOULD PREFER PERFORM
OUR WORK. WHICH I REFERENCED IS
A PART OF- THE LEGISLATION AND
SOME OF THE SEASON
RECOMMENDATIONS AS FAR AS THE
FRAMEWORK TO ESTABLISH A
RECESSION PLAN- ADJUSTING THE
WAY IN WHICH WE'RE PERFORMING
OUR WORK INCLUDES- SOME OF THE
AREAS IN WHICH WE ARE. CHANGING
THE WAY IN WHICH WE- COMPLETE.
ELIGIBILITY INTERVIEWS WHERE
WHERE ARE CURRENTLY LOOKING AT
ENSURING THAT WE CAN- TILT THE
PROCESS TO ALLOW THE CUST THE
CONSTITUENT TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY INFORMATION
BEFOREHAND THEREFORE
ELIMINATING AN INTERVIEW- AND
ALLOWING US TO MAKE A DECISION
WITHOUT AVAILABLE INFORMATION-
WITH THEIR RESPONSE
INFORMATION. WE ARE CONTINUING
TO LOOK AT- CROSS TRAINING ANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO CROSS TRAIN
STAFF- IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
WE CAN- CONTINUE ALONG WITH THE
BENDER THE CONTRACTOR VENDOR TO
LIQUIDATE THIS WORKLOAD. WE ARE
PUTTING OUR PROCESSES AND OUR
FRAMEWORK IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT- WE CAN PREPARE FOR THE
END AND IT NEXT COMING SPIKED
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT.
THE ON. HOW TO MAKE
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
CERTAINLY WAS A NEW ONE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THAN
ANYTHING WE'VE EVER HAD IT
WITHIN THE U. I. PROGRAM. AND
SO FOLDING THAT INTO OUR
PREPAREDNESS FOR THE FUTURE IS
GOING TO BE VITAL TO ENSURE
THAT WEEK. THE DEPARTMENT. IS
SUCCESSFUL IN THE NEXT DOWNTURN.
AND WE ARE. VERY AWARE OF.
THANK YOU I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
ANY COMMENTS. FIVE HUNDRED TOP
IN THE FARMING TO FINANCE THE
THANK YOU CHAIRED BY WESTERN-
RIGHT NOW YOU KNOW YOU NEED HAS
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED AS WELL
AS THE BUDGET AUTHORITY TO
ADJUST THE AMOUNT OF FEDERAL
RESOURCES IN OCTOBER AND MAY-
TO MEET WORKLOAD DEMANDS. ON
PLACENTA THAT WERE SO VALUE
WAITING- RESOURCES AND DON'T
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU FOR
THAT MUCH APPRECIATED AND ONE
FOLLOW UP QUESTION IS. TO EDT
ITSELF WHAT PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE IN IMPLEMENTING AB ONE
THIRTY EIGHT THE TRAILER BILL
THAT CONTAINS A LANGUAGE ACCESS
PROVISIONS. WHICH WAS A HUGE. A
HUGE PART OF THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE HAVE HAD IN VARIOUS
DIFFERENT HEARINGS. YES I THINK
GOT THANK YOU- THANK YOU SIMPLY
RUN A CAREER. I THINK I
MENTIONED IN MY- TESTIMONY.
YEAH WE HAVE EXPANDED LANGUAGE
LUNCH HOUR. AND WE HAVE
ADVERTISED THE EXPANSION OF
THOSE LANGUAGE LINES AND WE'RE
GETTING INCREASED CALLS EVERY
WEEK. IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
ARE WE HAVE OUR MODIFIED
RETRANSMITTED A NUMBER OF KEY
FORMS THE CLAIMANTS USE SO THAT
THEY'RE AVAILABLE IN THEIR OWN
LANGUAGE WE HAVE- IN EXPANDING
THE LANGUAGE LINES OF THE
TRANSLATION FOR THE LANGUAGE
LINES WE HAVE HAD A SPECIAL
TRAINING FOR OUR STAFF SO THAT
THEY CAN BETTER I HAVE BETTER
CAPACITY TO USE THOSE LANGUAGE
WORDS. ARE HERE IN DROUGHT WE
ARE LOOKING TO OUR TRANSLATE
EVEN MORE FORMS. WITHOUT INTO
THE FIFTEEN LANGUAGES AND ONCE
WE HAVE DONE THAT WE ARE GOING
TO OPEN UP A SPECIAL LANGUAGE
LINE PORTAL. AND GARCIA
ANYTHING ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO ADD
TO THAT. S. C. O. T. T- I'M
JUST ADDITIONAL- ITEM TO ADD IS
THE LANGUAGE ACCESS OFFICE
WHICH IS- WE'RE CURRENTLY
RECRUITING FOR THE WHOLE TIME
LEGAL ACCESS COORDINATOR ON
THIS EXPECTED TO BEGIN IN
NOVEMBER OF THIS YEAR AND
RECRUITING ADDITIONAL STAFF
MEMBERS FOR THIS UNITS
ANTICIPATED BY. A TO BEGIN IN
JANUARY OF NEXT YEAR. THIS
OFFICE IS GOING TO BE IN THE
DIRECTOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
FOR THAT SO JUST TO BE CLEAR WE
ARE THAT EDT WILL FULLY
IMPLEMENT A FULLY FUNCTIONING
FRAUD DEPARTMENT AND STAFF BY
THE END OF NOVEMBER AS WELL AS
THE LANGUAGE ACCESS PROGRAMS BY
THE END OF NOVEMBER AND A FULLY
TRAINED STAFF. BY JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS THAT
ACCURATE. WHAT IS ACCURATE I
THINK YOU'VE GOT MOST OF IT OUT
WE HAVE ALREADY TRAINED STAFF
TO USE THE IMPROVE LANGUAGE
LINES. WE HAVE ALREADY EXPANDED
OUR CONTRACTS WITH THE LANGUAGE
LINE CONTRACTORS. WE ARE STILL
IN THE PROCESS OF TRANSLATING A
NUMBER OF FORMS WE HAVE
TRANSLATED ALREADY ALREADY
TODAY A NUMBER OF FORMS A KEY
FORMS THAT ARE USUALLY USED
WHEN PEOPLE ARE APPLYING. FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT AND THE OTHERS.
THE OTHERS WILL BE DONE OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME. GARCIA DO WE
HAVE OUT DO WE HAVE A TIME LINE
FOR THAT BUT YOU RECALL. YES
THE NEW UNIT. YES SO TO
CONFIRM- ASSEMBLY TDD TO
CONFIRM THE FRAUD UNIT YES-
CONFIRMING THAT IT IS EXPECTED
TO BE WE'RE ACTUALLY HOLDING
INTERVIEWS FOR THOSE FIRST
LEVEL AS A SOMEONE STATUS A
DEPUTY AT CHIEF OF OPERATIONS
AMY DISCUSSED- THEY'RE
OCCURRING THIS WEEK SO WE ARE
EXPECTED AND FULLY ON TARGET TO
ENSURE THAT THAT UNIT IS FULLY
STAFFED WITH THE APPROPRIATE.
MANAGEMENT BY THE END OF
NOVEMBER. THANK YOU I JUST WANT
TO HAVE ON RECORD- ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTED OR A DETERMINE
DEADLINES AND GOALS SO THAT
WHEN WE COME INTO BUDGET FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- JUST A FEW
MONTHS FROM NOW. WE'RE ABLE TO
HAVE SOME TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASUREMENTS AS
TO WHERE THE DEPARTMENT IS. AND
THE DIRECTION OF THE EMPLOYMENT
OF STAFF IN CERTAIN AREAS
WHETHER IT'S FRAUD OR LANGUAGE
ACCESS OR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
AB ONE THIRTY EIGHT AGAIN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE-
CONTAINING LANGUAGE ACTIONS
PROVISIONS I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THAT ON
RECORD SO THAT WHEN WE COME
BACK IN A FEW MONTHS FROM NOW.
WE'RE ABLE TO HAVE-
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASUREMENTS AS
TO WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOT WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO OPEN IT UP
TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT- AND AS
WE PREPARE FOR THAT AGAIN I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT. AS WELL
TO THINK ALL OF OUR LEGISLATIVE
STAFF BOTH IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE THAT HAVE TAKEN A
HUGE BURDEN- TO ACTUALLY BE
PART OF THAT. EDT WORK FORCE.
TO HELP WITH CONSTITUENT CASES-
AND REALLY HELPING THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS TO
THE SAFETY NET THAT REALLY
SHOULD. HAVE BEEN FUNCTIONING
BUT CLEARLY WE ARE IN A
DIFFERENT SPACE RIGHT NOW AND
SO I JUST WANT TO. GIVE THEM A
HUGE SHOUT OUT TO BECAUSE THEY
HAVE REALLY BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO ENSURE THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS HAVE RESOURCES AND
ACCESS TO. SOMETHING THAT.
REALLY WAS MUCH NEEDED IN THE
LAST NINETEEN MONTHS. AND AGAIN
THANK YOU TO THE EDT WORK FORCE
AS WELL I KNOW YOU'RE WORKING
WITH A LOT OF. ANTIQUATED IT
SYSTEMS THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CHANGED AND UPDATED YEARS YEARS
AGO AND HAVEN'T AND SO WE'RE IN
A DIFFERENT SPACE NOW SO AGAIN
THANK YOU. UP BEFORE WE GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT I DO WANNA. GIVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IN THE DIOCESE SAYING
FINAL CLOSING REMARKS. BEFORE
WE OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
MS BETWEEN NORTH. ART WELL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND TO
ADD TO IT TO ECHO YOUR THANKS
TO YOU ARE LEGISLATIVE STAFF-
AND TO EVERYONE WHO HAS BEEN
WORKING SO HARD TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS AND THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES I'M IT WAS
GOOD TO HEAR TODAY THAT NOTABLE
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE ON THE
CRITICAL RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE JANUARY. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AUDIT REPORTS- WE'VE ALSO SEEN
THAT SIGNIFICANT WORK DOES
REMAIN TO ENSURE THAT
IMPROVEMENTS ARE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED AND THAT THE IMPACT
OF THESE CHANGES ARE FULLY
REALIZED I LIKE MY COLLEAGUES
WERE HERE TODAY I AM COMMITTED
TO THAT PERSISTENT OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY THAT I KNOW
WE ALL KNOW IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT- THAT
WE MAKE PROGRESS THAT WE
ACTUALLY GET TO COMPLETION ON
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS AND THAT
WE IN SHORT THAT WE'RE NOT
SITTING UP HERE. IN TWENTY
THIRTY TWO REHASHING THE SAME
ISSUES THAT CONVERSATIONS I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS WORK AND TIE
THANK YOU TO THE EDT TEAM ADDS
THAT TO THE OUTER STEAM AS WELL
FOR BEING HERE AND- AND FOR
YOUR COME BACK HALF OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THIS IS
US. THANK YOU MEDICARE JUST
WANTS TO THANK YOU BOTH MATTER
AND I THE MEMBERS ARE SET UP
TODAY FOR TODAY'S HEARING THAT
A LOT OF- MISTER HARRIS THANK
YOU GUYS FOR YOUR- FOR. I
OUTLINING BUT ALSO KEEPING THE
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH THE CHECK
IT'S NOT JUST A THIRTY DAYS TO
SIX MONTHS AND THEN EVENTUALLY
THE YEAR OUT- BECAUSE LIKE.
MADAM CHAIR SAID WE DON'T WANT
TO KEEP HEARING ABOUT THESE
ISSUES AND- FOR THE NEXT TEN
YEARS RIGHT AND I THINK THAT'S
WHY WE WERE SO PERSISTENT ABOUT
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND TIMELINE.
WHERE WE CAN EXPECT THESE OF
REFORMS THESE IMPLEMENTATIONS
SACK HER. AND SO I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING I'M DEFINITELY TAKING
AWAY AS AS WE STOOD UP FOR
SYSTEM OVERSIGHT. THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE ISN'T
GOING OVERSIGHT HEARING. THAT
HELPS MAKE. THINGS HAPPENED IN
THESE DEPARTMENTS AND HELPS
PROVIDE THAT CLARITY FOR
CONSTITUENTS MOVING FORWARD-
LIKE MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES WE
ARE STILL RECEIVING CALLS WE
STILL HAVE THOUSANDS OF CASES
THAT ARE STILL PENDING. SB
FORTY DVD BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE SO
FRUSTRATED PEOPLE STILL NEED
ANSWERS. AND SO WE'RE
DEFINITELY LOOKING FORWARD TO
THAT IT AND- AND I AM
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT SO
THAT WE CAN RESOLVE THIS
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
WE WANT CALIFORNIA TO FUNCTION
BETTER. WE WANT CALIFORNIANS TO
BE SERVED AND WE'RE HERE TO TRY
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN SO THANK
YOU MEDICARE. JACKSON YEAH
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO-
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PARTICULAR
HURDLE VEHICLES ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT- WE'RE STRUGGLING
IN THIS IN THIS DAY AND AGE IS
A BUILDING TRUST WITH OUR
PUBLIC AND I THINK THAT THESE
KIND OF HEARING TO HELP PROVIDE
THE TRANSPARENCY THAT'S CLEARLY
A WARRANTED ON THIS PARTICULAR
ASPECT I STILL REMAINS
SERIOUSLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FOR THE FRAUD PROBLEM I WAS A
LITTLE BIT CONCERNED ALSO ABOUT
THE EXPRESSION. AS IT WAS
SOMEONE EXPLAINED AWAY AS ALL
STATES HAVE THE PROBLEM AND
THAT WE HAVE A STRONG GANG
MEMBER ELEMENT IN THIS FRAUD
WHICH WE MAY HAVE SOME BUT IT'S
WAY BEYOND THAT I WHICH I WOULD
SUBMIT TO YOU THAT THE GANG
ELEMENT IS A SMALL PORTION
COMPARED TO OF THE STATE WIDE
PROBLEM AND- I LOOK FORWARD TO
THIS GROUP THAT'S BEING
ORGANIZED TO FOCUS ON THIS
PROBLEM BECAUSE A- I MEAN IT'S
BEEN SO ENORMOUS ALREADY. BUT
IF WE DON'T ADDRESS IT IN A
MORE SERIOUS WAY IT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE A BIG BIG
PROBLEM. AND THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT- WE'RE LOSING. IS
ENORMOUS THAT ANDERSON
EXCUSABLE IN MY OPINION AND SO.
I HOPE WE TAKE IT SERIOUSLY I
LOOK FORWARD TO- WATCH INDIA'S
STATISTICS AND- AND IMPROVE
SITUATIONAL ON THIS ASPECT SO
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME BE
PART. THANK YOU MR LIKE IN
AGAIN THANK YOU TO ALL THE
MEMBERS HERE TODAY AND A
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS- STAFF ON
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW AND STAFF
AT GILLETTE AS WELL FOR ALL OF
YOUR HARD WORK AND- A
COMMITMENT TO THIS EFFORT. SIR
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WAITING ON
THE MICROPHONE FOR A BIT PLEASE
GO AHEAD FOR PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
HAVE ONE MINUTE. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS KEVIN AS
THEM WITH THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS. IN THIS HEARING
IS VITALLY NEEDED WE REALLY
SHOULD SAY THAT- I WORK WITH
LEGAL SERVICES ORGANIZATIONS.
AND ADD BASICALLY THE JUROR
ALLERGIC. TO COMMUNITY AND PUT.
WE HAVE A WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH PARTNERS SOCIAL
SERVICES. DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES WE ABOUT THE MEETINGS
WITH THEM. EVERY POLICY THAT
THE ADOPTIVE BROTHER THROUGH
US. WITH THE DID DID WE HAD A
MEETING ABOUT A YEAR AGO. WE
PICKED UP FIFTEEN ISSUES ON THE
TABLE. INTO THIS STATE. WE HAD
A MEETING WITH THE MEN IN THE
MEETING WE HAD. WAS WITH THE
SYSTEMS OF DARCY THROUGHS. AND
SEES THAT THE AUTHORITY THROUGH
HIS WORK WITH. THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE. INTO THIS STATE THEY
SAID THEY'RE GOING TO GET BACK
TO ASSEMBLY. RESIDUALS. WE
HAVEN'T HEARD NOTHING. AND WE
ALSO HAVE THAT THE CA SHOULD. A
MONTHLY. REPORTS ABOUT THE CALL
CENTERS WHAT DID ALL THIS DATA
TO TALK ABOUT WE HAVE A SEAT
THE SHOULD BE POSTED ON THE
WEBPAGE. THEY SHOULD ALSO GIVE
MY MONTHLY PROGRESS REPORTS. AS
TO HOW THE IMPLEMENTING-
DAUGHTER TO GENERAL'S REPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU SIR MUCH
APPRECIATED WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE PHONE
LINES OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY
CALLS. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
TWO IN Q. WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. TAKING MY CALL MY
NAME IS SELENA. LYFT MALL
BUSINESS OWNERS SACRAMENTO AREA.
OVER THE YEARS THAT. UNDER
PREPARED TO KILL THE HUGE
RECALL CAMBRIDGE OUT OF THE
BUSINESS CLOSURES GET OUT OF
PEOPLE WHO YES IT'S NOT ALLOWED
TO WORK SHOULD AFFECT THE
COURSE NOT PART OF I'M GONNA.
YEAH WHAT THE MILLION JOBS
CALIFORNIA CURRENT ACCOUNT FOR
OVER 30% OF UNEMPLOYMENT. WITH
ALL THE PLANNING DEPARTMENT
PROJECTS MEASURES WHAT IS
CURRENTLY BEING DONE TO ADDRESS
ALREADY TAKEN QUITE BUT AFTER
BEING TAKEN RECOVER BILLIONS OF
BILLIONS OF THAT PARTY PAID OUT.
THANK YOU OPERATOR WE LOSE CALL
OR AT THE END. I BELIEVE WE MAY
HAVE LOST THE INDIVIDUAL- LIKE
TO GO BACK IN THE QUEUE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
WANT TO ONE NUMBER FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE
FORTY FIVE CAN I BE HEARD IN
THE- COMMITTEE HEARING ABOUT
EDT I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I'M
IN THE RIGHT PLACE. OUR MINDS
ARE ALWAYS WORK. CAN BE HEARD
MANY COMMITTEE YOUR ON YOUR AT
THE RIGHT PLACE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE- EXCELLENT.
YOU KNOW THIS IS REALLY A
FASCINATING SAYING THAT THE
VERY ENTITY. THAT PAID OUT ALL
THIS MONEY IN FRAUD IN THE TENS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. IS NOW
BEING ENTRUSTED TO POLICE
ITSELF WITH A FRAUD UNIT.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED MORE
INCOMPETENT AGENCIES POLICING
THEMSELVES LIFE IN CALIFORNIA
IS TRULY LIKE LIVING IN A BLACK
HOLE OF WASTE AND CORRUPTION
AND WE THE PEOPLE APPARENTLY
ARE EXPECTED TO KEEP PAYING FOR
IT. THAT BEING SAID I WANT TO
REFERENCE ON OCTOBER TWENTY
FIRST- MERCURY NEWS ARTICLE
CALIFORNIA WORKERS FILED THE
MOST INITIAL CLAIMS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS IN SIX
MONTHS. A HUGE WEEKLY TOTAL
REVEALED ON THURSDAY LAST WEEK
THAT SUGGESTS CORONAVIRUS
LINKED WOES STILL AFFLICT THE
STATE WIDE ECONOMY WORKERS
STATEWIDE STYLED. EIGHTY
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED. FIRST
TIME UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS DURING
THE WEEK THAT ENDED ON OCTOBER
SIXTEENTH WHICH WAS UP FROM
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
WE NEED TO DO RATHER AMENITIES
THAT PRIOR. WHEN IS A JOKE YOU
PEOPLE PONTIFICATE FOR. A
CHANGE ONLY HUNDRED UP SAYS
DISCONNECT THE CALL. ANY
ADDITIONAL CALLS. I REMEMBER
NEXT OPEN UP LIKE NEVER FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
THANK YOU FOR TAKING MY CALL
I'M CALLING AS A- TAX PAYER AND
I JUST WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU
TOO MY CONCERN ABOUT- THE
QUESTION. ABOUT WHY CALIFORNIA
IS A HAS A HIGHER UNEMPLOYMENT-
WHERE PEOPLE ARE NOT WORKING
AND I WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU
MY THOUGHTS ON THAT. THERE
THERE IS NO INCENTIVE FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO GO TO WORK THEY
MAKE MORE MONEY STAYING HOME
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF
DRAWING THE STIMULUS PAYMENTS.
THAT P. Y. OR P. WAY PAYMENT.
GETTING RELIEF FOR THAT HAVE TO
PAY THE RENT THEIR POWER NOT
BEING WHAT IS THE- WE GIVEN
THEM A CRIED SO THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO GO TO WORK WHEN YOU
TAKE ALL THESE THINGS THE WAY.
IT WILL BENEFIT THEIR FAMILY TO
GO TO WORK THEY'LL MAKE. MORE
MONEY WORKING THAN STAYING HOME
RIGHT NOW THEY MAKE MORE MONEY
STAYING HOMES AND WORKING AND
THAT'S YOUR PROBLEM. AND THEN
EDT WILL NOT HAVE SO MANY
PAYMENT CLAIMS TO MAKE OUT AND
IT'LL GET BACK TO NORMAL.
THAT'S JUST MY OPINION THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING STRIDES HAVE
A WONDERFUL DAY. THANK YOU
MA'AM. ANY ADDITIONAL CALLS.
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO
LAUGHTER GOOD AFTERNOON. SURE
MEMBERS AND- CHAIR CLEANED SURE
ARE MANY MATURE NONCHALANTLY
CONFIRMED THERE. ARE CALLING IN
REGARDS TO. THE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE CURRENT STATE FROM
VARIOUS IQALUIT. AND OUR
APPRECIATE KEVIN KILEY BRINGING
UP- SOME OF HIS POINTS EXPLORER.
EIGHTY PLANNING ON DURING
STORAGE TRAINING- INDIVIDUAL.
TO- OVERSEE AND OBVIOUSLY-
APPROPRIATORS- YOU KNOW CHECK
OUT WHAT- WORKING IN THOSE
THINGS- I'M I'M I'M VERY
CONCERNED AS TO WHAT. ET
CONSIDERS IT APPROPRIATE
TRAINING PERIOD TIME- ARE WE
TALKING A WEEKEND COURSE ARE WE
TALKING YOU KNOW THREE THREE
FOUR WEEKS TO GET THEM PLOY I
NEED TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE-
WORKLOADS- VERY CONCERNING TO
KNOW YOU HAVE TEN SECONDS BUT-
IT WILL- VERY CONCERNING AND
WE- DRESSED I ALSO ADDRESS THE
FACT THAT MAYBE WE SHOULD ALSO
AND- CHECK WITH THE DMV AS FAR
AS- YOU KNOW WHERE PEOPLE LIVE
ADDRESSES AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE WITH THEM WE NEED TO
READ ON YOUR ARGUMENT IT. WHAT
OKAY WE'RE GOING- E. R. ET
TEACHER TWO PEOPLE ARE OUR
CARDS TO PEOPLE WE NEED TO
REALLY- FIND OUT WHERE. YOU'RE
ACTUALLY LIVING WITH THAT ARE
NOT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
UNDERWRITER LET ON TO THE NEXT
CALLER. LINE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SALLY
CHANG AND I AM A CALIFORNIA
POLICY MANAGER WITH THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER SIERRA. WORKERS WITH
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY
HAVE THE RIGHT TO ACCESS
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE AND PAID
FAMILY LEAVE- BUT DESPITE THE
EXPANSION TO LANGUAGE SERVICES
THAT WERE MENTIONED BY THE EDT
REPRESENTATIVE THERE ARE STILL
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO ACCESS
FOR THE COMMUNITY. THEY MUST
HAVE SOME WAY TO APPLY AND GET
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED
WHETHER OVER THE PHONE OR
DURING TRANSLATION- CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO THE NATION'S LARGEST
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY
POPULATION OF THE TOP ELEVEN
LANGUAGES SPOKEN IN THE STATE
API LANGUAGES MAKE UP SEVEN OF
THE ELEVEN LANGUAGES. FOR
SMALLER ASIAN AMERICAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LANGUAGE GROUPS SUCH
AS THE SOUTHEAST ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY OVER 90% THE LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH AT HOME AND
45% OUR LANGUAGE OUR LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT- THE VERY
FAILURE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
FLING WITH LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AS THE DIRE
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT THEY NOW
FACE. DEPRIVE INCLEMENT WEATHER
SOLD THORTON AND COMPANY TO
ECONOMIC PRESSURES OF RENT AND
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS FOOD AND
CHILD AND ELDER CARE- THE EDT
MUSCOVITE NON MACHINE
TRANSLATION FOR ALL ON ONLINE
APPLICATION PORTALS FOR ALL
BENEFIT PROGRAM. EDT MUST ALSO
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF LANGUAGE
SPECIFIC PHONE LINE
PROFESSIONAL FROM MY
COLLABORATORS TO ENSURE REAL
TIME SERVICES FOR BENEFIT
APPLICANTS APPLICATION OR CLAIM
QUESTIONS- RIGHT NOW PROFESSOR.
THANK AND APPLE MY NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LET ME. ATTY YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME CATHOLIC BRIBIE PLASTER
COUNTY AND I JUST WANNA GIVE A
BIG SHOUT OUT THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY WOMAN MEGAN DOLLY FROM
DISTRICT ONE AND HER TEAM. TO
HELP ME GET SEVERAL MONTHS BACK
PAYMENTS OWED TO ME BY THE EDT.
I WOULD REFORM THE ID MI SYSTEM
WAS VERY INEFFICIENT AND NOT
USER FRIENDLY IT WAS ALSO VERY
INVASIVE. PERHAPS YOU SHOULD
REVERT TO IN PERSON APPLYING
THE DRIVER'S LICENSE AND PROOF
OF ID. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING MY RECOMMENDATION
TO GET BACK IN PERSON BUSINESS.
OUT THERE WILL BE SO MUCH FOR
US. THANK YOU NEXT COLOR. AND
BEFORE WE OPEN MY NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT AS A REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ZERO FOR PUBLIC COMMENT LIKE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME ST
LOUIS ON BEHALF OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO FOR
BRINGING UP THE TRAILER BILL
ONE. AB ONE THIRTY EIGHT IN
REGARDS THE EXPANDING LANGUAGE
ACCESS. AB ONE THIRTY
REPRESENTED A FIRST STEP
TOWARDS TRUE LANGUAGE ACCESS
BUT WE NEED TO LEARN THE
SPECIFICS ON WHAT IS BEING
DONE. TO IMPLEMENT IT AND
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD- MORE
COMPLETE SOLUTIONS. CURRENTLY
WRITTEN TRANSLATIONS ARE OFTEN
NOT AVAILABLE AND ARE
UNIFORMLY. DIFFICULT TO ACCESS
WE HOPE THAT YOU DD WILL
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN ORDER TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS WITH LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY. HAVE
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS. SHOULD THEY NEED IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT COLOR
AND I HOPE MY NUMBER FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. YES HELLO MY
NAME IS CHARGING RAMREE FROM
CALLING FROM CREAMY CENTERPIECE
FAITHFUL SERVICE PROVIDING
CENTER THAT WE SERVE FOLKS ALL
OVER THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
GRITTY CALIFORNIA I DO WANT TO
STAND WITH AND THANK OUR
PARTNERS AT CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC. HEALTH NETWORK IN
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE CENTER-
MEDICAL THEY'RE CALLED- WE DO
WANT TO- ECHOED THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
INSTEAD A STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE THIS- IN ADDITION TO
ALL OF EDIE'S PROGRAM HAS BEEN-
VASTLY- DIFFICULT TO ACCESS AND
HAS BEEN VERY DIFFICULT. FOR
OUR CLIENTS TO- WE GET FOR- WE
ALSO WANT JUST LIFT UP ON ONE
OF OUR CLIENTS AND- OUR CLIENTS
A SEVENTY FIVE YEAR OLD
ELDERLY- PERSON IN OAKLAND. WHO
HAS BEEN RECEIVING THE- YOU AYE
AND- THE CALL THAT YOU I AND
CHIEF JUSTICE PLEASE WITH ET DE
THAT THE WAITING TIME AND SHE
DOES THANKS- YOU FOR A READY
DOING THE CHANGES. AND HIRING
BUT SHE ASKS THAT YOU ALSO LOOK
INTO HIRING- MORE CULTURALLY
DIVERSE AND COMPETENT FOLKS WHO
ARE ABLE TO A SISTER MORE IN A
TIMELY MATTER SHE HAS BEEN
GETTING A LOT OF. CONFUSING AND
CONTRADICTING INFORMATION FOR
ME A REPRESENTATIVE AND HAS
JUST ADDED HOURS AND HOURS ON
FOR HER TO GET HER ON ISSUES-
RESOLVED- SHE ALSO RECOMMENDS
RATHER. COMMON OVER A MINUTE.
CHAU RECORD THAT THERE IS MORE
FOR AND TEXT- AND OTHER
ACCESSIBLE AND I THINK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. AND AT THE TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU OPERATOR. AND WITH NO
ADDITIONAL FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE ROOM ARE ON THE
PHONE. THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.